COMMITTEE ON FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE WE WELCOME YOU TO
THE FORTY SIXTH ANNUAL ZEKE
GRADER FISHERIES FORM THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
I WANNA START OUT WITH AN
APOLOGY I APOLOGIZE FOR CERTAIN
A BIT LATE --
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SEASON IS
UPON US --
AND HAVE BEEN IN BUDGET --
SUBCOMMITTEE SINCE TEN IT'S
STILL GOING AND I DO WANT TO LET
FOLKS KNOW I'M GONNA HAVE TO
LEAVE COMMITTEE MOMENTARILY
TURNED OVER TO OUR VERY PEOPLE
VICE CHAIR TO BE ABLE TO GO COM --
FINISH VOTING IN BUDGET SUB IS
WELL.
HI MY NAME'S MIKE MCGUIRE AND
I'M HONORED TO BE CHAIR OF THIS%
JOINT COMMITTEE TO BE TO WORK
WITH THESE TWO FINE GENTLEMEN OR
UP HERE AS WELL AND I APPRECIATE.
YOU TAKING TIME IN YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULES WE WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THINK ALL OF THE
VOLUNTEERS FOR THEIR HARD WORK
AT THE ANNUAL RECEPTION LAST
NIGHT.
IT WAS AN AMAZING SHOWCASE OF
THE GOLDEN STATE'S SEAFOOD
BOUNTY AND WE'RE GONNA STEP OUT
OF WHAT WE TYPICALLY DO AND GIVE
THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE PLEASE.
WE WANT TO WELCOME A ALL
FISHERMEN WHO TRAVELED FROM
EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE TO
THIS TIME HONORED TRADITION. FOR
FORTY SIX YEARS EACH OF
CALIFORNIA'S FISHERIES SPECIFIC
COMMITTEES ORGANIZATIONS
ASSOCIATIONS COUNCILS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR FISHERMEN
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE AND
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IN ANNUAL
REPORT ON THEIR NEDS GOALS
YEARLY ACTIVITIES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
THE JOINT COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
QUITE BUSY THE LAST SINCE THE
LAST TIME WE ALL MET.
WE HEARD FROM ALL OF YOU ABOUT
THE NEED FOR DISASTER RELIEF IN
SUCCESSFULLY SECURED DECORATIONS
FOR CRAB SALMON AND SARDINES.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO HEAR ABOUT
THE STATUS OF THESE FUNDS WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE FOCUSED ON
SECURING A FEDERAL DECLARATION
FOR THE RED SEA URCHIN.
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR GOVERNOR
NEWSOME SWIFT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE'RE NOT DONE UNTIL THOSE
FEDERAL DOLLARS START FLOWING
INTO THE GOLDEN STATE.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN MOVING I FISHERY
RELATED LEGISLATION OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS WE HAVE ENACTED
LEGISLATION FOR WELDING
COMMENCING CRAPPER TRIPLE THE
CRAB FISHERY SALMON STEEL.
ANCHOVIES HALIBUT.
AQUA CULTURE IN MORE WE'VE BEEN
ACTIVE ENGAGE WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU ALL THROUGHOUT
THESE PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
IN TODAY WITH AN OVER THE NEXT
YEAR WE'RE GONNA BE FOCUSING ON
STREAMLINING PERMANENT FOR THE
OPERA CULTURE INDUSTRY AND
MITIGATING ANY POTENTIAL IMPACTS
OF OFFSHORE WIND HAS ON OUR
OCEAN ECOSYSTEMS.
IN FISHERIES YOU WERE GOING TO
BE SEEN A HEARING COMING UP IN
MAY WHICH WILL BE HOSTING IN THE
BEAUTIFUL COUNTY OF HUMBLE WILL
ALSO BE ADVANCING FOR THE SECOND
TIME A FISHERIES ON THIS BILL
LATER THIS YEAR.
THIS SEASON WE ARE FORTUNATE TO
HAVE AN ABUNDANCE OF WATER BUT
WE ARE STILL SUFFERING FROM THE
IMPACTS OF CALIFORNIA'S EXTENDED
DROUGHT.
POUR WATER MANAGEMENT THAT
KILLED MORE THAN 95% OF BABY
SALMON ALONG WITH LOUSY OCEAN
CONDITIONS CREATED A PERFECT
STORM OF SOUND SALMON KILLING
EVENTS.
THESE LIMITATIONS DRAMATICALLY
IMPACT OUR ECONOMY ALONG THE
ENTIRE WEST COAST ALL THE WAY UP
TO CANADA.
BUT SOME GOOD NEWS WE'RE TURNING
THAT SHIP AROUND BUT WE ARE
STILL FAR FROM A FULL PRODUCTIVE
SEASON FOR COMMERCIAL
RECREATIONAL INTRACTABLE SALMON
FISHERMEN.
IN WHILE WE SEEN IMPROVEMENT WE
STILL NEED ANOTHER YEAR OR TWO
OF GOOD CONDITIONS TO BE ABLE TO
REBUILD OUR STUFF.
OUR NUMBER ONE GOAL HERE TODAY
IS TO HEAR FROM ALL OF YOU HEAR
FROM YOU ABOUT THE ISSUES INTO
WAYS RAISE AWARENESS.
THE PRECARIOUS STATE OF OUR
FISHERIES AND EDUCATE THE
LEGISLATURE RESIDENTS ABOUT
THEIR STATUS THREATS IN SUCCESS
WE HAVE AN ALL STAR LINE OF OUR
PANELISTS TODAY BUT BEFORE WE
GET INTO IT WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER. TO OUR VICE
CHAIR PRICE YOUR STONE FROM THE
STATE ASSEMBLY ON OFFER A HEARTY
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE VICE
CHAIR BEING RE APPOINTED.
BY THE SPEAKER AND I JUST WANNA
SAY MISTER VICE YOUR LOOK FOR TO
THE NEXT A4 YEARS.
THANK YOU ALTHOUGH WE ONLY SIR
FOR TWO SO LET'S NOT GET AHEAD
OF OURSELVES WE WE IN THE
ASSEMBLY DO NOT HAVE THE BENEFIT.
I WANT TO WELCOME YOU ALL HERE
TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
I KNOW FOR MOST OF THE FOLKS IN
THIS ROOM YOU WOULD MUCH RATHER
BE ON THE WATER.
THEN IN SACRAMENTO AND
ESPECIALLY IN A LEGISLATIVE
HEARING.
BUT IF I LOOK AT AND SPECIALLY
OUT OF THE LAST TWO YEARS WITH
UNDER CHERUB MCGUIRE.
THE STRIDES WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
MAKE TO BRIDGE SOME OF THE GAPS
AND BE ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER ON
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT.
SUPPORT THE FISHERY SUPPORT THE
GOALS THAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND REALLY ACROSS THE SPECTRUM
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THAT
SOMETHING TO TAKE PRIDE IN.
IT'S NOT BEEN A PERFECT JOURNEY
BY IT'S A JOURNEY THAT I KNOW
WE'VE BEEN TAKEN AS MORE OF A
PARTNERSHIP THAT HAS HAPPENED IN
THE PAST.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT SO WE'LL ALL LOOK FOR
TO A TO A GOOD HEARING TODAY.
AND WITH THE GOOD INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE AND THE FACT THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS NOW REACHED
OUT AND BEEN WILLING TO HOLD
HEARINGS IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE.
AND AT OTHER TIMES OF THE YEAR
SO THAT WE CAN TIMELY ADDRESS
THE ISSUES THAT COME UP WITH THE
FISHING INDUSTRY SOMETHING THAT
IS CRITICAL ABSOLUTELY TO
CALIFORNIA.
SO LOOK FOR TO THE INFORMATION
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET TODAY
AND I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU
BEING HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH BY
SHEER.
WE'RE ALSO REALLY EXCITED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A SIMILAR DOLLY
HERE WE'RE HOPING THAT HE'S
GONNA BE JOINING US IN THE
SENATE HERE --
IN A FEW WEEKS IN AND TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO YOU MISTER DALI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VICE
CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR SHOWING UP TODAY I
JUST WANTED.
TO KIND OF MAYBE USE A SPRING
BOARD OF OUR NEW SECRETARY
TALKED ABOUT LAST NIGHT --
AS YOU KNOW NONE OF MY DISTRICT
TOUCHES THE OCEAN --
DIRECTLY BUT INDIRECTLY IT DOES --
BY REPRESENT --
CLASS INCLUDE THIS YEAR A BEAUT
[inaudible]
PLASTER NEVADA --
IT AND BUT WE HAVE THE ORVILLE
WE HAVE SHASTA DAM AND WE HAVE
THE BIGGEST --
WATERSHED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH A IS THE
HABITAT AND RIGHT.
AREAS -- FOR
FISH IN WATER AND CLEAN SOURCE
WATER BUT I WANT TO JUST SHARE A
THAT MAYBE AT SOME POINT WE
SHOULD --
TALK ABOUT.
THE STATE OF YOU KNOW
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE LAST YEAR
WE BURNED ONE POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES.
AND THAT'S THE WATERSHED --
THAT FEEDS THE STREAMS AND AND
RIVERS THAT ALLOW --
YOU HABITAT FOR THE FISH THAT
EVENTUALLY ENDS UP IN THE OCEAN
AND AND CRATES OCEAN HABITAT AS
WELL.
SO JUST WANTED TO TOUCH ON THAT
AND IT'S NOT AN ORIGIN I KNOW
BUT HOPEFULLY WE TALK ABOUT THAT
I KNOW THAT.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FIRE
AND AND IT'S OVER THE LAST SIX
YEARS SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THIS
FAMILY AND WE'VE SEEN.
OF THE LARGEST FIRES IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY AND WHAT IT'S
DOING TO THE HABITAT AND
WILDLIFE IT'S OUT THERE ACTUALLY
THE BILL THIS YEAR IS ONE OF THE
LET YOU ALL KNOW THAT I'M
RUNNING A BILL TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND GAME.
TO QUANTIFY THE HABITAT AND
WILDLIFE --
THAT WE'VE LOST --
IN DUE TO FIRE AND SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY CAN START GAUGING THAT
AND FIGURING OUT WHAT THE THE
PUBLIC COST IS TO THAT SO --
THE FOUR DOOR HEARING IN --
APPRECIATE BEING ON THE
COMMITTEE AS A MEMBER WHO
DOESN'T ACTUALLY HAVE --
DEPARTMENT ISSUE THAT TOUCHES
THE OCEAN BUT I DO INDIRECTLY
AND LOVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH TO SEND
WOMEN AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK --
IN YOUR AFFIX HIM WE HAVE HAD TO
RESOURCES ACROSS THE STATE.
THERE'S GENERALLY NOW WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO GET INTO THE
HEARING AND AGAIN WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU ALL OF YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
I IT IT IS BEEN A TRADITION THAT
THE SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES KICKS OFF FOR HEARING
ALONG WITH THE DIRECTOR OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE WE'RE GONNA WELCOME
BOTH GENTLEMEN TO BE A COME UP
TO THE DICE AT THIS TIME.
WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM MR
WADE CROWFOOT SECRETARY THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCE
AGENCY.
THE SECRETARY --
EASE IS GOING TO BE FOCUSING
THESE FISHERIES PRIORITIES FOR
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FOR
FISHERIES AQUACULTURE AND AN
OVERALL FOCUS ON CLIMATE CHANGE
AND WHAT THAT MEANS TO FISHERIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
WE'RE ALSO GRATEFUL THAT MISTER
CHUCK BONHAM IS HERE TODAY HE'S
A DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH WILDLIFE.
THE DIRECTOR IS GOING TO BE
DOING A BIT OF A DEEP DIVE ON
HIS PRIORITIES IN HE DEPARTMENT
PRIORITIES FOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN FOCUSING ON DUNGENESS
CRAB FISHING.
WHALE TANGLED WITH THE PROGRESS
OF THE WORKING GROUP HE'S ALSO
GOING TO BE GIVEN AS A SNEAK
PREVIEW ON THE SALMON SEASON.
AS WELL AS A BIT OF A GAUGE OF
WHAT IT'S LOOKING LIKE ON THE
KLAMATH RIVER IN THE SPRING TION
OF LISTING.
WE'RE GRATEFUL BOTH THE
GENTLEMAN TO BE HERE TODAY
SECRETARY AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS
ON BEHALF THE JOINT COMMITTEE WE
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH YOU.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR YOU HAVE
TEN MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
ONE MINUTE PROMPT AND THEN WE'LL
THEN TURNED OVER TO THE DIRECTOR
IT WILL HOLD ON QUESTIONS UNTIL
BOTH.
AT THE GENTLEMAN A COMPLETE
THEIR COMMENTS FORESHORES GREAT
THANKS SO MUCH CHAIR FOR THE
INVITATION TO BE HERE THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY MY FIRST.
APPEARANCE OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE BUT TRADITION THAT I
HOPE TO MAINTAIN AS SECRETARY OF
THE NATURIST ARSES AGENCY --
REALLY AND AND HAVE AN
ATTENDANCE RECORD THAT IS A 100%
SO.
HOLD ME ACCOUNTABLE HI TO THAT
OR NEAR THAT --
THE OPPORTUNITY LAST NIGHT FOR
MANY OF US TO ACTUALLY MEET --
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
FISHERIES INDUSTRY FISHING
INDUSTRY WAS REALLY VALUABLE.
AND IT DROVE HOME.
A REALLY IMPORTANT POINT TWO
REALLY IMPORTANT POINTS TO ME
THE FIRST IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
ACTUALLY THOSE WHO MAKE THEIR
LIVING -- ON
THE WATER ACTUALLY COMING UP
HERE IN TALKING TO POLICY MAKERS --
THAT'S CRITICAL SO I WANT TO
THANK THE PEOPLE BEHIND ME FOR
ACTUALLY TAKING TIME OUT OF
THEIR WORK LIVES --
IN GIVING YOU KNOW REVENUE IT
ACTUALLY BE UP HERE AND TO MAKE
THEIR VOICES HEARD WHICH RELATES
TO MY SECOND POINT WHICH IS.
YEAH THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE THIS
DAY TODAY NO THIS RESOURCE
BETTER THAN MOST OF US.
AND ARE IMPACTED BY THIS
RESOURCE BETTER THAN MOST OF US.
NOT HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO SOME
FOLKS --
LAST NIGHT THEY SAID LOOK.
IF YOU CUT A SEASON OFF YOU KNOW
TWO MONTHS --
YOU CUT TWO MONTHS AFTER SEASON
THAT IMPACTS.
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF OUR
ANNUAL SALARY OUR TAKE HOME.
SO YOU KNOW THESE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND REGULATIONS AND RULES YOU
KNOW I HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF OF OF OUR FISHING
COMMUNITIES IN WAYS THAT I THINK
WE JUST ALWAYS HAVE TO KEEP
FIRST AND FOREMOST IN OUR MIND.
ARE SO IT'S A REALLY HELPFUL
REMINDER --
AND THEN JUST --
YOU KNOW INVOKE BILL GREIDER WHO
YOU KNOW I THINK IT HELPED
INITIATE THIS --
JOINT COMMITTEE IN OVER FORTY
YEARS AGO AND THEN A SON ZEKE
IT'S A PRETTY AMAZING AND PROUD
TRADITION OF NOT ONLY IN.
OUR FISHING COMMUNITIES BUT
THEY'RE ABBA SO LET ME JUST AT
THE VERY HIGH LEVEL.
YOU KNOW SHARE WITH YOU WHY I
THINK -- THE
FISHERIES ARE VALUABLE TO OUR
STATE -- AS
I START THIS WORK I MEAN CLEARLY
I THEIR ECONOMIC LIFEBLOOD FOR
MANY COMMUNITIES FROM SAN DIEGO
OPERA CRESCENT CITY.
I AND SO KEEPING THIS RESOURCE
VIABLE AND KEEPING THIS INDUSTRY
VIABLE IS CRITICAL TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
SECONDLY I YOU KNOW KEEPING THIS
RESOURCE VIABLE AND KEEPING OUR
FISHERIES HEALTHY IS CRITICAL
FROM AN ENVIRONMENTAL
PERSPECTIVE.
TO CALIFORNIA IS BLAST BY SO
MUCH IN TERMS OF ITS ITS NATURAL
SYSTEMS NATURAL ENVIRONMENT
FISHERIES ARE NO EXCEPTION.
WE ARE REMARKABLE BIO DIVERSITY
I AND WE HAVE A CHARACTER OF OUR
FISHERIES SORT OF WRIT LARGE
THAT IS ALMOST UNIQUE IN THE
WORLD -- SO
IT'S OBVIOUSLY CRITICAL AND IN
THE CULTURAL ASPECT OF OUR
FISHERIES NOT ONLY TO THOSE --
SOVEREIGN NATIONS YOU KNOW THAT
HAVE BEEN HARVESTING THE
RESOURCE.
FOR MILLENNIA BUT FOR OUR
IDENTITY AS CALIFORNIANS.
I MEAN WE YOU KNOW WILL PRESIDE
OVER REGULATIONS THAT KEEPS
SPECIES HEALTHY THAT I'VE BEEN
RETURNING TO CERTAIN TRIBUTARIES
OF THE SACRAMENTO FOR TEN
THOUSAND YEARS.
AND THAT AS CALIFORNIANS WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL PLACE TO LIVE WE TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW THAT THE THE
SEAFOOD INDUSTRY AND THE OCEAN
AND OUR WATER WAYS SO IT'S
ESSENTIAL TO ALL THAT WE DO.
CLEARLY HUGE CHALLENGES THAT
WERE CONTENDING WITH --
ONE OF WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
CLIMATE CHANGE.
I AM AS I UNDERSTAND IT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS HAVING A MAJOR IMPACT
ON THE OCEANS --
WHICH IS HAVING IMPACT ON THE
FISHERIES IN ACIDIFICATION.
IS WREAKING HAVOC HI IF YOU'RE
SHELLFISH FARMER IT MEANS IT
IMPACTS ON YOUR YIELDS --
IF YOUR CRAB FISHERMEN IT MEANS
YOU'RE SEES AND MAY HAVE BEEN
CLOSED -- BY
IT WAS CLOSED A COUPLE YEARS AGO
AS A RESULT OF DEMONIC ACID
WHICH HAS A CONNECTION.
TO OUR CLIMATE CHANGE.
HI AND THEN IMPACTING MIGRATION
PATTERNS OF MARINE MAMMALS I AND
CHALLENGING THAT KIND OF THE
USUAL --
HARVEST OF OF CRAP ANOTHER
FISHERIES.
BUT THEN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
DOLLIES POINT --
LET'S NOT ONLY FORGET OUR LET'S
NOT FORGET I SHOULD SAY THAT
WE'RE WE'RE NOT ONLY TALKING
ABOUT THE OCEANS BUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OUR WATERWAYS AND
OUR HEADWATERS.
AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT --
FISHERIES IN THE FUTURE I WANT
TO INTEGRATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES --
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
CAL FIRE WHICH YOU WOULDN'T
NORMALLY N. C. IMPACTING
FISHERIES BUT YOU CAN BAT --
THAT OUR FORESTS ARE IN CRISIS
AND THEY HAVE A REAL IMPACT ON
OUR WATERSHEDS NOT ONLY THE
SUPPLY OF WATER TO COMMUNITIES.
BUT NOT THE SUPPLY WATER THAT
PROVIDES CRITICAL HABITAT FOR
THE FISHERIES.
SO I'M REALLY X. EXCITED AND
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE WE
CONNECT THESE DOTS IN TERMS OF
OUR RESOURCE MANAGEMENT.
AND WE DON'T TREAT OCEANS AND
FRESH WATER AND FORESTS
SEPARATELY IN SEPARATE SILOS BUT
WE INTEGRATE --
AND IT'S IT'S COMPLICATED BUT
IT'S ESSENTIAL --
MOVING FORWARD.
YOU KNOW I'M I'M COMMITTED TO
SPENDING TIME ARE REQUIRED TO
ROLL UP SLEEVES AND ADDRESS
CHALLENGES --
THAT WE'RE FACING WHETHER IT'S
ACTUALLY GETTING --
EMERGENCY.
DISASTER FUNDING FOR THE CLOSURE
OF CRAB SEASON THREE FROM THREE
YEARS AGO STILL WORKING ON THAT --
OR IF IT'S AGAIN ROLLING UP
SLEEVES WITH YOU KNOW ON ON
REGULATORY QUESTIONS ARE
CHALLENGES AS THEY ARISE --
I WANT TO BE THE KIND OF LEADER
AT THE RESOURCES AGENCY THAT
SUPPORTS MY DEPARTMENTS TO DO
GOOD WORK AND THE PROBLEM SOLVE
WITH LEGISLATORS.
AND STAKEHOLDERS LIKE LIKE
FISHING INDUSTRY AS PROBLEMS
ARISE --
ALAS WE SAY I WANT TO THANK OUR
DIRECTOR BONG WITH --
CHUCK FOR FIVE YEARS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION --
WHEN I WASN'T WORKING ON NATURAL
RESOURCES ISSUES WHEN I WAS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND I CAN
TELL YOU --
HE WAS THE VOICE FOR FISHERIES
OVER THAT FIVE YEARS IN SOME
DIFFICULT TIMES WITH THE CRAB
CLOSURE AND ETCETERA AND IN MOST
OF WHAT I'VE LEARNED IN
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES I'VE
LEARNED FROM SHOCK SO.
LOOKING FOR DINNER TO WORKING
WITH HIM AND BEGAN INTEGRATING
THESE OTHER DEPARTMENTS WITH MY
WITHIN MY AGENCY INTO THIS
DISCUSSION ON FISHERIES --
AND THEN LASTLY I'LL I'LL REPEAT
A POINT THAT WAS MADE LAST NIGHT
WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE YOU KNOW ALL OF OUR FISHING
INDUSTRIES HAVE TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION AND THEY HAVE TO BE
AT THE CENTER OF THE DISCUSSIONS --
ABOUT -- HOW
WE STEWARD THIS RESOURCE BECAUSE
THE DECISIONS WE MAKE IN
SACRAMENTO I HAVE REAL IMPACT ON
THEIR LIVELIHOODS AND ON THEIR
COMMUNITIES?
YOU ALL KNOW THIS WHICH IS WHY
YOU'RE ON THE JOINT COMMITTEE
BUT I DO THINK IT'S IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
FIND WAYS TO GIVE --
YOU KNOW THIS INDUSTRY AND
ASSOCIATIONS REPRESENTING IT A
MEANINGFUL HOW TO IDENTIFY
SOLUTION THROUGH THESE
CHALLENGES --
SO I'M EXCITED TO BE HERE I'M
EXCITED --
TO SYMBOLIZE OR AT LEAST I AM.
VERBALIZE --
MY COMMITMENT AND THENI'M MOST
EXCITED ABOUT DEMONSTRATING AND
PROVING THAT COMMITMENT OVER
TIME INTO THIS JOB THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE SECTOR
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE
AND WE LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH YOU
HERE IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS TO
COME SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING TIME YOU BUSY SCHEDULE
AND WILL HOLD COMMENTS UNTIL --
DIRECTOR BOTTOM --
IT COMPLETES HIS COMIC STRIP BAR
ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR TEN
MINUTES AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING TO ACER'S COULD YOU
SEE THAT THANK YOU TO OUR
CULTURE.
MEMBERS HAD THESE ISSUES WE'RE
GOING TO DISCUSS OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE HOURS ARE PERSONAL TO ME.
I'VE SPENT MY WHOLE PROFESSIONAL
LIFE FOCUSED ON THEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I THINK THEIR PERSONAL TO
YOU AND EVERYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM.
SO MY NAME IS CHUCK BOTTOM ON
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
WHICH I STILL THINK IS THE
GREATEST JOB IN THE WORLD.
MY FIRST SHOT OUT GOES TO THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY RIGHT YOUR LEFT
I CONSIDER WAIT A FRIEND AND A
COLLEAGUE AND I COULDN'T THINK
OF A BETTER SECRETARY FOR OUR
AGENCY SO I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE
FUTURE IN THAT REGARD.
YOUR MARCH TENTH LETTER TO ME
ASKED ME TO COVER A LOT OF
DETAILS SO LET ME GET GOING.
UNLIKE PRIOR YEARS HERE'S THE
BOTTOM LINE TAKE AWAY I WANT FOR
YOU TO HEAR AND EVERYONE
LISTENING.
GOOD NEWS.
THERE'S WAY MORE GOOD NEWS THIS
YEAR THAN ANY ONE OF MY PRIOR
UPDATES TO YOU IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
YOU ASKED ABOUT MY PARTIES FOR
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN LET ME
START IN AN ODD PLACE.
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING [inaudible]
WHY?
FINDING IT WAS TRANSPARENCY
TRANSPARENCY BECAUSE TRUST TRUST
BECAUSE CAPACITY CAPACITY
BECAUSE OUTCOMES.
IF WE CAN PRODUCE OUTCOMES WE
CAN KEEP FISHING FOR EVER.
SO YOU'LL REMEMBER IN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN STATE
BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT RECEIVED
NEW FUNDING.
N. POSITIONS WE TOOK ELEVEN OF
THOSE POSITIONS WHICH ARE NEW.
AND WE DEPLOY THEM ON TO THESE
TOPICS AND HEAR SOME THE
OUTCOMES.
WE'VE IMPROVED OUR DATA STREAM
LYING AND ELECTRONIC REPORTING
WE HEARD A NEW DATA MANAGER.
AND WE'RE VERY CLOSE TO
COMPLETING AN ENTIRE TRANSITION
OF A TWENTY YEAR OLD DATABASE.
TO A NEW STATE OF THE ART
DATABASE FOR COMMERCIAL FISH
LANDINGS IN THE STATE THAT'S
INCREDIBLE.
IT'S WAY PAST DUE.
WE'VE DEVELOPED AND DISTRIBUTED
ALL WHOLE USER GUIDE FOR FISH
BUSINESS YOU TICKETS THAT I'LL
TALK ABOUT IN A MINUTE.
AND WE'VE PRETTY MUCH SWAPPED
OVER SOME OF OUR KEY SECTORS
FROM PAPER [inaudible]
THE DIGITAL.
BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE NEW
CAPACITY INPUTTED TO FISHER'S
WORK.
WE HIRED TWO NEW POSITIONS FOR
SUSTAINABLE AND INNOVATIVE
FISHERY MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
ONE OF WHICH IS FOCUSED ENTIRELY
ON THINKING THROUGH THE CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS THE FISHERIES.
AND DEALING WITH EXPERIMENTAL
PILOT PROJECTS --
OF THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON OUT
IN OUR OCEANS.
WE TOOK TO THOSE POSITIONS AND
WE HARD NEWS STAFF DEDICATED TO
WHALE SAVE FISHERIES.
THEN USING THAT STAFF IN NEW
CAPACITY WE'VE IMPLEMENTED NEW
REGULATIONS TO RESTRICT THE
AMOUNT OF SURFACE GEAR WHICH CAN
BE USED IN DUNGEONS CRAB TRAPS.
WE'VE DEVELOPED OUR ABANDONED
AND LOST COMMERCIAL CROWD CHAT
PROGRAM WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT IN
A MINUTE.
AND WE'VE KIND OF UNDER WRITTEN
THE CONVENING OF THE DODGES CRAB.
GEAR WORKING GROUP AND THE TASK
FORCE WHICH BY THE WAY GOOD NEWS
ALERT MMHM MMHM MMHM.
I WAS TALKING WITH THE OCEAN AND
OUR DEPARTMENT STAFF WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
SO THERE'S NO BREAK.
THERE'S A SEAMLESS --
PROGRESSION OF THE MEETING OF
THE TASK FORCE AND WE'LL TAKE
CARE OF THE FUNDING TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAPPENS.
SO AS WE COME OUT OF SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING YOU MAY REMEMBER WE WERE
ALSO SIGNED SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING AS AN ASSIGNMENT WHAT
IS THAT.
WE'RE HALFWAY THROUGH OUR FIRST
COUPLE OF MONTHS OF OUTLINING
ALL THE INDIVIDUAL TASKS THE
DEPARTMENTS RESPONSIBLE.
FOR WITH HARDEN INTERNATIONAL
FORM TO LLOYD CONSULTING.
AND ALIGNING THOSE TASKS WITH
OUR MISSIONS IN OUR PROGRAMS AND
OUR PURPOSES.
WE'VE POSTED ALL THIS ON A
DEDICATED PUBLIC WEB PAGE WHICH
IS FOUND ON OUR HOME PAGE AT THE
DEPARTMENT.
WE'VE ENGAGED WITH YOUR BUDGET
STAFF TO A SERIES OF MEETINGS
WITH HOSTED SEVERAL STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
PUBLIC MEETING APRIL EIGHTH. TO
LAY OUT ALL THE PHASE ONE WORK
AROUND OUR BUDGET OUR PROGRAM
AND OUR TASKS RELATIVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S CAPACITY.
I MENTIONED THE TECH
[inaudible]
IMPLEMENTATION.
SO WE HAVE LAUNCHED IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE PACIFIC
STATES MARINE FISHERIES
COMMISSION ETEC.
WHICH WILL BE USED FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL FISHING
LANDINGS EFFECTIVE JULY ONE OF
THIS YEAR.
SO JULY ONE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND THE HOME OF
TECHNOLOGY WE WILL FINALLY HAVE
ALL OF OUR COMMERCIAL FISHERIES.
THE LANDING THEIR INFORMATION
USING AN ELECTRONIC DATABASE
SYSTEM -- I
HAVE MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO OUR
COMMITMENT TO SEND OF
SUSTAINABLE FISHERIES IN A
CHANGING CLIMATE.
LET ME MOVE ON TO OTHER GOOD
NEWS.
GROUNDFISH STOCKS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE REBUILDING.
AND WE ONLY HAVE TWO GROUNDFISH
STOCKS.
OFF OF OUR COAST REMAINING THAT
ARE CONSIDERED OVERFISHED.
THIS IS TRANSLATING INTO MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL ANGLERS AND IT'S A
BIG DEAL.
IF YOU GO BACK FIVE TEN YEARS
MOST OF THESE STOCKS WERE DEEMED
OVERFISHED.
AND WE'VE REBUILT ALL OF THEM
EXCEPT.
FOR TWO THAT MEANS THE FOLKS
BEHIND ME IN THIS ROOM HAVE MORE
RECREATIONAL AND COMMERCIAL
FISHING OPPORTUNITY.
LET'S TURN TO THE KLAMATH.
I THINK THIS IS GOOD NEWS AS
WELL.
MOST RECENTLY WE HAD A
DISRUPTION IN THE FORCE AROUND
THE PROSPECT OF LISTING A
CERTAIN RUN OF SALMON THAT EXIST
IN THE KLAMATH RIVER.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT.
OUR FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
TOOK THIS UP AT HIS LAST PUBLIC
MEETING.
AND I OFFERED TO THE COMMISSION
AND THE STAKE HOLDERS INVOLVED.
TO FOCUS THE CONVERSATION AROUND
WHETHER THERE WAS A WAY TO HAVE
THE LISTING PROCESS CONTINUE.-AT THE SAME TIME WE PROVIDE SOME
FISHING OPPORTUNITY.
THIS IS ALLOWABLE UNDER LAW
WE'VE LOOKED INTO IT WE'VE HELD
THREE MEETINGS WITH NORTH COAST
COUNTY.
IN NORTH COAST FISHING INTERESTS
TO CONSIDER OPTIONS FOR RE
OPENING A FISHERY FOR THE SPRING
CHINOOK SALMON ON THE KLAMATH
RIVER WHILE WE'RE CONTINUING OUR
STATUS REVIEW.
SUBJECT TO THE THE ESA PETITION --
LISTING PROCESS.
SO WE'VE ALREADY HAD MEETINGS IN
CRESCENT CITY.
AND I BELIEVE THERE'S A MEETING
IN READING SCHEDULE FOR NEXT
WEEK ON THAT TOPIC.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE OCEAN
SALMON FISHING SEASON
ALTERNATIVES WERE DEVELOPED
ALREADY IN RECOGNITION OF THE
NEED TO MINIMIZE THE RISK.
OF SPRING RUN IN THE KLAMATH
BECAUSE THEY MAY EVENTUALLY BE
LISTED.
AND UNDER LAW IN THE STATE SIDE
WHILE WE'RE CONSIDERING LISTING
FOR THE YEAR PERIOD.
THEY GET LEGAL PROTECTION SO
WE'VE ALREADY GONE OVER TO THE
FEDERAL FRONT AND TALKED ABOUT
THE DIFFERENT FEDERAL.
OPTIONS IN THE OCEAN BEING
SUFFICIENTLY PROTECTIVE OF THE
SPRING RUN AS THEY'RE OUT IN THE
OCEAN.
IF YOU TAKE A BROADER LOOK AT
THE OCEAN OVERALL I ALSO THINK
THIS IS GOOD NEWS.
THE SPORT AND COMMERCIAL OCEAN
SALMON FISHERIES ARE ANTICIPATED
TO BE BETTER THAN THEY WERE IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND THAT'S
MOSTLY DO A SLIGHT IMPROVEMENT
IN THE OCEAN ABUNDANCE
CONDITIONS AND FORECAST.
SO THOSE SEASON DATES WILL BE
FINALIZED UNTIL APRIL.
BUT IF I LOOK AT ALL THE
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE OUT FOR
PUBLIC REVIEW AT THE FEDERAL
COUNCIL LEVEL ALL OF THOSE
ALTERNATIVES.
ALLOW FOR SIGNIFICANT FISHING
TIME IN THE OCEAN OFF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST WHICH IS GOOD
NEWS COMPARED TO WHERE WE'VE
BEEN.
YEARS BEFORE.
IF YOU TURN AND LOOK FRESH WATER
INLAND I THINK THAT'S MORE GOOD
NEWS AS WELL.
THE OUTLOOK FOR THE RECREATIONAL
FISHING ON FALL RUN CHINOOK
SALMON IS ALSO POSITIVE. FOR
BOTH THE KLAMATH TRIGGER TRINITY
RIVERS AND THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
WE ANTICIPATE A GOOD SEASON --
WE DO NOT ANTICIPATE A REDUCE
SEASON THE SACRAMENTO AS WAS THE
CASE LAST YEAR --
AND THE COMMISSION --
IS ALSO GOING TO BE CONSIDERING
EXTENDING SEASONS IN BOTH THE
FEATHER AND THEM CALLING ME
RIVERS.
SO IF YOU LOOK TO THE OCEAN AND
YOU LOOK IN RIVER WE'RE SEEING
GOOD NEWS COMPARED TO LAST YEAR
AND A COUPLE YEARS BEFORE THAT.
LET ME TURN TO DENTURES GRAB.
SO WE'RE STILL COLLECTING ALL
THE LANDING INFORMATION.
BUT BASED ON THE PRELIMINARY
LANDINGS AND THE OBSERVATIONS
WE'RE AWARE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SEASON.
IS ANTICIPATED TO YIELD LESS
THAN WAS LANDED DURING THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SEASON.
SO JUST FOR REFERENCE POINT THE
TOTAL SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REVENUE
WAS ABOUT SIXTY NINE IT'S NOT
ABOUT IT WAS PRECISELY. SIXTY
NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION AND I
THINK IT'LL BE A LITTLE OFF OF
THAT ONCE WE'VE GONE THROUGH ALL
OF THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SEASON --
INFORMATION [inaudible]
DEMO CASSIDY.
IS A BAD NEWS STORY BUT IN SOME
SENSE THIS YEAR IT WAS GOOD NEWS
COMPARED TO WHERE WE'VE BEEN
MOST RECENTLY.
IT DID CONTINUE TO CAUSE FISHERY
DELAYS IN SOME PARTS OF THE
STATE BUT IT JUST WAS NOT AS
NEARLY SEVERE OR AS WIDESPREAD
AS PRIOR SEASONS.
SOME OF OUR NORTHERN AREAS WERE
DELAYED UP TO THREE WEEKS WHILE
OTHER AREAS EXPERIENCED NO
DELAYS AT ALL.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE FOUND
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IS A
LITTLE IMPROVED ABILITY TO FINE
TUNE.
HOW WE'RE THINKING ABOUT WHICH
PARTS OF THE STATE MAY BE
SUBJECT TO A CLOSURE WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON TRYING TO KEEP?
OTHER PARTS OPEN RATHER THAN.
A BROADER CLOSURE APPROACH
LOOKING AT IT MORE SURGICALLY
BASED ON OUR DIALOGUE WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES.
AND THE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH HAZARD ASSESSMENT.
DISASTER FUNDING.
WE ARE WAITING FOR THE CRAB
AND I MADE A PROMISE TO NO ONE
OPPENHEIM YESTERDAY THAT I WOULD
GO CHECK INTO THIS.
AND WE CAN REPORT.
THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED SOME VERY
RECENT LAST MAYBE TWO DAYS
QUESTIONS FROM THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT BUDGET --
AND BE ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL WE
THINK THEIR FINAL CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS.
WE SPOKE WITH OUR COUNTERPARTS
IN THE FEDERAL SYSTEM AND WE
THINK WE CAN.
SEE THESE FUNDS COMING TO US BY
MAY.
ONE BUT I THINK THEY SHOULD BE
HERE TOMORROW.
SO I WILL MAKE MY COMMITMENT IS
DIRECTOR AND I THINK THE
SECRETARY WILL CONCUR WILL DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER. TO GET
THOSE FUNDS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
AND BEFORE MAY [inaudible]
ONE WELL ENTITLEMENTS
[inaudible]
STUFFED UP.
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN FEDERAL
COURT --
AROUND LITIGATION OVER THE
INTERPLAY BETWEEN OUR DUNGENESS
CRAB FISHERY.
AND ENTANGLEMENTS OF THESE
MAJESTIC MARINE MAMMALS.
WHAT I WILL SAY ON THAT FRONT IS
IT'S A COMPLICATED --
PIECE OF FEDERAL [inaudible]
LITIGATION.
I BELIEVE I UNDERSTAND THE
INTERESTS OF THE PLAINTIFF THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
AND THE INTERVENOR THE PACIFIC
COAST FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS.
AND I THINK ALL THREE PARTIES
THOSE TWO IN THE DEPARTMENT.
UNDERSTAND WHAT AN AGREEMENT IN
PRINCIPLE MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
AND I'M HOPEFUL WE CAN GET A
RESOLUTION AND I CAN COME BACK
TO YOU PRETTY SOON.
AND LAY OUT THE THE POSSIBLE
RESOLUTION TO THIS RISK
MEANWHILE --
WE HAVE A RULE MAKING PACKAGE
IMPLEMENTING YOUR GEAR RETRIEVAL
PROGRAM --
IT'S CURRENTLY OUT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
AND IT IS ANTICIPATED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED BY JUNE THIRTIETH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THANK YOU
FOR THIS PROGRAM AND THAT
LEGISLATION.
EFFECTIVELY AS YOU KNOW IT MEANS
WE CAN GET PEOPLE OUT THERE MORE
SMARTLY PICKING UP A BANDED CRAB
GEAR AND BRINGING IT BACK
[inaudible]
YOU'RE MARKING.
WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS TO
STANDARDIZE THE MARKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR ANYBODY WHO IS
FISHING FIXED GEAR IN THE OCEAN.
AND WE ANTICIPATE RELEASING
THOSE REGULATIONS FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT THIS SUMMER.
THEY'RE GOING TO PRESCRIBE THE
DIMENSION SHAPE COLOR FOR BOOBY
TAGS.
TO YOUR TRAPS OR ANY STRING OF
TRAPS AND THIS IS AN IMPROVEMENT.
AND A A MOVEMENT IN THE
DIRECTION OF WILL SAY FISHERIES.
AND AS MOST OF YOU KNOW BACK IN
NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR.
A PUBLICLY STATED OUR DEPARTMENT
WILL BE.
ON FILING A NOTICE OF INTENT TO
APPLY FOR AN INSTANT ALL TAKE
PERMIT UNDER THE FEDERAL ESA.
HERE'S WHERE I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO END UP.
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE GONNA END UP
THERE PRETTY SOON.
A RESOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE OF
THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN WELLS IN
OUR FISHERIES.
WERE WE CAN CREDIBLY STAND UP
AND SAY.
WE'RE SAVING WHALES.
AND WE HAVE SUSTAINABLE
[inaudible]
WELL SAVE [inaudible]
GRAB.
WE CAN DO BOTH OF THOSE THINGS
IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK WE'RE ON THE VERGE OF A
PROGRAM WHICH WILL BE THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE ONE IN THE NATION.
AND FOLKS CAN FEEL CONFIDENT
EATING THE CRAB AND ENJOYING IT.
AND KNOWING WE'RE SAVING WELLS
AT THE SAME TIME I THINK WITH
THAT CLOSE TO THAT CANAL COME
[inaudible]
THE AQUACULTURE.
E. D. I. R. WHICH IS A MOUTHFUL
LET ME JUST GET TO THE BOTTOM
LINE IT'S BEEN WAY TOO LONG.
IT'S BEEN LURKING IS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT FOR TOO
MANY YEARS.
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW HAVING
DONE AN ASSESSMENT YOU'LL HEAR
MORE ABOUT IN A MINUTE.
WE'RE GONNA GET THIS THING OUT
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT BY THE END OF
THIS MAY.
THERE'S A COUPLE OTHER PIECES OF
LEGISLATION YOU ASKED ABOUT.
WE ARE NEXT WEEK PUTTING OUT A
RULE MAKING PACKAGE TO IMPLEMENT
THE DRIFT GILL NET BUYOUT
PROGRAM.
SO THE PUBLIC WILL SEE THE
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A FUNDING
MECHANISM TO PHASE OUT THE
REMAINING TWENTY OR SO FOLKS
USING THAT FISHING TYPE
[inaudible]
WE ARE.
ABOUT TO PUT OUT AN APPROACH FOR
CREATING A PATHWAY FOR
EXPERIMENTAL FISHING PERMITS
WITH THE BILL'S SPONSOR --
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
THAT'S PRETTY EXCITING.
AND THE LAST THING I'LL SAY SOME
OF THE TOPICS I'VE GOT MY MY
MIND ON IN MY EYE ON FOR THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
OFFSHORE RENEWABLE ENERGY OFF
SHORE OGLE CULTURE ARTIFICIAL
REEFS AND MARINE SPECIAL
PLANNING.
LET ME STOP THERE I HOPE I WAS
CLOSE TO TEN MINUTES AND WE'LL
TAKE QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER TRIGGER VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT THANK YOU FOR THE THOROUGH
PRESENTATION.
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS --
BUT WOULD LIKE TO GO TO TURN
OVER THE VICE CHAIR FIRST TO SEE
IF HE HAS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE DIRECTOR IN YOUR
AT THE SECTOR --
YOU MENTIONED THE THE SETTLEMENT
AROUND THE ENTANGLEMENTS AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S CLOSE
COULD YOU MAKE SURE THAT YOU LET
US KNOW WELL TO FIGURE OUT A
FORM TO MAKE SURE WE WHATEVER
INFORMATION THAT YOU HAVE WE CAN.
I UNDERSTAND AND THEN AND THEN
GET BACK OUT YES.
AT THE MOMENT I BELIEVE IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO TALK ABOUT IT IN
PUBLIC I WOULD WELCOME THE
CHANCE TO COMMON.
A SPEAK WITH YOUR OFFICES AND I
THINK ALSO DO THIS IN A PUBLIC
FORUM I THINK THERE'S A CREDIBLE
ENDEAVOR.
BY ALL THE PARTIES INVOLVED TO
COME UP WITH A CREATIVE SOLUTION.
THAT'S THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR.
AND THEN THE THE EXPERIMENTATION
PERMIT THE EXPERIMENT PER THE
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE
NEED.
TO FIGURE PATHWAYS FOR A LITTLE
BIT MORE BROADLY AS THE AS WE
TRY AND EXPERIMENT WITH GEAR.
WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY
WORKING WITH THE FLEET AND
MOVING FORWARD.
FINDING WAYS TO BE ABLE TO DO
EXPERIMENTAL WORK AND RESEARCH
WORK.
IN CALIFORNIA MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S IN OUR WATERS INSTEAD OF
HAVING TO GO MORE BROADLY IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS.
IS AN ENDEAVOR THAT WE NEED TO
WORK WITH YOUR AGENCY A KIND OF
ACROSS AGENCIES.
SECRETARY ON IT IN UNDERSTAND
HOW WE CAN BETTER.
IMPLEMENT THOSE PERMITS SO THAT
WE GET AND BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
THIS QUICKLY AS WE CAN SO THAT'S
JUST A SUBJECT THAT I THINK I'M
HOPING THAT THIS COMMITTEE.
WE'LL KEEP ON OUR RADAR SAID
THAT WE WORK THROUGH IT IN THAT
THAT WE COULD BE TALKING ABOUT
AS WE NEED TO WORK WITH
DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
ON BUT I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING I'M VERY INTERESTED AT
THIS POINT.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT
UP YOU BET AND WE WERE ACTUALLY
PRETTY RECENTLY ABLE TO DO ONE
OF OUR FIRST AND ONLY
EXPERIMENTAL GEAR PERMITS FOR A
BOX CRAB FISHERY --
IT TOOK ABOUT TWO LEGISLATIVE
SESSIONS TO WORK OUT A BILL AND
TO BE HONEST OUR DEPARTMENT
HELLO HISTORICAL RESISTANCE.
INTERNALLY TO THE IDEA OF
EXPERIMENTING.
AND I ACTUALLY THINK NOW THAT WE
HAVE THIS LEGISLATIVE STRUCTURE
IN PLACE YOU'LL SEE A RULE
MAKING FROM US.
WE'VE BEEN COLLABORATING ON WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY THAT A
LAY OUT THE EXPEDITED PATHWAY.
FOR DOING MORE EXPERIMENTAL
PURPOSES OFFSHORE.
GOOD BECAUSE AS WE SORT THROUGH
SOME OF THESE ISSUES WE NEED TO
BE DOING THESE THINGS HERE.
IN WAYS THAT THAT WE FIND
ACCEPTABLE WITH REALLY ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND SO I I
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THAT
THANKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESSURE.
SYSTEM [inaudible]
RIGHT.
DOESN'T COME INTO QUESTIONS ON A
FEW ITEMS AND IS GOING TO DO A
LITTLE BIT OF SHOCK ON APPROACH
WORKS WE ALL ON THIS --
TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE TOP
ISSUE SAID.
THE EJECTOR TOUCHED ON AS WELL
AS ITEMS FOR THE YEAR AHEAD.
LEANING FEES --
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WANTS TO
REPEAT BUT WE HAD A TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS AGO PLAYING THE FEES.
NO CERTAINLY NOT HAVE THAT
FISHERMEN DON'T AND I ALSO KNOW --
THE DIRECTOR DOESN'T --
AS HE CONTINUES SO --
LONG STORY SHORT --
WE WANT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
INCREMENTALLY.
LOOK AT AN ANNUAL INCREASE.
I EVERY OTHER YEAR INCREASE
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT THE
COMMITTEES CAN BE FOCUSING ON
THIS YEAR BECAUSE IF WE JUST
LOOK AT FREEZE WE'RE GONNA END
UP IN THE SAME PLACE.
AND JUST --
YOUR EARLY THOUGHT ON THAT.
AS A MEMBER OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO YOU LIVE THROUGH THE FEE
INCREASE EXPERIENCE LIKE I DID.
DON'T WANT TO DO THAT AGAIN YEAH
I'M AWARE OF LEGISLATION THAT
SUGGESTS THERE'S A WAY TO
INCREMENTALLY INCREASE FROM THE
BASELINE OF TODAY.
HERE TO SOME INDEX IT EXACTLY --
I THINK THAT'S WORTH CONSIDERING
AND OF COURSE WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE A SYSTEM
TO THINK THROUGH ALL PROPOSED
LEGISLATION.
YEAH I. N. M. LOOK NOT TRYING TO
ADVOCATE FOR AT THE MOMENT I
JUST THINK THAT --
THE PASS IS ALWAYS A PRETTY GOOD
PREDICTOR OF WHAT THE FUTURE IS
GONNA LOOK LIKE AND THIS LEARN
FROM THOSE LESSONS SO THAT WE
DON'T END UP --
IN THAT SAME SEAT AGREE AND ONE
OF THE COMPOUNDING FACTORS LAST
DISCUSSION AROUND WAS IT HAD
BEEN SO LONG SINCE EXACTLY AND I
THINK THE IDEA IS RESPONSIVE TO
THAT.
DR.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I'M LIKE YOU DO A LITTLE BIT OF
A DEEPER DIVE IN THE SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING WHAT THAT'S
GOING TO MEAN A FISHERY BY
FISHERY.
I SO IF YOU CAN JUST --
TALK TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY WHAT
I AM ABOUT THE FISHERY BY
FISHERY --
BUDGET MANAGEMENT THAT YOU'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO DO I THINK
THAT. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES TO
THAT WE HAD A LONG DISCUSSION
OVER DURING MEANING FEES THE
DISCUSSION CERTAINLY ANY FEES IS.
EACH FISHERIES KIND OF LUMPED
INTO ONE POT I'M BEING UP.
WAIT GENERAL THE MOMENT.
THIS SERVICE FACE BHAJAN IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO FOCUSON
INDIVIDUAL FISHERIES I BELIEVE
IF YOU CAN JUST TOUCH BASE ON
THAT.
SO IT'S A IT'S A MOUTHFUL TO SAY
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING AND WHEN
I SAY IT MOST PEOPLE'S EYES
GLOSS OVER.
BUT IT TURNS OUT IT'S AN ACTUAL
BUSINESS DISCIPLINE.
THE LLOYD IS PROBABLY THE
PRIMERA DITTY THAT'S DOING IT IN
THE GOVERNMENT SECTOR.
THE BUDGET ACT INSTRUCTS ME TO
HER HIRE A CONSULTANT WE'VE
HEARD THEM.
AND AS I SEE THE PRODUCT.
THE OUTCOME IS AN EXHAUSTIVE
LIST OF TASKS.
THAT OCCUR WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
CONNECTED TO PROGRAM AND PURPOSE
WHICH IN MY MIND IN THIS CASE.
WILL ALLOW US TO SEE THE FISHERY
SPECIFIC YOU KNOW ORGANIZATION.
AND THEN YOU COMPARE THOSE TWO
LEVELS OF INFORMATION TO WHAT
YOUR CURRENT LEVEL OF SERVICE.
AND WHAT'S KIND OF YOUR OPTIMAL
LEVEL OF SERVICE.
AND LOOKING AT THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT WHICH USE SOMETHING
SIMILAR YOU GET A PUBLIC FACING
DASHBOARD.
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO UNDERSTAND
AND EXPLORE THAT INFORMATION
REAL TIME.
AND SEE HOW THE DEPARTMENT IS
ANALYZING TASKS REVENUE.
FISHERIES SECTOR IF YOU WILL
YEAH.
CURRENT AN OPTIMAL.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HEADED --
WE HAVE A FAIR AMOUNT OF WORK
LEFT IS A LONG WAY TO GO LET'S
BE HONEST TO ME JUST SO I CAN IN
THE IN.
THE EARLY DAYS OF THIS RIGHT BUT
I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO GO AND IT PROVIDES.
LOOK BOTTOM LINE IT HELPS THE
DEPARTMENT ON WHERE THEY'RE
SPENDING THE TIME.
AND WHAT WE ALL NOW IS TIME IS
MONEY -- AND
IT ALSO PROVIDES THE PUBLIC AND
THE FISHING COMMUNITY
TRANSPARENCY YESTERDAY TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING ON WHAT
TIME YOU SPEND A NIGHT ON
ANCHOVIES VERSUS CRAP FOR
EXAMPLE MMHM AND THIS IS RISKY
THINK ABOUT IT FROM OUR SIDE.
I HAVE FOUND --
COMING FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR
TO THIS PUBLIC SECTOR POSITION
THAT.
YOU KNOW IT THERE'S A A LEVEL OF
NERVOUSNESS WHEN YOU'RE LAYING
OUT ALL YOUR EXPENDITURES RIGHT
SURE.
AND I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
SOMETHING TO BE EMBRACED AND
THIS PROCESS WILL ALLOW US TO DO
THAT AFFIRMATIVELY.
IN A SMART MANNER THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE WE HAVE A
CONFUSING BUDGET.
AND WE HAVE ALREADY PUT A LOT OF
THE INFORMATION WE GENERATED ON
A PUBLICFACING WEBPAGE WILDLIFE
DOT CA DOT GOV.
BACKSLASH BUDGET BACKSLASH
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING.
AND WE'RE WELCOMING THE INPUT
AND THAT WEB LINK.
AS I MENTIONED WE'VE GOT A
SERIES OF PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
SCHEDULED I LOVE A CHANCE TO
TALK AND SUB TO INSULT THREE
ABOUT IT.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF REALLY
IMPORTANT ENGAGEMENT STILL TO BE
HAD.
THREE THANK YOU.
THAT COULD BE TO SWITCH GEARS
HERE TO CRAB INTO TESTING.
REALLY HAVE A TWO STEP PROCESS
WHERE BY YOUR DEPARTMENT MISTER
DIRECTORS OUT THERE --
WORKING WITH FISHERMEN WHO
GENEROUSLY GIVE THEIR TIME TO BE
ABLE TO GO CATCH THE SPECIMEN.
WORKING WITH YOUR DEPARTMENT AND
ULTIMATELY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH --
OVERSEEN THE TESTING.
ON I THINK THAT THERE'S STILL
SOME GAP OF WHERE PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS.
TO BE IN REGARDS TO THEIR
FINDING UNDERSTAND THE DFW WAS --
PROVIDED TO ENHANCE FUNNY BUT I
THINK.
AGAIN NO THIS IS SEPARATE FROM
YOU BUT ALSO YOU'RE ATTACHED TO
HIP WITH THE PH I THINK THAT'S
THE ONE AREA THAT WE STILL NEED
TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT IS.
HOW TO BE A GIVE THEM ADEQUATE%
RESOURCES BID TO COMPLETE THE
TESTING ESPECIALLY IN A TIMELY
MANNER -- IN
AS WITH THE SECTORS TALK ABOUT
DEMO CASTED.
MY OPINION I THINK THAT WE WILL
ALSO HEAR FROM.
I'M -- THE
CRABBERS IS THAT SOME CHALLENGES
THERE IN REGARDS THE TIME MIGHT.
ANY COMMENTS ON THAT YES THERE
ARE STILL CHALLENGES THERE.
YES THE OUTCOME DEPENDS ON
GETTING INFORMATION AND
PROCESSING IT QUICKLY.
AND OFTEN THAT'S A FUNCTION OF
PEOPLE AVAILABLE IN LABS.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT TO SAY IT'S
A CONTINUING AREA OF CONCERN I'D
LOVE A CHANCE TO GO OFF LINE
TALK TO THE SECRETARY AND OUR
COLLEAGUES ELSEWHERE PERFECT.
AND KEEP WORKING ON THE TOPIC
IT'S GREAT I'M GONNA I'M JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF A PARKING LOT JUST
SO WE CAN FOLLOW UP ON IT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WHEN ENERGY?
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
ANYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE --
FOR MANY IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
SAY THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON RENEWAL AFFORDABLE
RENEWABLE --
SOURCES OF ENERGY FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
IN WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO IT RIGHT --
MAKING NEW SURE THAT WHEN WE ARE
LOOKING AT THOSE TURBINES --
INSENSITIVE OCEAN AREAS
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S GONNA BE GOOD
FOR THE GREATER.
GOOD FOR A G. SHE IMPACT WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S ALSO
WORKING FOR VERY SENSITIVE
HABITATS OFF OF OUR COAST IN HIS
SON IMPACTING COMMERCIAL FISHING
GROUNDS -- I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU EITHER OF YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON THIS AND WE
WILL BE HAVING THAT HEARING
COMING UP ON THE THIRD UP IN
EUREKA --
BUT I JUST LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF
YOU HAVE ANY EITHER ONE OF YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS.
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO BOUNCE RIGHT
AT A BROAD LEVEL I THINK THE
DIRECTOR INDICATED A PRIORITY IN
HIS DEPARTMENT.
FOR BEING CENTRELINK GAUGE IN
THIS MARINE SPATIAL PLANNING.
ANDWE HAVE.
TO THE OTHER DEPARTMENT OR
ENTITY WITHIN THE RESOURCE
AGENCY OF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION.
AND THEY'VE BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT THEIR APPROACH TO THIS
THEY'VE DONE SOME LARGE SCALE
ENERGY PLANNING ON LAND.
AND THEY'RE FOCUSED IN
PARTNERING WATER.
IS OBVIOUSLY A FEDERAL DIMENSION
ON THIS AS WELL --
SO I WELCOME YOUR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF THIS AND JUST KNOW
THAT THIS IS A PRIORITY WITHIN
OUR AGENCY.
THE ONLY ADDITIONAL THING I'D
SAY IS FROM EXPERIENCE.
HAVING LIVE THROUGH.
MOST OF THE EFFORT TO PERMIT THE
LARGE SCALE SOLAR ON THE LAND
SIDE YEAH.
WITH THE RIGHT MAPPING IN
PLANNING AND THE RIGHT
LEADERSHIP TO ENSURE WE'RE
TALKING ACROSS OUR OUR BAND WITH.
I FOUND THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT KIND DISCUSSION IS IS
THE FOOTPRINT QUESTION WHERE DO
YOU WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO PUT
THE ASSET.
AND IF YOU CAN ENSURE YOU'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT THAT
THOUGHTFULLY.
YOU ALMOST ALWAYS CAN ACHIEVE
BOTH OBJECTIVES.
SENSITIVITY TO SPECIES AND
HABITAT AND GREENING OUR GRID.
AND A LOT OF THAT RESTS ON THE
QUESTION AROUND CITING INFOPRINT.
ABSOLUTELY AND I WOULD ONLY
MENTION ONE OTHER IMPORTANT
STAKEHOLDERS THE FEDERAL
MILITARY.
AND WE'LL CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH SEVERAL
FEDERAL MILITARY INSTALLATIONS
THAT ARE DOING TESTING IN
TRAINING.
I AND WIND ENERGY.
ARE PLACED IN THE WRONG --
LOCATION CAN BE REALLY
PROBLEMATIC --
TO FLYING THE MILITARY PLANE SO
WE'RE SENSITIVE TO THAT AND
WE'RE ENGAGING THOSE FOLKS AS
WELL.
GREAT FOR I THINK THAT ONE OF
THE AREAS THAT.
WERE ALSO CAN WE FOCUS ON ARE
THOSE LINES THAT NEED TO BE
BUILT OUT SO FOR LOOKING AT THE
NORTH COAST FOR EXAMPLE YOU'RE
GOING THROUGH SOME OF THE MOST.
SENSITIVE ECOSYSTEMS ON EARTH --
AND WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE THERE
TO BE ABLE TO GET WHATEVER
ENERGY IS GOING TO BE.
DEVELOPED OFF SHORE --
INPUT INTO THE GENERAL GRADE
IT'S GOING TO BE INCREDIBLY
COSTLY BY THE WAY RIGHT AND
WE'RE GONNA BE BUILDING THESE
TRANSMISSION LINES THROUGH SOME
OF THE MOST SENSITIVE WATERSHEDS --
WHICH ARE --
SALMON BEARING HABITAT.
AND SOME OF THE MOST SENSITIVE --
FORCEFULLY AND WITH ENDANGERED
SPECIES I THINK THAT'S THE OTHER
AREA THAT WE WE NEED TO BE A
FOCUS THAT WILL BE TOUCHING THE
FOOTPRINT OF THE DIRECTOR'S.
OFFICE AS WELL [inaudible]
I'M.
SETTLEMENT KNOW THAT I YOU HAVE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY --
ON THE SETTLEMENT.
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ON WHAT THIS
WILL LOOK LIKE --
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN A GREAT COMMUNICATOR WHEN
YOU CAN BE ON AND WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE.
AND IN ONE OF THE ITEMS THAT WE
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HOST IS I CAN
MEAN AND MEDIAN WITH --
WITH THE DEPARTMENT ALONG --
WORKING WITH MR OPPENHEIM HE
BETTER COME IN AND SEE WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE  AS WE MOVE FORWARD
I THINK.
THAT MAY MEAN SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IF WE'RE GOING TO ADD
IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SEASON WHAT THAT'S GOING TO MEAN
TO BE ABLE TO GET FOLKS OUT IN
THE WATER.
AND WHAT WE CAN DO IF --
THAT SEASON IS INTERRUPTED
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE RUNWAY IF WE
LOOK AT A DIFFERENT ARE SHORTER
SEASON FOR EXAMPLE WHO KNOWS
WHAT IS GOING TO BE.
BUT THERE IS SOME GREAT CONCERN.
FOR THE LIVELIHOOD IT'S OUR TOP
TIER FISHERY WE HAVE AND THERE'S
A LOT OF ANXIETY OUT THERE AS
YOU ALL KNOW AND WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE PROACTIVE ON
CONVENING A MEETING.
OBVIOUSLY WITH A DEPARTMENT AND
THOSE WHO WOULD BE IMPACTED BY
THE SHORTENED SEASON AND OFF.
EITHER ONE OF YOU HAVE --
HAVE THAT.
NOT WANTING TO BE A TO GET INTO
THE DETAIL ON THE SETTLEMENT --
ALL I KNOW HE CAN'T SPEAK TO
THAT BUT I THINK TO SOME PROCESS
POST YES.
I SPENT QUALITY TIME WITH THE
BOARD OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION THOSE A LITTLE BIT
OF CUSSING INVOLVED YEAH.
A DIRECTED SOME AT ME I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND I THINK
THERE'S A VERY LEGITIMATE.
ANXIETY IN THE FLEET.
I HAVE BENEFITED FROM
UNDERSTANDING THEIR INTEREST IN
KEEPING THAT IN MIND AS I'M
TRYING TO HELP SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
I WOULD ARGUE THE FEDERAL
LITIGATION POTENTIALLY IS AN
EVEN GREATER RISKS TO CERTAIN
INSTABILITY IN THE FLEET.
THAT SAID I HAVE COMMITTED TO GO
TO THE CRAB WORKING GROUP ON
TUESDAY IN PERSON.
AND HERE THE CONCERNS AND
QUESTIONS YOU KNOW FIRST HAND.
AND I WILL MAKE THE COMMITMENT
TO YOU THAT WHATEVER STRUCTURE
WORKS BEST FOR YOUR STAKE
HOLDERS ALEX REPLIED INFORMATION
WHEN I CAN.
THAT'S GREAT THINKS MISSIONS
DIRECTORTHE LAST ITEM --
I MENTIONED --
INVOLVES A DIFFERENT AGENCY --
BUT NOW THAT S. P. --
ONE HAS FOR MANY MANY YEARS ON
FISH PASSAGE IN STATE HIGHWAY
PROJECTS --
IN US BUILDING RESILIENT --
RESILIENT LEE TO ENSURE THAT
WHEN WE ARE GOING THROUGH SOME
VERY SENSITIVE WATERSHEDS THAT
WE ARE NOT **** UP THOSE
SENSITIVE STREAMS AND THAT'S
ANOTHER PRIORITY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE ESPECIALLY WHEN WE ARE
CONTROLLING THE DESTINY BUT
THOSE PROJECTS LOOK LIKE.
MAKING SURE THAT THE STATE
HIGHWAY PROJECTS ARE FISH
FRIENDLY WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
SEE FISH PASSAGE --
INSPECTION SOME OF THE AREAS
WHERE MR DOLLAR REPRESENTS SOME
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY --
IN OUR ENTIRE WATER SYSTEM
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE EXPLORING.
IT WILL TOUCH OBVIOUSLY THE SHOP
OF THE DIRECTOR BY --
THIS WILL ALSO INVOLVE CALTRANS
AS WELL --
IN BUILDING THAT INTO THEIR
PLANS --
WITH THESE SP ONE DOLLAR
CERTAINLY MOVING FORWARD AS WELL.
PLEASE OTHERS SAY BROADLY ONE OF
MY PRIORITIES IS TO INSURE --
CLOSE COORDINATION BETWEEN
NATURI SOURCE AGENCY IN THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. TO ENSURE
THAT ALL OF THAT FUNDING THAT
WE'RE GENERATING TO IMPROVE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA IS DONE THOUGHTFULLY --
AND ACTUALLY YOU KNOW ALL THOSE
MITIGATION DOLLARS GET SPENT ON
ACTUALLY PROTECTING THE RESOURCE.
WHETHER IT'S A FORESTER THE
WILDLIFE ASH I AND I THINK THAT
THERE ARE THERE'S SO MUCH
OPPORTUNITY ACTUALLY TO CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE WHAT WE'RE DOING --
I'M REALLY PASSIONATE I KNOW
DIRECTOR BOTTOMS REALLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT WILDLIFE
MIGRATION AND WILDLIFE MIGRATION
CORRIDORS --
AND SO YOU BRING UP ONE EXAMPLE
OF OF THAT MIGRATION CORRIDOR
BUT BOY YOU KNOW ONE PRIORITY I
HAVE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
SPENDING THIS TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN IN WAYS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY.
IMPROVING --
ARE REESE ARE NATURI SOURCES AND
HABITAT VERSES IMPACTING THEM
NEGATIVELY.
THIS USUALLY SECTOR AND VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT BECAUSE LOOK --
OVER THE DECADES WE HAVE SOME
REALLY OLD CRAPPY CULVERTS THAT
HAVE GREATLY IMPACTED NEGATIVELY --
THE WATER FLOW IN A SPAWNING
ABILITY OF SALMON --
IN --
EIGHTEEN ALL AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE A
BIG PRIORITY BEEN FOCUSING ON
SPECIALLY NOW THAT WE HAVE
pRESOURCES AND WE CAN CONTROL
THAT DESTINY SO THAT'S REALLY
WONERFUL FOR YOU TO SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE LOVE TO BE
A FOLLOW UP WITH.
YOUR NEXT THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
IMPACT --
THAT WE'D LIKE TO BE NAKED IN
THE FUTURE.
MR DIRECTOR AND OTHERS IN AND
YOU WANTED TO ADD TO THAT WHAT
HE SAW TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
FOLLOW UP UP FROM THE COMMITTEE
MR SOON.
JUST A ONE ENCOURAGE YOU --
TO REACH OUT TO THAT WHEN WE HAD
THE CAR FIRE UP IN --
SHASTA COUNTY WE HAD --
SECRETARY --
PURDUE AND THEN WAS RYAN ZEKI
ALONG WITH JOHN LAYERED AND THE
CAL FIRE.
JUST WANT --
TO COURAGE YOU DO YOU KNOW THE
BIGGEST LANDOWNER IN THE STATE
OF OUR HABITAT AREAS IS THE FOR
SERVICE AND AND OUR ABILITY BILL
TO WORK TOGETHER TO COME OUT
WITH A COMMON GOAL IS GOING.
TO REQUIRE YOU YOUR ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE THA AND
I WANNA BE PARTNER WITH YOU ON
THAT.
AND I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON GETTING THEM AT THE
TABLE AND WE HAVE SOME GOOD
NEIGHBOR AUTHORITIES THAT THE
SECRETARY LAIRD WORKED ON SO.
WE COULD EXPAND ON THAT --
TOO DO GOOD FOREST HEALTH TO
IMPROVE OUR WATERSHEDS.
YEAH I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU
MORE AND I TOOK NOTE OF YOUR
COMMENTS I IN ANOTHER FORM
REGARDING LONG TERM STEWARDSHIP
CONTRACTS ON NATIONAL FOREST
LANDS -- WE
NEED THE NASH --
AND USDA HAS TO BE A PARTNER ON
THE GOOD FOLKS WORKING THERE
ROWING IN THE SAME DIRECTION AS
US I MEAN WE CAN ACTUALLY
IMPROVE THE COORDINATION.
WHICH WILL BE HELPFUL FOR FOREST
MANAGEMENT WHILE FIRE SAFETY AND
THEN AS YOU'VE CONNECTED THE
DOTS ALSO HELPFUL --
FOR HEADWATERS IN RIVER HABITATS
FOR THAT MIGRATING SALMON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY OTHER
ANSWER.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR TELLING
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND VERY GRATEFUL FOR UP YOUR
PRESENTATIONS TODAY.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH AS WE'RE
TRANSITIONING BETWEEN OUR
PANELISTS WE WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY LEFT I HIS NAME
IS TOM WEST LOW HE'S THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR THE JOINT
COMMITTEE --
NONE OF THIS WOULD BE HAPPENING
WITHOUT HIS INCREDIBLE WORK AND
I THINK WE NEED TO GIVE HIM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE FULLY SELF
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISTER WESTOVER.
RD WORK SIR.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE TO GIVE
YOU A STATE OF THE STATE ON ALL
ISSUES ON ALL ISSUES RELATED TO
THE SALMON FISHERY WE HAVE FOUR
OF THE BEST EXPERTS IN THE
GOLDEN STATE HERE WITH US TODAY.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO WALK IN
THEM AND HAVE THEM COME FORWARD
PLEASE FORGIVE ME WELCOMING NO
OPPENHEIM IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION.
JOHN MCMANUS AND CHECK THE
DIRECTOR OF THE GOLDEN STATE SAM
ASSOCIATION WE'RE GONNA WELCOME
JIM ANDERSON HE IS A COMMERCIAL
FISHERMAN FISHERMAN AND A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA SALMON STAMP
COMMITTEE.
AND WHO WE WOULD NOT HAVE A PEN
WITHOUT MISTER RICK IT'S MIKE
RICKETS WHO IS CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SALMON STAMP
COMMITTEE WE WELCOME THE
GENTLEMAN HERE TO THE COMMITTEE
WE WILL GO BE GOING IN THE
FOLLOWING ORDER NO.
ONE JOHN JIM AND MIKE EACH
INDIVIDUAL HAS FIVE MINUTES
WE'LL GIVE YOU ONE MINUTE PROMPT.
I'M SORRY BUT I AM AND THEY HAVE
TO GO AND VOTE BACK IMMEDIATELY
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES AND WELCOME THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
FIGURES WAS MISCHIEF MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER VICE CHAIR.
AND ANOTHER DELI IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE WITH YOU AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR ATTENDING THE CIVIC
RECEPTION LAST NIGHT --
THAT WAS --
TREMENDOUS EVENT THANKS TO OUR
VOLUNTEERS AND AND ARE EXCELLENT
STAFF.
AND TO TOM AS WELL SO THANK YOU --
MY NAME'S NO OFTEN I'M I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS.
AND AS AS WE'VE HEARD.
EARLIER IN THIS PROCEEDING THERE
ARE THERE'S BAD NEWS AND GOOD
NEWS TO SHARE --
IN IN OUR IN OUR DISCUSSION OF
WHAT IS IN STORE FOR US IN BOTH
THE SALMON FISHERY THIS YEAR AND
IN SAM AND RELATEDISSUES THAT
WE ARE.
DEALING WITH IN THIS YEAR IN THE
YEARS AHEAD --
IT'S A COMPLEX PICTURE IT'S ONE
WHERE WE ARE EMPOWERED TO CARVE
A PATH FOR OURSELVES TO
PROSPERITY AND TO THE RENEWAL
REJUVENATION OF OUR MOST ICONIC
FISHERY THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA.
KING SALMON FISHERY --
THEY'VE THAT WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH EXTRAORDINARILY CHALLENGING
TIMES IN COMMERCIAL FISHERIES
LATELY AS WE KNOW --
BUT BUT THIS THREE FOOT FISH IS
RESILIENT IT'S BEEN HERE FOR
MILLIONS OF YEARS AND WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP IT THAT WAY.
BUT RECENT EVENTS --
INCLUDING CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED
IMPACTS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY --
HUMAN MISMANAGEMENT AND AND
FOLLY AND GREED FRANKLY HAVE
BEEN --
DEVASTATING OUR FISHERIES THE
HIJACKING OF THE FEDERAL POLICY
APPARATUS --
IN PARTICULAR AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF INTERIOR DELIVERING MORE
WATER AWAY FROM FISH AND TWO
OTHER USER GROUPS.
IT HAS BEEN WREAKING HAVOC IN
RECENT PAST DESTROYING OUR OUR
CENTER VALLEY SALMON RUNS OUT
AND IF WE DON'T TAKE ACTION HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. TO TAKE BACK OUR
PROCESS.
WE COULD LOSE IT ALL --
AND AND THAT'S NOT AN
EXAGGERATION MANY OF US HAVE
ALSO LEARNED.
RECENTLY WITH REVULSION THAT
ANOTHER FEDERAL FOLLY THE AT THE
FEDERAL THE FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION --
IS GOING TO RESULT POTENTIALLY
IN THE THE PERMITTING IMPORTING
OF GMO SENATE FOR THE FIRST TIME
A PRODUCT GENETICALLY ENGINEERED --
FOR EXCESSIVE GROWTH A IS GOING
TO BE POTENTIALLY IN OUR MARKETS
ARE IT WILL IF WE DON'T.
EITHER FEDERALLY OR IN
CALIFORNIA REQUIRE LABELING IN
ORDER TO LET CONSUMERS KNOW THAT
THIS PRODUCT.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
THE A. FRANKEN FISH AND NOT THE
WILD -- THE
FISH THAT THEY HAVE COME TO LOVE
AND CHERISH --
THEN WE COULD BE DOING OUR
CONSUMERS AND OUR FISHERIES A
DISSERVICE --
I FOR ONE AM WORRIED ABOUT WHAT
THIS MEANS --
FOR ALL OF US --
IT CAN'T JUST BE A Q. R. CODE IT
NEEDS TO SAY LOUD AND CLEAR GMO
FISH.
FARMED.
AND AND IT NEEDS THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE INFORMATION TRANSPARENCY.
THERE IS A BRIGHT SPOT THIS YEAR.
THE THE COMMERCIAL SALMON
FISHERY IS GOING TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE FISHING
OPPORTUNITY THAN ANY YEAR IN
RECENT MEMORY --
AND THE THE REASON WHY MAY
SURPRISE.
SOME OF THOSE IN DC OR DOWN
HIGHWAY NINETY NINE BUT FOR
THOSE OF US IN HE ROOM THE
REASON IS CLEAR.
FISH NEED WATER.
AND THE WINNER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN FISH GOT
THAT WATER AND WE'RE GOING TO BE.
REVELING IN THAT BOUNTY THIS
YEAR THE SEASON ALTERNATIVES
THAT WE'VE CRAFTED FOR THE
COMMERCIAL FISHERIES IN THE
OCEAN HAVEN'T BEEN FINALIZED YET.
BUT IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ALTERNATIVES WHICH ARE AVAILABLE
IN THE PACIFIC FISHERY
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL'S WEBSITE --
THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR THE
FISHERIES IF THAT THIS YEAR
WE'RE GONNA BE COUNTING MONTHS
ON THE WATER INSTEAD OF WEEKS.
WHICH IS AN EXTRAORDINARILY
REALLY EXTRAORDINARY RELEASE
NATURE'S BOUNTY WILL BE SHARED
WITH THE PEOPLE THIS YEAR AND
THAT'S A REASON TO CELEBRATE.
THERE IS THE OTHER REASONS TO BE
EXCITED ABOUT SEVEN THIS YEAR
INCLUDING A COUPLE KEY PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT I AND OTHERS
WILL SPEAK TO A LITTLE LATER.
I THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ONCE
AGAIN --
YOUR TRUE FRIEND TO SALMON AND
TO SALMON FISHERMEN --
HOWEVER OUR OUR CELEBRATION WILL
BE SHORT LIVED IF WE DON'T LEARN
THE LESSONS OF THE RECENT PAST --
BOTH GOOD LESSONS IN BAD TO
PRESERVE AND PROTECT OUR RIVERS
WE NEED TO APPLY THOSE LESSONS
IN A COUPLE KEY ISSUES.
WE NEED TO KEEP THE DELTA
TUNNELS.
OUT OF ANY PORTFOLIO APPROACH
THIS IS THE POSITION OF OUR
ORGANIZATION IT'S BEEN FOR YEARS
YOU CANNOT CARVE UP THE DELTA.
IN ORDER TO SECURE WATER FUTURE
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THOUGH THE THE REGIONS IN THE
SOUTH AGRICULTURAL MUNICIPAL
WATER USERS MUST FIND
ALTERNATIVES THEY CAN IT'S BEEN
PROVEN.
IT'S GONNA BE COSTLY BUT IT
CAN'T COME AT OUR EXPENSE WE'VE
WE'VE ALREADY LOST ENOUGH.
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
AND IT'S DELTA PLAN UPDATE.
THE PHASE ONE PROCESS WAS A
NIGHTMARE.
IT'S BEEN POLITICALLY COMPROMISE
AND YET DESPITE THAT FACT THE
WATER BOARD.
CAME OUT WITH THE FIRST STRONG --
PROTECTIVE.
WATER QUALITY CONTROL PLAN FOR
THE DELTA.
IN THIRTY YEARS PERHAPS EVER
SOME OF SAID THIS IS THE BEST
THING THE WATER BOARD EVER DONE
IN ITS HISTORY.
AND NOW THAT'S COMROMISED --
AND WE'RE STARTING TO SEE SIGNS
THAT IF IF IF IF THINGS PROCEED
AS THEY'RE GOING AND WE WILL
LOSE TRANSPARENCY WILL LOSE THE
PUBLIC NATURE OF THIS PROCESS.
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
CAN WORK.
IF THEIR PUBLIC.
AND IF THEY ARE.
IF THEY VERIFIABLY IT HERE TO
APPROPRIATE.
MINIMUM FLOW STANDARDS.
SO WE CAN GET THERE --
BUT IT'S A IT'S A CRITICAL
MOMENT THERE IN THE FISH NEED
THIS WATER WE GRILL WATERS ON
THE TABLE.
IT'S TIME TO KEEP IT THERE
[inaudible]
SO.
WE WON'T WE WON'T GIVE UP THE
FIGHT ON BEHALF OF THESE FISH
AND THE MEN WOMEN WHO. FIVE THE
OCEANS IN ORDER TO CAPTURE IT
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENJOY --
AND AN ORGANIZATION STANDS READY
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH YOU SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO GOING FISHING.
WITH AS MANY OF YOU AS I CAN ON
THE OCEAN THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
STUFF I'M VERY GRATEFUL THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS WILL HOLD.
UNTIL WE WENT TO THE ENTIRE SET
OF PANELISTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MINISTER FOR YOURS YOUR
FIVE MINUTES FROM THE ONE IN A
PROMPT WE WELCOME YOU SIR
[inaudible]
THANKS THANKS.
EXCUSE ME.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
SETTLEMENT DOLLARS SOME WOMEN
STONE SENATOR MAGUIRE.
TOM I'M JOHN MCMANUS PRESS
ASSOCIATION I'M ACTUALLY --
JUST CUED UP --
TO ECHO A LITTLE BIT ON SOME OF
THE THEMES THAT --
NO IT JUST SPOKE ABOUT ALTHOUGH
WE'RE OUT OF THE WOODS FOR THE
MOMENT WITH GOOD WATER YEARS --
WE WERE.
BADLY SCARRED DURING THE LAST
DROUGHT AND WE WANT TO TAKE
STEPS NOW TO AVOID THAT IN THE
FUTURE --
SACRAMENTO BEE HEADLINE FROM
JANUARY NEWSOME INHERITS A WHOLE
BUNCH OF HEADACHES DESPITE.
LAST MINUTE WATER DEALS BY BROWN
SOME HAVE SAID BECAUSE OF LAST
MINUTE WATER DEALS BY BROWN --
TOPIC OF DEBATE THIS GOES TO THE
BSA IS THAT WHERE YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT.
THE GOLDEN GATE SALMON
ASSOCIATION AND ALLIES PREPARED
AN ANALYSIS OF THE V. ESSAYS
WHICH WERE HAPPY TO SHARE WITH
ALL OF YOU.
AND BASICALLY WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT THEY MIGHT ACTUALLY MAKE
CONDITIONS WORSE FOR THE BAY
DELTA RIVERS SALMON AND WILDLIFE --
WE WEREN'T THE ONLY ONES THERE
WERE OTHER --
CONSERVATION GROUPS.
CLOSURE AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PART OF THE VOLUNTARY
SETTLEMENT PROCESS FOR THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS INCLUDING TROUT
UNLIMITED THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
THE BAY INSTITUTE.
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN AMERICAN RIVERS
THEY BASICALLY FOUND SIMILAR
THINGS TO WHAT WE DID THE TOP
FINDINGS OR THE AMOUNT OF WATER.
ALLEGED TO BE SHIFTED TO THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THESE NEW
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS.
SHE DOESN'T MEET THE LEGAL AND
SCIENTIFIC REQUIREMENTS OF THE
STATE BOARD IT DOESN'T MEAN
THESE --
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
CAN'T YET BE NEGOTIATED AND
MODIFIED HOPEFULLY THEY WILL BE
BUT AS THEY STAND TODAY THEY'RE
NOT THERE YET.
THERE IS DISAGREEMENT OVER WHAT
CONSTITUTES BASELINE CONDITIONS
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
IN THE PROPOSALS ARE UNCLEAR ON
HOW TO PROTECT ANY ADDITIONAL
WATER FROM BEING DIVERTED IN THE
DELTA SO ONE OF THE VOLUNTARY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS WE COULD
SEE SOME ADDITIONAL WATER PUT
INTO THE CENTRAL VALLEY ONLY
LOOK TO LOSE IT IN THE DAY --
RESTRICTIONS ON EXPORTS DOWN
THERE MEANWHILE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS MOVING TO
INCREASE DELTA PUMPING RIGHT NOW
AS WE SPEAK.
MODELING BY THE U. S. BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION SHOWS THAT THE
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT FLOWS.
COMBINED WITH WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS NOW PROPOSING
WOULD REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF WATER
FLOWING THROUGH THE DELTA WE MAY
GET MORE OF THESE BLUE GREEN
ALGAE OUTBREAKS WHICH IS WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING IN THIS PICTURE
HERE.
THAT'S SHUT UP --
NEAR OAKLEY IN THE DELTA BLUE
GREEN ALGAE --
FOR LACK OF FRESH WATER LACK OF
FLUSHING FLOWS THAT WAS DURING
THE DROUGHT WE COULD BE BACK IN
THERE VERY SOON.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSALS ARE ALL REALLY JUST SO
THEY CAN SEND MORE WATER SOUTH
TO THE VERY ARID WESTERN SAN
JOAQUIN.
VALLEY.
I'M NOT GONNA GET INTO THE
NUMBERS I JUST WANT TO HAVE YOU
LOOK AT THE RED.
THIS IS FROM THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION THIS IS THEIR
ESTIMATE OF HOW MUCH LESS WATER
WOULD SEE.
IN THE DELTA UNDER PROPOSALS
CURRENTLY UNDER THE TABLE OR ON
THE TABLES WHEN I MEANT TO SAY.
YEAH THAT'S QUITE A BIT OF WATER
THAT WE COULD STAND TO LOSE WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
SO ONE SOLUTION --
THE WE'D LIKE TO HELP YOUR ADS
FOR YOUR HELP ON IS TO SUPPORT
SP ONE OF OURS SENATOR TONI
ATKINS BILL. TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT WORKERS
AND CONSUMERS FROM THE HARMFUL
CONSEQUENCES OF RECKLESS
DEREGULATION AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THIS BILL IS FRONT OF THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW IT WOULD
GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS HELPING US.
I WOULD TURN MY ATTENTION TO
WELL THE SITE'S RESERVOIR
PROPOSAL JUST FOR A QUICK SECOND --
AND JUST POINT OUT WITHOUT
GETTING INTO DETAIL THAT --
YOU'LL HEAR A LOT OF ROSIE
THINGS ABOUT SITES OF THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE AWARE OF
THIS LETTER SENT BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
BACK IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN KLAY SAID --
HIGHER BYPASS FLOWS WOULD BE
NEEDED BEFORE SITES COULD DIVERT --
WHAT CDF W. IS CALLING ON IS
ABOUT TWICE THE BY PASS FLOWS
ENVISIONED BY THE?
SITES PROJECT AUTHORITY.
A AND DOES SO FOR THE SITE'S
FOLKS HAVE NOT TAKEN THESE
PROPOSALS AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO
HEART AND THEY NEED TO GOING
FORWARD --
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON
ONE OF OUR FAVORIT TOPICS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ME ADDRESS EVERY
TIME I'VE BEEN HERE.
AND THAT IS --
THE FEATHER RIVER BELOW THE
ORVILLE DAM AND THE HOT WATER
THAT'S POURING INTO THE RIVER
OUT OF THE THERMAL LIDO AFTER
BAY -- RIGHT
NOW -- ALL
PARTIES HAVE AGREED TO FIX THIS
BUT IT'S NOT BEEN FIXED.
SO I JUST WANT.
TO CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
FACT THAT --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH SENATOR
SCOTT WEINER AND HE'S BEEN GOOD
ENOUGH TO INCLUDE SOME LANGUAGE
NSP.
SIXTY NINE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY --
PROMPT AN ACCELERATION IN THE
FIX ON THAT PROBLEM IF D. W. R.
ISN'T GONNA MOVE WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE LEGISLATURE.
GIVE IT A LITTLE NUDGE AND
THAT'S WHAT S. B. SIXTY NINE WE
HOPE YOU'LL SUPPORT THAT.
AND NONE OF MY PRESENTATIONS
WOULD BE COMPLETE WITHOUT A A
FEW SHOT SO THERE'S A FISH SHOP.
IS MY GREATEST THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALWAYS VERY MUCH APPRECIATED AND
BRINGING THE POWER POINT AS WELL
GREAT REALLY REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT.
NOW TO TURN OVER TO
MISTRANSLATED SO MUCH COMING.
I IS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CONFERENCE HIM SAME COMMITTEE
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE
AT THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
HERE.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO STEP OUT AND
VOTE IS GOING TO GIVE YOU HEADS
UP AND I'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
MY NAME IS JIM ANDERSON ON ON
CALIFORNIA'S SAM SAM COMMITTEE.
THE OTHER THING THAT I'VE BEEN A
PART OF HIS THE CAL BARGING
PROGRAM AND I WAS REALLY HAPPY
TO BE A PART OF THAT.
THE MOST INTERESTING THING THAT
EVERY YEAR THAT WE DID BARGING
DOWN RIVER WE WERE ABLE TO LEARN
A WHOLE LOT ABOUT WHAT WE COULD
DO IN THE SYSTEM HOW TO TAKE
CARE OF THE FISH OUT A RELEASE
THE FISH WERE RELEASED EFFICIENT --
LEARNING WHAT TIME IS TIDES OR
WHATEVER WOULD BE THE BEST FOR
THE FASHION.
BY DOING THAT EVERY YEAR WE ARE
ABLE TO LIVE THAT.
I'VE HEARD THAT --
THURS --
SOME OF THE LOCAL PEOPLE ARE
HERE TO TRY TO INFLUENCE WHERE
WE DO RELEASE FISH OUT OF THE
TRUCKS THIS YEAR IN CASE ---WE'RE DUMPING DRUNK FISH INTO A
BAD SPOT.
PLACE WHERE THERE'S A WHOLE
BUNCH OF STRIPERS BE NICE TO
FIND SOMEWHERE ELSE TO DUMP THE
FISH.
RATHER THAN RIGHT IN THIS SPOT.
IF WE DUMP A TRUCKLOAD OF FISH
RIGHT ON TOP OF THE STRIKERS WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS LAST SUMMER --
YOU KNOW.
WE AS FISHERMEN DON'T CARE OF
THE BIRDS CRAWFISH STRIPERS
SEALS ARE WHALES EAT THE BABY
FISH WE DON'T CARE OF THE SEA
LIONS ARE THE KILLER WHALE THE
THE BIG FISH COMING BACK IN THE
RIVER ALL WE REALLY WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO PUT N A FISH IN THE
RIVER.
SO -- FISH
IN THE OCEAN SO THAT WE HAVE A
RETURNING FISH IN THE RIVER WE
HAVE A GOOD OCEAN FISHERIES FOR
BOTH SPORT AND COMMERCIAL.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE SEASON
STRUCTURES THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
THIS YEAR THE OCEAN ABUNDANCE
THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS YEAR --
THE OCEAN ABUNDANCES ISN'T A
HUNDRED AND IF WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON SOME OF THE PROJECTS
THAT WE'VE DONE THROUGH THE
DROUGHT --
WE HOPE TO GET TO THOSE KIND OF
NUMBERS RATHER THAN WHERE WE ARE
TODAY --
THIS YEAR WITH THE AMOUNT OF
SNOW IN THE MOUNT A RAIN WE'RE
HOPING FOR GOOD THINGS FOR FOR
THE YEARS TO COME.
BUT WE STILL LOOK AT THE
FISHERIES IS BACK N NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WE HAD FOUR
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED NINETEEN
VOTES FIVE HUNDRED AND TWO
VESSELS CAUGHT 50% OF THE FISH
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY FOUR
VESSELS CUT 90% OF THE FISH.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE'S FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX VESSELS
THAT LANDED A FISH THERE'S FIFTY
SIX BEZEL THAT LANDED 50%.
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED NINETEEN
VESSELS THAT LANDED 90% OF THE
FISH.
THAT'S A 90% REDUCTION IN THE
FISHERIES SINCE THEN --
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
SALMON STAMP IS PUT FISH IN THE
OCEAN SO THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN OCEAN FISHERIES AND AND
TRY TO DO THAT?
THIS 90% REDUCTION THE REAL
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE HAVING WITH
THAT IS IT'S NOT ONLY THE 90%
REDUCTION IN THE FISHERIES.
BUT IT'S A 90% REDUCTION ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ICE MACHINES FEEL
MECHANICS HERE STORES HOLLOW
FACILITIES ALL THOSE INDUSTRIES
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE
REDUCTION IN THE OCEAN FISHERIES.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED
REAL PROBLEM WITH US --
LAST THING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY IS IS.
WE SEE THAT THE REMOVAL OF THE
DANCE IN TWENTY TWENTY IS COMMON.
SO WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO WITH
SALMON STAMP AT LEAST BE AT THE
TABLE TO BE ABLE TO TALK WE'D
LIKE TO SEE SOME OF THE
SCENARIOS THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
OUT TO SEA.
OUR WHAT THE RATINGS OR SNOW
RATES AND THE FLOW RATES WOULD
BE AND WHAT KIND OF SEDIMENT
DEPOSIT THOSE KIND OF THINGS
WOULD HAPPEN DURING THE SYSTEM --
WITH THE DM REMOVALS --
WE WE TO TRY TO HELP MOVE FISHER
DO SOMETHING IN THE HATCHERIES
OR WHATEVER --
TO TO HAVE AN OCEAN FISHERIES
WALL THAT PROJECT IS GOING ON WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE REMOVAL OF THE
DAMS AND AND LOSE A COUPLE YEARS
OF OF STOCKS OUT OF CLAMS SYSTEM
AND HAVE NO OCEAN FISHERIES SO
WE WANT TO BE.
PROACTIVE AND TRY TO GET
INVOLVED IN THAT NOW SO WE CAN
HAVE SOME KIND OF SCENARIOS AND
UNDERSTANDINGS OF WHERE THAT
FISHERIES --
MIGHT END UP WITH THE REMOVAL OF
OF THAT.
TOO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
PRESENTATION WITH THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE RECORDS WHO'S THE
CHAIRMAN THE CAL CALIFORNIA.
SEVEN STAFF COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR HAVING US HERE AND I AGREE
WITH ALL OF THE PREVIOUS TALK.
TO THEM THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO
BE DONE AND WE APPRECIATE THE
RENEWAL OF THE SALMON STAMP.
PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
WORKING WITH.
OUR FRIENDS AND AND THAT THE
FUNDS THAT WERE AVAILABLE --
MAKE THIS SALMON --
ADVENTURE.
WORK IS THIS IS JUST A LOT OF
WORK.
AND A LOT OF THE DEMAND FOR MAN
POWER TO MAKE IT WORK WITH --
THROUGH YUR HELP IN THE LAND
BASE OPENED OVER A WORK WITH THE
CALCULATION WILDLIFE SO.
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE HELP THAT
YOU'RE DOING FORCE.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ONE THING IN
PARTICULAR IS.
THE OF THE COATED WIRE TAG
RESULTS HIS MESSAGES FOR FIVE
YEARS AND IF WE COULD HAVE THOSE
MORE UP TO DATE SO WE HAVE. TO
ON TIME.
WE CAN WORK WITH WATER FLOWS IN
THEY COULD WEAR TAGS AND
PROBABLY PRODUCE.
BETTER RESULTS WITH THE FISH
THAT WE HAVE TO WORK WITH.
THE THE HATCHES I THINK YOU'RE
DOING A GOOD JOB.
THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT HAVE TO
BE WORKED OUT WITH THE SOME OF
THE PEOPLE ARE DOING WITH TIME
RELEASES.
NIGHT RELEASES THINGS IT SO THAT
WE KEEP THE PREDATION DOWN.
AND THOSE THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND THAT TAKES A
COORDINATION WITH FISH AND
WILDLIFE WITH THE TRUCKING AND
THE BARGING IN.
WITH THE REAL SO THERE.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
BUT OVERALL I THINK WE'RE
LOOKING AT PROBABLY A WITH ****
WATER AND AND THIS YEAR'S WATER.
MAYBE TWO TO FIVE YEARS OF GOOD
FISHING SO.
MAYBE THAT WILL WEAKEN A KEEP
THE SALMON COME ON WHY WOULD
MAKE ENOUGH MONEY.
TO KEEP MORE PROJECTS GOING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ROLE WITH YOU GUYS ARE DOING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THANKS
FOR FOR BEING HERE GIVING THAT
UPDATE.
IS LITTLE MORE POSITIVE AND
SOMETIMES WE'VE SEEN AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS AND IT AND IT'S
INTERESTING AS WE NARROW DOWN ON
SOME OF THE ISSUES.
IT'S GOOD THAT WERE ABLE TO GET.
BE ON SOME OF THE CATASTROPHIC
THINGS WE'VE BEEN HAVING TO DEAL
WITH AND IN DWN SOME OF THE
DETAILS ALTHOUGH I SHARE.
YOUR FRUSTRATION WITH THE HOT
WATER DUMP THE THERMAL LIDO AND
WHY THAT.
THAT HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO TO
CHANGE I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CERTAINLY.
NEED TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT AND I
AGREE HAVING THE RIGHT FOLKS IN
THE FISHER THE SAM SAM
PROGRAMMING FISHMAN AT THE TABLE
AS WE DEAL WITH THE IMPACTS OF
CLOSING THE DAMS UP ON THE
KLAMATH AND THOSE ARE GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS.
AS THEY'RE THE CONVERSATIONS
AROUND THE DELTA.
THOSE ARE.
KIND OF ITS AT AT THEN FLOWED IF
YOU WILL ABOUT EXPECTATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO THE THE DELTA AND
CONVERSATION.
AROUND WATER OFTEN LEAVES OUT
THE IMPACT ON THE FISHERIES
INDUSTRY UNFORTUNATELY.
AND PAYING ATTENTION TO
HYDROLOGY HOW FISH MOVE WHAT
WHAT THAT ASPECT IS THE DELTA IS
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT NURSERY.
FOR THE OFFSHORE FISHING
INDUSTRY AND WE WE OFTEN LOSE
THAT IMPACT OR LOSE THAT
DOUCETTE UNDERSTANDING --
THE GMO ISSUE IS AN INTERESTING
ONE WHAT WHAT IS THE FEDERAL
ACTION THAT IS.
PENDING OR HAPPENING THAT WOULD
START TO OPEN THAT UP.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE QUESTIONS
SO THE FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION RECENTLY APPROVED
THE IMPORTATION OF OF OF PRODUCT
CALLED.
LOCKWOOD VANTAGE.
WHICH IS PRODUCED BY AQUA BOUNTY.
INCORPORATED BELIEVE STILL BASED
IN MASSACHUSETTS --
AND THE PRODUCT ITSELF IS A IS
AN AMALGAM OF OF OF ATLANTIC
SALMON.
CHINOOK SALMON AN ARCTIC CHAR --
IT HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT OF OF
SCRUTINY LITIGATION ETCETERA THE
FACT THE MATTER IS THAT THAT THE
THE THE CERTIFICATION OF THIS
PRODUCT IS.
SAFE FOR ORDINARY RECOGNIZES
SAFE GRASS --
IS IS RESULTING IN THIS THIS
IMPORTATION --
LOOPHOLE IF YOU WILL.
WITHOUT THE APPROPRIATE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES FOR LABELING AND THAT
THAT PRESENTS THE HEALTH
QUESTION BUT I THINK IT ALSO
PRESENTS.
AS I ALLUDED TO EARLIER THE THE
QUESTION OF MARKETING AND
INFORMATION FOR CONSUMERS SO IT
IS SOMETHING THAT STATES MAY
NEED.
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
[inaudible]
IF THE FEDS DON'T STEP UP BUT I
BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME OF OUR
OUR FRIENDS IN CONGRESS ARE.
MAKING THIS --
KNOWN AMONG THEIR COLLEAGUES AND
SOLUTIONS MAY BECOME.
OKAY THAT'S GOOD BECAUSE WE'VE
LOOKED AT SOME LABELING ISSUES
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
AND THOSE DISCUSSIONS USUALLY
END UP KIND OF LEAVING IT
BECAUSE OF SOME PROGRESS IS
BEING MADE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND IF THAT'S NOT HAPPENING I I
I KNOW --
LABELING IS A CONTROVERSIAL
SUBJECT BUT WHAT'S AT STAKE IS.
NOT JUST INFORMATION TO
CONSUMERS BUT POTENTIALLY THE
HEALTH OF OUR OWN INDUSTRIES
HERE IN IN CALIFORNIA SO IT'S A
VERY THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT AND APROPOS OF OTHER
PARTS OF THE CONVERSATION IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING
THINGS THAT [inaudible]
OUR ANTITHETICAL DESTRUCTIVE TO
WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING THAT WE
HAVE TO BE HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHERE WE
NEED TO STEP IN AND BOTH THE
REGULATIONS OR HAVE THE RIGHT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
STRUCTURE IN ORDER TO HEAD OFF
SOME THINGS THAT WE KNOW WILL BE
HARMFUL TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
ABSOLUTELY AND AND AND CERTAINLY
WILL WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
LOOKING CAR TO LOOK INTO THIS
DEEPLY WITH YOU YOUR STAFF AND
AND WILL --
WILL BE IN TOUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT MR BUT THE PRESSURE PLEASE
DON'T.
THANK YOU UP. TO GOD THAT IS ONE
OF MAKE A STATEMENT FIRST AND
THEN FOLLOW THE QUESTION SO YOU
KNOW AS LEGISLATORS.
YES ON THIS COMMITTEE SAID ON
WATER PARKS WILDLIFE MOM SEVERAL
DIFFERENT SELECT COMMITTEES IN.
AND SO WE HAVE TO BALANCE I MEAN
IT'S A BALANCING OUT FOR A
LEGISLATOR I MEAN MOST OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COME TO US
ARE.
FOCUSED ON THEIR ISSUE.
SO YOU OBVIOUSLY THIS GROUP IS
FOCUSED ON THE FISHERY.
AND AS JOHN MENTIONED ANY TOLD
ME WAS GONNA TALK ABOUT SITES AS
WORKERS HE KNOWS I SUPPORT IT
AND I THINK IT'S HEALTHY HEALTHY
CONVERSATION TO HAVE.
SO WE'VE INCREASED THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA DOUBLED
IT SINCE THE LAST TIME WE
INCREASED THE WATER.
AVAILABILITY IN CALIFORNIA.
SO AS A LEGISLATOR NOT ONLY ME
BUT OTHER LEGISLATORS REPRESENT
IN THE VALLEY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT YOU KNOW THEIR AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY REPRESENT I
AM ALWAYS SEEKING YOUR BE TALK
ABOUT FIRE BECAUSE IT'S THE
BIGGEST THREAT TO MY WATERSHED
IN MY COMMUNITIES AND SO THOSE
ARE THE THINGS.
THAT I FOCUS ON BECAUSE THAT'S
MOST PRESSING THING. FOR FOR MY
CONSTITUENCY WELL ALL OF US
OTHERS SIMPLY ALL EIGHTY OF US
HAVE SOME ISSUE THAT'S IN OUR
BACKYARD THAT WE'RE FIGHTING FOR
WERE TRYING TO CORRECT.
BUT AS A LEGISLATOR AS A
HOLISTIC LOOK AT THE WHOLE
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE DECISIONS THAT ARE
REALLY TOUGH TO MAKE WHETHER
WE'RE GONNA.
ADD STORAGE ARE WE GOING TO FIX
THE PROBLEM WITH THERMAL LEGAL
ARE WE GONNA THIN ARE FORCED.
ARE WE GONNA TALK ABOUT HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEFECATING ALONG
OUR RIVERS AND LEAVING SYRINGES
AND ALL KINDS OF HEALTH ISSUES
HONOR EMITTERS OF MILLION THINGS
WE WORK ON SO I AND I TRY TO
TIME COME UP WITH AS A
LEGISLATOR AS OF APPROACH OF
WHERE CAN I MOVE.
THE NEEDLE IN THE FURTHEST
CORRECTION TO AND TRY TO KEEP AS
MANY PARTIES HAPPY AS I CAN
WHILE STILL.
MAKING A LOGICAL GOOD DECISION
THAT AND IMPACTS AND HELPS OUR
ENVIRONMENT AT THE SAME TIME SO
I JUST STAGE THAT THIS QUESTION
WITH.
WHAT IS THE BALANCE?
AN INMATE AT PUT YOURSELF IN MY
SHOES AND SOMEBODY HAS TO MAKE
THAT BALANCE DECISION.
NOT ONLY FOR MY DISTRICT BUT FOR
THE WHOLE OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
ECONOMY.
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND AND SO WHAT IS THE ANSWER TO
THE SOLUTION TO DO WE BUILD WHAT
WAS STORAGE WITH THE THERMAL
LEGAL ISSUES WITH.
SO CAN YOU GIVE ME SOME IDEA
WHAT YOU'RE WHAT IF YOU WERE MY
POSITION HOW WOULD YOU SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS THAT WERE FACED.
NOT JUST FOCUSED ON ONE ISSUE.
I'LL TAKE A STAB AT THAT WITH
ANY MAJOR DEVELOPMENT PROJECT
THERE'S ALWAYS THE DRAFTY I ARE
YEAH YES IF IT'S A BIG ENOUGH
PROJECT AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
HERE.
AND CITY OF W. WHO HAS SALMON
EXPERTS HAVE OPINED.
ABOUT SITES AND IT SEEMS THAT
THE SITES JOINT PROJECT
AUTHORITY.
BASICALLY JUST NEEDS TO TAKE
THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS TO HEART
GO BACK AND REWORK THE THE I.
YES AND LET'S SEE WHERE THE
CARDS FALL THEY'RE NOT SAYING
DON'T BUILD IT THEY'RE JUST.
PUTTING SOME SIDE BOARDS ON SOME
SUGGESTED MITIGATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROJECT DOESN'T
HARM SALMON ANYMORE THAN THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN HARMED AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF SO IT'S NOT A
BLACK OR WHITE EITHER WAR.
IT'S A PROBABLY YES WITH SIDE
BOARDS IS HOW I UNDERSTAND CITY
OF W'S POSITION HERE.
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PANEL PLEASE
MISS ROBIN AND CERTAINLY IT JUST
JUST WITH RESPECT --
SOME OF OUR DAILY TO THE TO THE
NOTION OF BALANCE.
WITHOUT QUESTION POPULATIONS ARE
INCREASING AND WITHOUT QUESTION
THE POPULATION OF OF SALMON
FISHERMEN AS AS JIM ANDERSON --
ATTESTED TO HAS DECREASED
MARKEDLY I WOULD SUBMIT THAT.
THERE THERE NEEDS TO BE A
RESTORATION OF BALANCE.
IN IN THE DIRECTION OF PROVIDING
FISH FOR FISHING COMMUNITIES AND
pIMPORTANT RESOURCE AS YOU
POINTED OUT INYOUR OPENING
COMMENTS.
IT'S CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN THE
OCEAN AND INLAND IN UPLAND AREAS
THAT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PROMOTE.
THE LARGEST TRANSFER OF BIOMASS
TWO IN THE WATER IT WEIGHS
ANYWHERE.
IN THE WORLD IS A HEALTHY SALMON
RUNS.
LIENS OF POUNDS OF OCEAN
NUTRIENTS BINGLE DEPOSITED.
INTO FORESTS AND AND AND AND
VALLEYS AND PLAINS.
ARMED WITH NEW ON ON THE THE
NOTION OF CONSTRUCTING SITES I
THINK WE WE NEED TO SEE A NEW D.
E. R. -- WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT ADDITIONAL.
SCRUTINY ON WHAT THE IMPACTS TO
OTHER RIVERS WOULD BE --
TRINITY RIVER IMPACTS --
THAT ARTS ELUCIDATED IN IN THE
P. E. I. R. IT'S IS IT ADMITTED.
MISTAKES MADE IN THE MODELING --
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN ADDRESSED IT
WE NEED TO THROTTLE BACK THERE'S
NO RUSH.
PROP ONE FUNDS WILL BE THERE.
SO GET IT RIGHT WE NEED TO GET
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT --
UP TO THE STANDARD THAT THAT WE
WILL DEMAND --
IN ORDER FOR PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR
THIS PROJECT.
NOTHING'S OFF THE TABLE BUT
TERMS OF BALANCE THE SCIENCE
NEEDS TO BE.
AT THE FOREFRONT [inaudible]
RETURNS.
IN TERMS OF BALANCE WE NEED TO
GET FOR SALMON STAMP WE NEED TO
GET BACK TO THE FOUR MILLION
ENHANCEMENT FISH TO WE USED TO
HAVE -- WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DUMP THEM IN
THE OCEAN AND ALLOW THEM TO
RETURN AND BE IN THE OCEAN
FISHERIES DAN AND RIVER
FISHERIES.
AND AS AS THE SYSTEM REBUILDS AS
WE GET BETTER SEASONS THAN THAN
WE CAN DEVELOP OTHER THINGS BUT
THESE ARE THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING THROUGH THE
DROP IN THERE SHOWING GOOD
RESULTS AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED
TO GET BACK TO OUR FOUR MILLION
ENHANCEMENT FISH SO WE COULD.
PUT HIM SOMEWHERE WHERE WE THINK
IS THE BEST PLACE TO PUT IT.
PLEASE YEAH DOES ONE MAKE A
FOLLOW UP CALL I BASICALLY
STAYED THE QUESTION BECAUSE THIS
IS THIS FOR A DIFFICULT POSITION
AS A AS A LEGISLATOR WHO CARES
ABOUT ALL THOSE ISSUES.
AND I I KNOW I WANNA HEALTHY.
FISHERY AND I ALSO WANT FARMERS
TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE FOOD THAT
I CAN EAT.
AND I HAVE TO WEIGH THAT BALANCE
OUT AS A LEGISLATOR IN THOSE ARE
DIFFICULT THINGS.
AND AND SO I JUST WANT TO SAY I
LOVE THIS COMMITTEE AND I LOVE
WORKING WITH YOU ALL.
AND I LOVE THE PEOPLE THAT DO
WHAT THEY DO I ALSO LOVE FARMERS
TO PRODUCE FOOD I CAN EAT AND SO
THERE'S A THERE'S A BALANCE TRY
TO STRIKE AND THAT'S WHY THE
FORCE THAT.
PLACE WHERE.
WE HAVE THE BILL THE BILL AND
I'VE BEEN VERY FROM ANY OF THESE
IS WITH THE FOR SERVICE AND AND
I BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW WE HAD
FIRE SUPPRESSION FOR A HUNDRED
YEARS.
IT'S NOT RIGHT WASN'T THE
LIGHTNING WOULD STRIKE IN OUR
FORCE WOULD BURN.
EVERY TWELVE YEARS HISTORY WILL
SHOW US.
AND WE'VE MESSED THAT PROCESS UP
AND NOW WE NEED TO GET BACK IN
THERE AND CORRECT THAT PROCESS
AND I KNOW THAT IF WE DO GOOD
MANAGEMENT OF OUR OF OUR FOREST
WE WILL INCREASE THE YIELD OF
WATER.
AT THE TIME WE WANTED.
AND AND HAVE GOOD CLEAN WATER
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
I'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON BUT I JUST
SHARE WITH YOU MY FRUSTRATIONS
OF TRYING TO BE A LEGISLATOR
THAT ACTUALLY
CAN HOLISTICALLY BALANCE THIS
AWESOME GREAT STATE THAT GOD
GAVE US
WITH ALL THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE ALL FACED WITH AND TRY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL THE
INTERESTED PARTY SO I JUST
BROUGHT THAT OUT NOT FORM TO
JUST.
KIND OF GIVE YOU SOME OF THE
FRUSTRATION AND AND I ALWAYS
CHALLENGE PEOPLE TO HEY DON'T
TELL ME YOU'RE JUST YOUR PROBLEM
HELPME FIX THE HOLISTIC
PROBLEMS THAT I THAT I'M FACED
WITH.
AND NOT ONLY JUST ME BUT EVERY
IN THEIR DISTRICT BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO WAR BASICALLY SOMETIMES
YOU WIN AND SOMETIMES YOU LOSE.
AND A BETTER OFF IT'S BETTER IF
WE ALL GIVE A LITTLE BIT AND
FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT WE CAN ALL
STAY HERE AND THRIVE SO.
SHAKE YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SOMEONE
VERY GRATEFUL.
BUT I DID ASK --
THE THE PANEL ABOUT --
ONE TUNNEL VERSUS TWO TUNNELS --
AND THERE IS BEEN A LOT OF TALK
AT SINCE THERE'S GONNA BE A
FOCUS OF GOING DOWN TO ONE
TUNNEL.
THOUGHT THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE
BETTER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT --
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GET A
READ FROM THE EXPERTS WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF US TODAY ABOUT THAT
PROPOSAL.
PLEASE MISS ROBIN.
ALTON DO YOU BRIEF THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLEX ISSUE
BUT THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
AND THANK YOU FOR BRING
ATTENTION TO THE TO THIS --
EMERGING CONCEPT OF OF ONE
TUNNEL.
WITH WITHOUT QUESTION AND
WITHOUT HESITATION.
IT'S MY BELIEF THAT CARVING UP
THE DELTA THE THE CONSTRUCTION
ALONE COULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS TO THIS CRITICAL AREA
FOR FOR JUVENILE SALMON --
IN ADDITION THE LOCATION OF THE
INTAKES THERE'S A PROBLEM IF
WE'RE FOR DESIGNING.
WATER MANAGEMENT SOLUTION. TO BE
RESILIENT TO SEA LEVEL RISE THE
CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES OR SWORD
IS SEISMICALLY --
RIZ ROBUST.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT.
PROJECT AS IT'S CURRENTLY
OUTLINED WITH THE W. R. --
THE INTAKES MAYBE TOO FAR
DOWNSTREAM TO WITHSTAND LONG
TERM SEA LEVEL RISE --
THE SEISMIC QUESTIONS OF THE OF
THE ENGINEERING CONCEPT ARE ARE
ARE.
NOT ANSWERED WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT
THE THE VOLUME OF WATER.
THAT MAY BE TRANSMITTED BY THIS
MONTH THESE TUNNELS WOULD BE --
AND CERTAINLY IT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE --
THOSE THOSE DESIGN CHALLENGES
NEED TO TAKE FIRST AND FOREMOST.
THE OTHER WATER ISSUES THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH --
LIKE PROVIDING MORE NOTCHING AT
THE A BY PASS --
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO HAVE AS MUCH VOLUME AND THAT
THE DELTA THE THE WEST COAST'S
MOST IMPORTANT AND LARGEST
ESTUARY --
MAXIMIZED SO --
A LOT OF WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE I
BELIEVE THAT --
THE WE NEED TO GO BACK THAT THE
PROCEEDINGS AT THE WATER BOARD
NEED TO BE REVAMPED --
START FROM SCRATCH BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW.
NONE OF THE ALTERNATIVES IN ON
THE PERMITTING --
DUMPING THE LEGAL SIDE FOR ME
FOR A SECOND --
IN MY OPINION ARE ANSWERED SO --
A LOT MORE WORK. TO BE DONE.
BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T DISTRICT
MENACE.
I CHUCKLE BECAUSE WE HAVE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT VIEWS ON THIS
AND IT'S RARE --
G. GSA'S OFFICIAL VIEW IS THAT
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD NEEDS TO COMPLETE
ITS PHASE TWO OF THE DELTA WATER
QUALITY UPDATE PLAN FIRST THAT
WILL TELL US HOW MUCH WATER.
IS POTENTIALLY AVAILABLE FOR
EXPORT THROUGH THE DELTA AND IT
SEEMS THAT IS NOT RESPONSIBLE TO
DESIGN A PROJECT TO WE KNOW HOW
MUCH WATER WE ACTUALLY REALLY
HAVE TO WORK WITH.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO TO
QUOTE STAFFORD LAYER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE --
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME WATER
MOVED FROM NORTHERN ALIFORNIA
TO THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY INTO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ACCEPT
THAT AS AN ARTICLE OF FAITH.
THE EXISTING SYSTEM.
THAT.
MOVES THIS WATER AROUND THE
DELTA KILL SALMON RIGHT NOW.
IT KILLS SALMON COULD WE DEVELOP
A BETTER SYSTEM THAT COULD STILL
MOVE SOME WATER AND BE BORE MORE
BENIGN TO THE WILDLIFE.
THEORETICALLY WE COULD --
HAVE WE SEEN IT YET NOT AS FAR
AS WE KNOW AND THIS GOES TO
NOTICE POINT ABOUT.
A NEAT NEED TO TAKE A WHOLE NEW
LOOK AT IT I WOULD ALSO COMMENT.
ON THE LAST GO AROUND WITH THE
TWIN TUNNELS.
I THINK IT WAS G. C. ID WHO
RESPONDED TO THE DRAFT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT AND
THEY HAD SOME REALLY GOOD
COMMENTS ABOUT --
THE INTAKE SCREENS NEAR FREEPORT
IN SACRAMENTO HERE AND THEY
POINTED OUT THE BASICALLY IF
YOU'RE GOING TO PUT IN TAKES IN
A RIVER YOU NEED TO PUT IT IN A
CURVE IN THE BAND BECAUSE IT
FORCES THE WATER SPEED UP.
AND SKEW YOUR BABY SALMON PAST
THE END YOU PUT THE INTAKES IN A
STRAIGHT AWAY YOU'RE GONNA KILL
MORE SALMON RIGHT NOW THEY'RE IN
STRAIGHT AWAY.
SO THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
CONSIDERATIONS BUT FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE STATE WATER BOARD
NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO COMPLETE.
ITS PROJECT.
TO REBALANCE WATER ALLOCATION SO
THE DELTA IS NOT DYING.
HE WAS RE MENACE RICKETS MISTER
ANDERSON.
IN THE END WE WE I WAS GONNA BE
A MINUTE AT THE FLOWS.
MANAGEMENT OF THE PHONE MORE
THAN.
OUR WEATHER'S ONE OR TWO BECAUSE
ONE CAN BE JUST AS BAD AS TO BUT
I THINK THERE'S A THERE'S A
BALANCE THERE THAT WE CAN ALL
WORK WITH.
BUT LIKE HE SAYS WHERE'S
POSITIONS HOW IT IS AND IT'S
JUST LIKE THE PUMPS AREN'T BAD.
EXCEPT WHEN THEY WERE PUMPING
MORE BABY FIRST ROOM THEN THERE
WAS WATER PRACTICALLY YOU KOW.
THERE'S THE MANAGEMENT OF IT IS
IF WE CAN HAVE OVERSIGHT OVER
THERE IS OVERSIGHT.
THAT CAN IN THE CONSTRUCTION AND
THE DESIGN.
THAT WOULD KEEP THE FISH FROM
THE IT WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH A
DIVERSION LIKE THAT.
WILL CHANGE THE WHOLE MIGRATORY
FLOWS. FOR THE SYSTEM BE
DIVERTED SOMEPLACE [inaudible]
WERE RESTRICTED.
WITH THE HATCHERY FISH ON ON
STRAYING IN WITH SOMETHING LIKE
THIS BECAUSE MAJOR STRAYING
INDUSTRY AND THE FIRST RETURNING.
TO THEIR STREAMS THESE ARE
THINGS THAT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
LIKE.
WE DON'T WANT TO SHARE THE WATER
IS THIS HOPEFULLY THAT WE CAN
ALL WORK WITH IT.
NOTHING SUBMISSIONS FOR
CONSTRUCTION.
I'M WORKING WITH A GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT.
BELIEVE THAT OUR GOAL IS.
TO PETITIONER'S SHOULDN'T
RESTORE THE FISHERY FISHERIES
AND AVENUE AND RIVER FISHERIES
AND STAY OUT OF THE WATER WARS.
AND SO WE TRY TO WORK ON WHAT WE
COULD DO TO INFLUENCE THAT AND
LIKE I SAY ARE.
MOST COMMON GOAL NOW IS TO GET
BACK TO THE FOUR MILLION
ENHANCEMENT FISH SO WE CAN PUT
HIM IN THE OCEAN [inaudible]
IT CONCERNS.
DISSEMINATED SHOW OF QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE. TWENTY SAY THANK YOU
TO OUR PANEL WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
FOR THE GENERAL NOW GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO THE STATE OF THE
STATE OF THE COMPANY CRAB SEASON
AND WE'RE GONNA BE GETTING AN
UPDATE FROM THE WHALE
ENTANGLEMENT WORKING GROUP.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE FOR
FANTASTIC PRESENTERS --
ON OUR PANEL HERE TODAY.
FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE LORI FRIEND
SHE'S A PRESENT AT CENTRAL COAST
WOMEN FOR FISHERIES.
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME DEAR GOD TO
THE PANEL HE'S A COMMERCIAL
FISHERMAN OUT OF THE DAY GOODBYE.
KELLY SPACES HERE SHE'S IN
MINISTRY OF THE CABINET AND
SCRAP FISHING YOU'RE WORKING
GROUP.
OF COURSE THANK YOU MASTER IT'S
A PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE MARINE
REGION OF THE COFFIN DEPARTMENT
OF FISH WILDLIFE WE WELCOME EACH
OF THE FOUR HI HERE.
TO THE FORUM TICKETS OFF THEY
WERE GONNA CHANGE OVER TO DICK
THEY WERE GONNA GO TO KELLY
THEY'RE GONNA GO TO SAKE.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS FRENCH
FOR ALL OVER WORK LAST NIGHT.
AS USUAL SHE WAS WORKING AT AND
CUSSING THE KITCHEN THE ENTIRE
TIME -- AND
JUST WANT TO SAY HOW GRATEFUL WE
ARE FOR YOUR ORGANIZING --
AND IT MEANS A LOT THAT YOU WERE
HERE EVERY YEAR --
IN MY RIGHT --
I WAS CUSSING IN THE KITCHEN
OKAY.
HEY THERE YOU GO WITH HIS FRIEND
SHE WE IT YOU ARE JUST A JAM AS
I WAS TELLING YOU LAST NIGHT --
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK.
ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES THAT WE'VE
BEEN COMING THROUGH IT HAS BEEN
VERY PERSONAL FOR HER AND HER
FAMILY AND YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO FOR OVER
TO YOU.
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR YOUR NICE COMPLIMENTS
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THAT THE
CANDY IN THE BOX IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE THIS YEAR HEY I KNOW
SOUR PATCH KIDS.
NOW NOW IS IT IS WE HAVE NO
CHOCOLATE AND WE REALIZE THAT
THIS MORNING.
BUT I DOUBT THEY WERE SLUMMING
IT WITH THIS OUR PACKAGE.
I APOLOGIZE --
THAT BEING SAID.
IN LIGHT OF RECENT EVENTS I'VE
HAD TO RE WRITE MY TESTIMONY.
MY ORIGINAL TOPIC WAS THE
CURRENT --
CRAB SEASON IN THE STATUS OF OUR
DISASTER MONEY --
NET KIND AND GOT TOSSED OUT THE
WINDOW.
YESTERDAY YEAH FOUR YEARS OF
WORK BY THE CRABBERS ON THE WELL
INTEGUMENT ENTANGLEMENT --
WORKING GROUP WERE PUT ASIDE AND
SEVERE RAMP IMPACTS ARE COMING
TO US.
WORK THAT WAS ON PAID AN
EXHAUSTIVE.
THIS WAS TIME THAT WAS SPENT
AWAY FROM.
BOATS AND FAMILIES.
TIME THAT WAS SPENT IN GOOD
FAITH. FOR US ONLY TO BE CUT OFF
ATTORNEYS.
WE'VE COME TO A TIME WHEN NGOS.
ARE MAKING THE POLICIES OF THE
STATE BY BULLYING AND LAWSUITS.
THIS THIS IS THE TRUTH AS I SEE
IT.
THESE CRISIS IS ARE BEING
FABRICATED AND SOLVED.
BY THESE BIG.
ENVIRONMENTAL.
BIG BUSINESS ENVIRONMENTALISTS.
DOWN THE LIVELIHOODS OF FAMILIES.
ARE BEING DESTROYED WHILE THESE
NGOS MOVE ON TO THEIR NECKS
FABRICATED CRISIS.
IT'S VERY EASY TO MAKE
REGULATIONS WHY YOU'RE RECEIVING
YOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS
PAYCHECK.
NEVER MIND THAT YOU'RE TAKING
FOOD OUT OF FISHING FAMILIES
MOUTHS.
I AM.
TRULY TRULY DISGUSTED COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN ARE BEING ASKED TO CUT
OFF EITHER THEIR RIGHT HAND OR
THE LEFT HAND AND THAT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR
FORM [inaudible]
CLOSURES.
WILL BANKRUPT SOME OF OUR
YOUNGER FISHERMEN WHO HAVE NO
WHETHER FISHERIES TO BACK THEM
UP.
LOSING PARTS OF OUR SEASON WILL
HURT NEEDLESSLY AND CONSIDERING
THE FACT THAT FISHERMEN HAVE
BENT OVER.
BACKWARDS FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS DID YOU EVER AVOID WHALEN
TANGLING.
THIS AGAIN IS JUST ON ACCEPTABLE.
WE'VE DONE IT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN GOOD FAITH.
THE FACT IS THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THERE HAVE BEEN NO
ENTANGLEMENTS IN THREE STATES.
ZERO THE FACT IS SHIP STRIKES DO
MORE DAMAGE. TO THE WELL
POPULATIONS NO ONE SEEMS TO CARE
ABOUT THAT WHY SHOULD THEY WIN
THE FISHMAN CAN BE MADE OUT TO
BE THE BAD GUYS LET'S JUST
REMOVE THE FISHERMEN
[inaudible]
QUESTION. FOR EVERYBODY IS WHY
IS THE COMMERCIAL FLEET TAKING
THE BRUNT OF THIS.
PROPOSED CLOSURE WHILE
RECREATIONAL FISHERMEN ARE
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE FISHING DO
WELLS KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A WRECK LINE AND A
COMMERCIAL LINE.
FACT THE WELL POPULATION IS-GROWING BY 8% A YEAR.
I ASKED YOU WHAT IS WRONG WITH
THIS PICTURE.
ANOTHER FACT.
THE CRAB FISHERY USED.
IN THIS STATE IS ONE OF THE
STATE'S OLDEST COMMERCIAL
FISHERIES IT'S BEEN HELD TO HIGH
STANDARDS AND REMAINED STRONG.
DUE TO MANY INDUSTRY INNOVATIONS
OVER THE YEARS SUCH AS X. SCAPE
RINGS AND COTTONS WE PUT THESE
DAYS THESE THINGS IN NOT THE
STATE WE DID IT FOR OURSELVES TO
KEEP OUR FISHERY [inaudible]
SOLID.
THIS CONTINUES TODAY WITH THE
INNOVATIONS THAT FISHMAN SUCH AS
DECALOGUE HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY
ON FACT.
WE NEED THE CROSS TO OTHER CRAP
TASK FORCE RE UPPED NOW NOT IN
THE FALL.
WE COULD SEE ADDED PRESSURE ON
THE SALMON SEASON OVER THE YEARS
THE MANAGEMENT STYLE.
HAS GOING TO CLOSING FISHERIES
RIGHT LEFT AND FORCING IS INTO
THE SAME POT ALL.
GUNS ANY LATERAL FISHING THAT'S
NOT MANAGEMENT.
BEING FORCED TO BRING YOUR CRAB
GEAR IN EARLY THIS YEAR.
PROPOSED.
BRING IT IN.
WILL ADD AN EXTRA DANGER THIS
YEAR --
COMMERCIAL CRABBERS PLAN OUR
STOCK OUT.
IN A MANAGED.
MANAGE WAY OVER PERIODS OF TIME
SPRINGTIME CONDITIONS SUCH AS
AND TESTIFY INTENSIFIED
NORTHWEST WINDS AND OCEAN
CURRENT WILL PLAY HELP GEAR FOR
THE RETRIEVAL FOR SMALLER BOATS.
AND I'M REALLY REALLY CONCERNED
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF YOUNGER
FISHERMEN THEY HAVE SMALLER
BOATS [inaudible]
AND IF ONE OF THEM DIES IT IS ON
THE STATE'S HEAD.
THE DEPARTMENT IS LEGALLY
OBLIGATED TO TAKE SAFETY INTO
ACCOUNT PLEASE FOR THE SAKE OF
OUR FAMILIES BE SMART.
ARM AS FOR THE CRAB SEASON THIS
YEAR.
IT'S BEEN PRETTY SLOW BUT WE
WERE MAKING A LIVING
[inaudible]
AND AS FOR THE ROWD DISASTER
MONEY ADAM IS BECOMING INDUSTRY
JOKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK --
TO FOR SOME QUESTIONS HERE IN
JUST A BIT BUT WE'LL GET THROUGH
OUR PANEL THAT WORKS --
FOR EACH ONE OF THE FOUR WE'RE
NOT GONNA TURN IT OVER TO MR AUG --
COMING INTO US FROM THE DATABASE
THANK YOU AGAIN SIR FOR YOUR
WORK WE WELCOME YOU TO FIVE
MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK --
I'D LIKE TO JUST KIND OF COMMENT
ON SOME OF OUR GEAR INVASION OF
PROJECTS THAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW -- AND
SOY I CAN YOU KNOW FIRST OFF I'D
LIKE TO SAY THAT THE THE ROPE
WAS SYSTEMS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED TO US --
RECENTLY --
ARE JUST REALLY PRACTICAL FOR
THE FISHERY OF THEIRS THEY WERE
NOT ABLE TO DO JUST WON'T
FUNCTION WITH THE WAY WE WORK
OUR GEAR.
PHIL WHAT I'VE SEEN HAPPEN IS
THAT THE GEAR INNOVATORS HAVE
TURNED OF MEN TO ITEMS THAT
DON'T NECESSARILY IMPEDE OUR
ABILITY. TO TO FISH AND REDUCE
THE IMPACT IT.
THEY'RE THEY'RE REDUCING THE
IMPACT ON THE ENTANGLED ANIMALS.
SO THE IDEA IS TO REMOVE THE
WEIGHT OF THE CRAB TRAP.
QUICKLY.
AND KEEP THE LINES FROM HITCHING
ON THE THE THE ANIMAL ITSELF.
THE DEVICE IS A SEPARATE THE
LINES IN THERE BASICALLY COLD
LINE CODERS --
THIS PARTICULAR PRODUCT CAN BE
OF SET OF RETENTION DEPP'S
SPEEDS AND A TIME TIME
SPECIFICALLY IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THE LONGER.
NEAR ME IF IT TAKES JUST A FEW
SECONDS TO BRING UP THE GEAR.
IF THE PART IS PULLED FOR A LONG
DRUG FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
LINE COULD POTENTIALLY CUT THE
CUT THE ROPE.
AND ALLOW THE POT TO FALL OFF
AND MINIMIZE THE THE IMPACT TO
THE ANIMAL.
MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN PUT THIS --
TRY THESE LINE CODERS IN THE
FIRST TEN FATHOMS OF THE OF THE
GEARED TO BE ABLE TO GROUP
THAT'S LEFT.
AND POSSIBLY ALLOW THE ANIMAL TO
FREE FREE ITSELF AND POTENTIALLY.
YOU KNOW INCREASE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO DISENTANGLE
THE ANIMAL QUICKER.
OR EASIER EASIER THE OTHER THING
WE'RE WORKING ON IS --
GPS BOOTIES --
AND WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO BE
TESTING THOSE AGAIN HERE VERY
SHORTLY -- I
REALLY TRULY BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL REDUCE THE NUMBER OF LOST
POTS AND HELP US TRACK THE
ANIMALS IF THEY DO GET ENTANGLED
[inaudible]
YOU'RE GONNA.
BUT THE LINE CUTTER CENTIMETER
UP THIS WILL TAKE YOUR TIME SO
JUST EXPLAIN HOW THE BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO BE --
TO SEE.
THE WAILING TANGLES EXACTLY AS I
JUST WALK US THROUGH THAT REAL
QUICK OKAY --
YOU KNOW MY MY MY THOUGHT WAS
THAT YOU KNOW I MEAN WE CAN'T
REALLY LOSE THE GEAR WE DON'T
WANT TO BE YOU KNOW HAVING THE
LINE CUT.
IN SAY YOU KNOW ALL I WORKED YOU
KNOW SO IDEALLY WHAT I'D LIKE TO
DO IS BE ABLE TO PUT IT ONLINE.
AND POTENTIALLY DIRECTLY BEHIND
A TRUCK OR SOMETHING TO SEE HOW
LONG YOU KNOW GIVE GIVE IT TIME.
TO PULL ON THE LINE AND
POTENTIALLY COATED IN RELEASE
YOU KNOW A OB CHIC.
ON LAND SO WE KNOW KIND OF WHAT.
AMONG THE TIME DAY INTO QUESTION
YEAH A OKAY OKAY OKAY AS IS.
YEAH I KNOW IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S
KIND OF A HOW HOW THEY WORK BUT
THERE THEY ARE.
YOU KNOW THEY I FEEL LIKE IF WE
CAN IF WE CAN GET THE LINE OFF
THE ANIMAL QUICKLY OR GET THE
WEIGHT OFF THOUGH AND THE LINE
QUICKLY.
THAT THE DAMAGE IS LESS NO I I I
REALLY HOPE THAT THAT'S STILL
THE WAY IT'S GOING TO WORK
[inaudible]
ON IN THE SHOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE
WE WE'VE WE'VE ALSO HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO LINE PROFILE TESTING WITH
SENSORS ON THE LINE SO THAT WE
CAN KND OF GET AN IDEA.
HOW THESE LINES?
LATE IN THE WATER UNDER
DIFFERENT CONDITIONS SEE
CONDITIONS --
TYPICALLY THAT ENDS UP BEING A
TWO DIMENSIONAL.
OF GRAFT YOU CAN SEE OPEN DOWN
BUT YOU CAN'T SEE FORWARD AND
BACKWARDS AND YOU ALSO CAN'T SEE
IF IT MAKES A LOOP.
SO I'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK -- OR
AM GOING TO BE WORKING WITH THE
BIG MARINE LAB WITH UTILIZING
OUR VIS. TO TAKE A LOOK AT THESE --
DIFFERENT LINE PROFILES VISUALLY
AND SEE IF WE CAN SEE.
UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS.
WITH A LONG LINE MAKES LOOPS
WITH THE ROUTE LADIES STRAIGHT
OVER THERE IT IS OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY.
YOU KNOW FOR ENTANGLEMENTS TO
OCCUR.
MORE READILY.
SO.
THESE ALL ARE GOING TO BE BE
TESTING THESE THINGS VERY
SHORTLY I SAY WITHIN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
AND THE ONE THING I WANT TO SAY
IS YOU KNOW --
HONESTLY DON'T GIVE UP ON US
WE'RE TRYING.
WE'RE TRYING EVERYTHING WE CAN
AND YOU KNOW I'M WILLING TO TEST
ANYTHING WE CAN TO TO TRYING. TO
TO REDUCE THE IMPACT SO THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
NEVER WILL GIVE A PROMISE YOU
THAT --
INDISCREET FOR YOU HERE THIS
TURNED OVER TO THE STATES WE
WELCOME YOU AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK IN
CONGRATULATIONS MY GOODNESS ON
THE HONOR AND IT HAS BEEN OUT OF
THE WHOLE GROUP --
IN JUST WANT TO SAY HOW GRATEFUL
WE ARE --
THROUGH WORKING THROUGH THIS IN
SOME REALLY CHALLENGING TIMES
FOR RESOURCE YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES THANKS FOR JOINING US
AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR THANK
YOU COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME AND
MY FELLOW.
COLLEAGUES HERE MY NAME IS KELLY
SEES ONLINE THE PRINCIPAL AND
COFOUNDER OF STRATEGIC GROWTH
CONSULTING AND TOGETHER WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FOR SHELL FISHER I
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF SERVING.
AS THE ADMINISTRATOR AND
FACILITATOR THE COMMITTEE SO
MUCH FOR HAVING US HERE TO BE
ABLE TO TALK A BIT ABOUT THE
WORKING GROUP'S RECENT AT BIRTH
RECENT EFFORTS AND ACTIVITIES --
AS YOU ARE LIKELY AWARE THE
WORKING GROUP IS CHARGED WITH
ADVISING THE STATE ON STRATEGIES
AND SOLUTIONS THAT HELP SUPPORT
THRIVING WE'LL POPULATIONS WHILE
ALSO A THRIVING AND PROFITABLE
DUNGEONS CRAB FISHERY.
AND TO ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL THE
WORKING GROUP CONTINUES TO FOCUS
THEIR ATTENTION ON ALL ASPECTS
OF ADDRESSING THE ISSUE WILL
ENTANGLEMENTS FROM GEAR
INNOVATIONS LIKE DICK WAS JUST
SPEAKING TO TO THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE RISK ASSESSMENT AND
MITIGATION PROGRAM OR RAMP.
THE RAMP WHICH WAS PILOTED
DURING THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN FISHING SEASON AND
BECAME FULLY OPERATIONAL AS OF
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN UTILIZES INFORMATION ON
FOUR FACTORS. TO IDENTIFY AND
ASSESS ELEVATED LEVELS OF
ENTANGLEMENT RISK AND DETERMINE
THE NEED FOR VOLUNTARY OR
MANDATORY MEASUREMENT MEASURE
MANAGEMENT MEASURES TO REDUCE
RISK OF ENTANGLEMENT.
THOSE FOUR FACTORS INCLUDE AT
THE RATE OF ENTANGLEMENTS THE
CONCENTRATION OF WALES THE
FISHING DYNAMICS AND
OCEANOGRAPHIC OR FORAGE
INCLUDING PRECONDITIONS.
WHEN AY OF THESE FACTORS
INDICATE AN ELEVATION IN
ENTANGLEMENT RISK A GROUP OF
EXPERTS INCLUDING AGENCIES
FISHERMEN ARE NGOS SCIENTISTS
RESEARCHERS AND OTHERS CONVENE
AND EVALUATION TEAM? TO REVIEW
AND REQUEST ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO HELP ASSESS THE
SITUATION AND INVESTIGATE HOW
ONE FACTOR MAY BE INFORMED OR
INFLUENCING OTHERS TO FOR
EXAMPLE LOOKING AT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN SEASON
DELAYS.
SEASONAL WILL MIGRATION PATTERNS
AND PRE DISTRIBUTION AND HOW
THOSE INTERACT WITH ONE ANOTHER.
AND AS NEEDED TO DEVELOP
MANAGEMENT MEASURES FOR THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT FOR
SMALL PLACE CONSIDERATION.
RAPPER LIES ON A VARIETY OF DTA
INPUTS AND RESEARCH TOOLS
INCLUDING AERIAL SURVEYS
LANDINGS DATA WILL WATCH DATA
OCEANOGRAPHIC SURVEY INFORMATION
ENTANGLEMENT REPORTS AND ON THE
WATER OBSERVATIONS.
BY FISHERMEN.
PER THE WORKING GROUPS TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THEY THEY HAVE REQUESTED I
SUPPORT TO IMPROVE AVAILABLE
RAMP DATA STREAMS AND THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCILS TAKEN STEPS
TO BEGIN BEING RESPONSIVE TO
THESE REQUESTS.
AN ACTIVE FISHERMAN'S TAX THREAD
HAS BEEN PROVIDING A DIRECT
CHANNEL TO DEPARTMENT MANAGERS
TO SHARE REAL TIME INFORMATION
ON WHAT FISHERMEN ARE SEEING ON
THE WATER.
I IN RESPECT TO BOTH CURE
CONCENTRATIONS WHEELED
DISTRIBUTION AS WELL AS PREY AND
FORAGE --
CONDITIONS THIS IS ALSO FOR THE
FACILITATION TEAM AND THE
AGENCIES UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE RISK IS BEING AS A CONCERN
OF ENTANGLEMENTS WE CHECK IN
WITH THE FISHERMEN TO SEE WHAT
THEY'RE WHAT THEY'RE OBSERVING
ON THE WATER.
THE EVALUATION TEAM PROCESS STEP
TWO OUTCOMES ARE SURE BROADLY
VIA THE WORKING GROUPS EMAIL
LIST THAT UNDESCRIBED TASK FORCE
EMAIL LIST AND POSTED ON BOTH
THE WORKING GROUPS WEBPAGE VIA
THE PC'S WEBSITE.
AND ALSO OTHER CHANNELS.
AS THE COMMITTEE IS AWARE AND
CERTAINLY HELP TO MAKE POSSIBLE
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH NINE I
GAVE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT THE ABILITY TO
RESPOND IN CASES OF INCREASED
ENTANGLEMENTS RISK.
AS THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED
EARLIER THE DEPARTMENT IS
DEVELOPING A REGULATORY PACKAGE
TO FORMALIZE THE RAMP IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE WORKING
GROUP AND HAS A STATUTORY
DEADLINE TO DO SO BY NOVEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY THE WORKING GROUP
MOST RECENTLY MET IN ON MARCH
NINETEENTH WHICH BELIEVE OR NOT
THAT WAS TUESDAY --
I PER THE AGENCY'S REQUEST AND
THIS CONVENING OF THE EVALUATION
TEAM WAS AS A RESULT OF SOME
REPORTS THAT WERE COMING IN THAT
WAY --
CONCENTRATIONS WERE STARTING TO
INCREASE WHEN THIS TRANSITION
TIME WERE PARTICULARLY HUMPBACKS
AND BLUES ARE STARTING TO MAKE
THEIR WAY TO THEIR MOST
HUMPBACKS ADD TO THEIR
TRADITIONAL FEEDING GROUNDS.
AND SO THE AGENCIES MOBILIZED TO
AERIAL SURVEYS WERE CONDUCTED ON
MARCH FIFTEENTH AND MARCH
SIXTEENTH.
THE EVALUATION TEAM CAME
TOGETHER --
ON MARCH NINETEENTH AND
ULTIMATELY ARRIVED AT THAT THE
WHEELS HAVE NOT FULLY ARRIVED
THAT THEY ARE STARTING TO COME
ONLINE.
THAT CURRENTLY LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S GOING TO BE A GOOD KRILL
IN ANCHOVY YOUR HEAD --
IN THAT THEY'RE ALSO SEEMS TO BE
SOME SHIFTING THAT'S HAPPENING
RELATED TO EL NINO CONDITIONS
LOOKING AT A MILD EL NINO -
80% CHANCE OF A MILD IT'S A MILD
ON THE NEW YORK IN THE SUMMER.
AND SO THIS INFORMATION --
WAS COMPILED A RECOMMENDATION
WILL BE GOING TO THE DIRECTOR
EARLY NEXT WEEK AND AS PART OF
THAT RECOMMENDATION AN ADVISORY
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED TO THE FLEET
REGARDING THESE FACTORS AND
LOOKING AHEAD --
INTO THE SPRING OR THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS TO BE MORE HONEST
OR MORE ACCURATE --
AND THAT A MEETING WILL BE HELD
AS THE SET AS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED ARE JUST IN HIS IN HIS
TESTIMONY MEETING WILL BE HELD
NEXT WEEK.
WHERE THE EVALUATION TEAM THE
WORKING GROUP WILL COME BACK
TOGETHER CONTINUE TO ASSESS
THESE RISK ASSESSMENT FACTORS
AND POTENTIALLY COME UP WITH
ADDITIONAL?
RECOMMENDATIONS AND POTENTIAL
MANAGEMENT MEASURES.
THE WORKING GROUP CONTINUES TO
BE VERY COMPETITIVE TO THE WORK
AND EXCUSE ME THE WORKING GROUP
CONTINUES TO BE COMMITTED TO
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THE LEGISLATURE.
NASH MEAN FISHERY SERVICE THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL AND THE
DENTURES CRIME TASK FORCE TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
REDUCE SWELLING HANG WITH RISK
AND TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
STATE'S NEEDS.
PLEASE DON'T HESITATE TO LET ME
KNOW IF YOU NEED ANY MORE
INFORMATION AND I THINK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME TODAY THANKS
CHUCK THINK SO MUCH CAN BE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK I HAVE A
FOLLOW UP IN WHAT WAY.
TO GET THROUGH THE REMAINDER THE
PAIN ONLY WELCOME SEMESTER TO
THE COMMITTEE HE'S A PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE MARINE REGION
CUFF AND PART AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE WE WELCOME YOU SIR YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES SO GIVE ME ONE
MINUTE PROMPT FOR RESOURCE.
THANK YOU --
CENTER MCGUIRE COMMITTEE CHAIR.
MY NAME'S SAKE MASTERMAN THE
INVERTEBRATE PROGRAM MANAGER.
I WAS ASKED TO KIND OF DO A
RECAP ON THE CRAB SEASON AND THE
WORKING GOUP MUCH OF IT HAS
ALREADY BEEN SAID TO MY
PRESENTATION WILL BE THANKFULLY
SHORT -- AS
YOU'VE HEARD --
THE CRAB SEASON THIS YEAR WAS
DELAYED BOTH DUE TO DEMO CAN
QUALITY ISSUES --
WE WERE A LITTLE SURPRISED AT
THE EXTENT OF THING POOR QUALITY
CRAB TO THE POINT WHERE WE'RE
TALKING OF PROCESSORS.
ASKING US TO DELAY THE SEASON
EVEN BEYOND THE STATUTORY
GUIDELINES CURRENTLY SO THAT WAS
AN INTERESTING PROBLEM ALL THE
WAY UP IN OREGON.
DISTRICT TEN IN SOUTH SEEM TO
HAVE A SIMILAR YEAR IN TERMS OF
YIELD -- AS
PREVIOUS HERE.
THE NORTHERN DISTRICTS APPEAR TO
BE COMING AND QUITE A BIT LESS
THAN LAST YEARS WE'VE SEEN A
SHIFT IN CRAB ABUNDANCE --
IN THE NORTH PARTICULARLY --
OF SOMETHING I REALLY WANT TO
POINT OUT IS DURING THE DEMO
EVENT WE DISCOVERED AN
INCONSISTENCY BETWEEN THE
TRISTATE MEMBER.
HEALTH AGENCIES INTERPRETATION
OF FDA GUIDELINES WHICH CREATED
QUITE A KERR FALAFEL --
AND WE ARE WORKING TO RESOLVE
THAT THIS SPRING AT TRI STATE
MEETING DEVOTED SOLELY TO
RESOLVING THIS DISPUTE AND WHAT
THAT WAS.
IS THE F. TAG FDA GUIDELINES HAS
AN INCONSISTENCY IN ITS WORDING.
OREGON AND WASHINGTON
INTERPRETED THAT IF A CRAB COMES
IN AT THIRTY PARTS PER MILLION
IT IS ADULTERATED AND NOT FIT
FOR CONSUMPTION I EAT CAN'T PUT
ON THE MARKET.
CALIFORNIA HEALTH HIS THIRTIES
OKAY.
AND SO IT WAS NORMALLY WE WOULD
HAVE NEVER.
NOTICED THIS DIFFERENCE.
INTERESTINGLY THIS YEAR THREE OF
OUR LAST TEST ON OUR NORTHERN
COAST.
THE AMOUNT MEASURED WAS
[inaudible]
THIRTY EXACTLY.
SO WE SAID GO.
OREGON WASHINGTON SAID DON'T YOU
DARE BRING THOSE CRAB INTO OUR
STATE PERSON MARKETING OR
PROCESSING BECAUSE ADULTERATED.
IT WAS A MASS --
ARE CRAPPER BOYCOTTED --
IN THOSE STATES WASHINGTON
FINALLY CAME AROUND.
BUT WE ALL AGREED ALL THREE
STATES AGREE THAT WAS NOT GOOD
FOR THE MARKET NOT GOOD THE
FISHERMEN SO.
WE'RE PLANNING A MEETING IN MAY
OR JUNE TO GET ALL THE HEALTHY
TO AGENCIES OF THE THREE STATES.
TO GET US ALL ON THE SAME PAGE --
AS FAR AS A WILL AND HANG A
WORKING GROUP YOU ALREADY GOT A
GREAT RECAP ON THE BASIC WORK
BUT GOING FORWARD THIS GROUP IS
GOT MORE WORK AND MORE IMPORTANT
WORK TO DO --
PARTICULARLY YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT
THE GEAR RETRIEVAL --
REGULATIONS THEY WOULD HELP US
DESIGN THOSE THOSE ARE LIKE --
UNDER PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD NOW.
OF COURSE THE RAMP HAS A LOT
MORE WORK TO DO ON REFINING --
RISK ASSESSMENT AND MANAGEMENT
MEASURES BEYOND JUST ROPE
WHISKEY OR BECAUSE PERSONALLY I
SEE ROPER'S GEARS KIND OF A
UNICORN RIGHT NOW --
AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT OTHER
TOOLS LINES CUT AWAY THINGS
OTHER PRACTICAL TOOLS SECOND
HELP MINIMIZE OUR IMPACTS TO
WEALTH --
AND THEN WE ALSO IN PARTICULAR
AS YOU HEARD THAT DIRECTOR
COMMITTED IS TO APPLY FOR AN
INCIDENTAL TAKE PERMIT.
THE CORE WORK OF THAT TO ACQUIRE
THAT IS A HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLAN WE ARE GOING TO DEPEND
HEAVILY ON THE WORKING GROUP TO
HELP US.
DRAFT IN --
FILL OUT ALL THE RETRACTED
REQUIRED ELEMENTS OF THAT THE
MOST IMPORTANT IS THE ACTUAL
MITIGATION AND MANAGEMENT
MEASURES.
THAT ESSENTIALLY ARE THE RAMP
RULE SO WE GOT A GOOD HEAD START.
WE HAVE A CALL WITH THE FEDS
FRIDAY PROTECTED MARINE SERVICES
FOLKS TO KIND OF GET INTO THE
DETAILS OF WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE EXPECTING THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLAN.
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING A LOT OF
WORK BETWEEN NOW AND MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I CERTAINLY
WILL TRY TO ANSWER THEM THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE.
THRESHER ANY ITEMS THAT YOU'D
LIKE TO BE REMOVED VANCE
[inaudible]
I'M. TO TALK ABOUT --
THE REAL TIME.
TEXTING AND FISHMAN BEING OUT
HOW IS AT WORK THE PATIENT KNOW
THAT THERE'S NO ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO CONTACT THE DEPARTMENT
BUT IS THAT A TOOL THAT IS THAT
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
CERTAINLY WILL WELCOME SIX
THOUGHTS ON THIS AS WELL SO
MAYBE TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
DETECTS GROUP AS IT CURRENTLY
STANDS ARE THE FISHERMEN BOTH
RECREATIONAL AND COMMERCIAL WHO
ARE ON THE WORKING GROUP.
ON THE MANAGERS THE DEPARTMENT
MANAGERS WHO ARE PART OF THE
WORKING GROUP AND THEN THE
FACILITATION TEAM --
AND SO WE TRY AND HAVE GOOD
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE THE
WORKING GROUP --
FISHERMEN ARE FROM OUT OF STATE
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO AVALON.
AND WE HAVE ALSO.
REACHED OUT TO VARIOUS AREAS
WHEN THERE IS A FOCUSED A PLACE
WHERE SOME WEATHER SINCE FOCUSED
ATTENTION IS NEEDED.
REACH OUT AND BRING OTHER
FISHERMEN INTO THE CONVERSATION --
DETECTS GROUP FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE FROM A PROCESS
PERSPECTIVE HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE SERRATION.
THANK YOU TO TO HEAR ABOUT IT
FROM A MANAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE
FROM A PROCESS PERSPECTIVE
INCREDIBLY VALUABLE HAS ALLOWED
THERE T BE THAT DIRECT LINE
BETWEEN FISHERMEN AND MANAGERS
WHICH IS I THINK A VERY POSITIVE
THING.
AND HAS ALLOWED TO FILL OUT THE
WHEN -- WHEN
LOOKING AT THE FISHING DYNAMICS
FACTOR AS PART OF THE RAMP TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
FISHERMEN ARE IN SPACE AND TIME
IS SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T HAVE
READILY AVAILABLE AND
QUANTITATIVELY GIVE SOME
CHANGEABLE EXAMPLES OF WHAT HAS?
SEEN IN DISCOVERED OUT IN THE
WATER SO AN EXAMPLE THAT COMES
UP IS WHEN AND THIS WAS LAST
DECEMBER SO.
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN THERE WAS OUT REPORTS
THAT WERE COMING IN FROM
FISHERMEN THAT WERE TALKING
ABOUT CLEAR WATERS NO WHEELS
WHAT'S A GOOD FISHING.
A BIT YOU'RE CERTAINLY THE START
OF THE SEASON LOTS OF LOTS OF
GEAR OUT AND WE WERE GETTING
INPUT IN FROM WHALE WATCHING
OPERATIONS.
THAT THERE WERE HUGE
CONCENTRATIONS OF WALES.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE A
DIRECT LINE OF COMMUNICATION
WITH THE FISHERMEN TO ASK WHAT
THEY WERE SEEING AND THERE WAS A
DISCONNECT AS TO WHAT WAS BEING
OBSERVED ON THE WATER.
THAT THEN LED TO THE ABILITY TO
DO AN AERIAL SURVEY WHICH IS
WEATHER DEPENDENT SO NOT ALWAYS
RELIABLE BUT RELIABLE TOOL THAT
WAS AVAILABLE.
AND THE AERIAL SURVEY WAS ABLE
TO SHOW THAT THERE WERE A GREAT
NUMBER OF WHALES AND THERE WAS A
HUGE AMOUNT OF FISHING HAPPENING
BECAUSE IT WAS DECEMBER.
BUT THERE WASN'T VERY LITTLE
OVERLAP BETWEEN THE TWO AND IT
WAS BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT
DIRECT LINE OF CONVERSATION WITH
THE FISHERMEN TO LET US KNOW
THAT IF WE HAD JUST RECEIVED THE
INFORMATION FROM THE WHALE
OPERATORS WHICH AGAIN WERE
OBSERVING WHAT THEY WERE
OBSERVING ON THE WATER.
THAT THERE MAY HAVE BEEN MORE OF
I NEED TO HAVE TO ACT IN TERMS
OF MANAGEMENT MEASURES QUICKER --
THIS ALLOWED THERE TO BE MORE OF
A BALANCED CONVERSATION AROUND
IT AND THEN THE AERIAL SURVEY
BEING THE OBJECTIVE DATA TO HELP
INFORM.
I'M SUCKING IN AND TAKE ANYTHING
TO OTHER ARE I WAS JUST GONNA
SAY IT IN YOU TOUCHED ON IT
REALLY HELPS US INTERPRET WHAT'S
BEING SEEN BY VARIOUS --
DATA STREAMS INDIVIDUALS.
SO TUESDAY NIGHT UNTIL TEN
THIRTY AT NIGHT I WAS.
TEXTING FISHERMEN ABOUT TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT ONE OF OUR
AERIAL SURVEYS ON THE WATER.
THE SIGN IN USUAL MY LARGE
AMOUNT OF GEAR MORE THAN WE WERE
EXPECTING AND WEIRD.
AND THERE WAS A LOT OF DEBATE
ABOUT THE DATA WAS JUNK --
SOMETHING'S WRONG AND REALLY
WHAT IT WAS MORE ABOUT IS YOU
HAVE TO HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE'RE SEEING HERE WE KNOW WHAT
WE SAW BUT WHY WHAT IS THAT AND
SO.
IT REALLY HELPS US.
WHO DON'T HAVE A PRESENCE ON THE
WATER DO IT KIND OF HELP
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S BEING SEEN OUT
THERE IT'S INCREDIBLY HELPFUL?
THANK YOU.
MY COMMENT ON THIS WOULD BE THAT
IT'S REAL TIME DATA.
AND YOU KNOW WE ARE SPREAD.
ALL UP AND DOWN THE COAST.
AND IT GIVES GIVES THE
MANAGEMENT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY HEAR.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING ON THE WATER
ON A DAILY BASIS?
MINUTE BY MINUTE AND AND I I
REALLY FEEL LIKEIT'S A VERY
VERY USEFUL TOOL.
NO IT'S GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO THIS COMING WEEK IN REGARDS
TO COME IN BEGINNING NEVER --
ALL THREE STATES IN THE SAME
PAGE.
SO WALK US THROUGH WHAT WILL BE
ACCOMPLISHED WHAT YOU HOPE TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED HERE THIS WEEK YOU
HAD SAID YOU CAN GET ON TUESDAY.
TUESDAY'S A WELL WORKING GROUP
MEETING ON SAYS HE DID YOU SAY
THE THOUGH YOU'RE GONNA BEGIN
AGAIN THIS WEEK WITH THE OTHER
STATES I'M SORRY THAT'S MAY MAY
OR JUNE MAY OR JUNE I PASAR.
OKAY NO NO IT'S MY BAD SO WE
JUST WALK US THROUGH A LINE --
AND BECAUSE YOU'RE NEEDING TO
GET ON THE SAME PAGE CORRECT.
AND OBVIOUSLY THE TIME LINE IS
GOING TO BE BACKING IN TWO OF
THE KICKOFF OF THE SEAS CORRECT
SO OUR HOPE OUR EXPECTATION IS.
WE HAVE ASKED THE FDA FOR
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE AS I
MENTIONED.
THERE DOCUMENTS OUR GUIDANCE
DOCUMENTS HAVE AN INCONSISTENCY
IN THEM --
THE ALL THREE STATES ONE
OFFICIAL WORD FROM THE FDA.
WE'RE GONNA BE PULLING HIM IN
THERE AND THEN WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A CONVERSATION ONCE WE HEAR
QUOTE.
THE OFFICIAL INTERPRETATION BY --
EACH STATE'S HEALTH AGENCY HAS A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT PROCESS AND
HOW IT IMPLEMENTS FEDERAL FDA
RULES.
SO OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
EVERY STATE ONCE WE FIND OUT THE
CORRECT INTERPRETATION.
MAKING SURE HOW EACH STATE IS
GOING TO ACTUALLY --
IMPLEMENT IN SOME CASES RULES
SOME CASES POLICY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE NEXT SEASON WE HAVE A
CONSISTENT.
UNDERSTOOD STANDARD ON WHAT'S
ADULTERATED OR NOT [inaudible]
IN ADDITION. FOR YOUR
INFORMATION.
OREGON HAS A EVISCERATION
PROCESS.
WE ARE NOW GETTING WORD BECAUSE
OF THIS THE MORE IT WASN'T A ONE
SHOT PROBLEM IT SEEMS TO BE HERE
TO STAY.
THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO LOOK AT
WITH THE HEALTH AGENCY HOW WE
WOULD SET UP AN EVISCERATION
OPTION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TOO SO WE WILL BE
CONSULTING WITH OREGON AND
WASHINGTON.
HOW THEY WENT THROUGH ND DID
THERE?
IN MY IGNORANCE THE TISSUES --
ONE OF THOSE TWO FOR EXAMPLE
WHAT IT COST THEM TO BE ABLE TO
GET THAT KICKSTARTED.
WE'RE GONNA FIND OUT I'M NOT
SURE BUT THAT'S SOMETHING WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT IT'S
UNCLEAR YET WHETHER THROUGH OUR
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT A HEALTH.
WHETHER IT'S A RULE MAKING OR
IT'S A POLICY APPROACH OR IS IT
THROUGH A BEST --
HAS A PLAN AT THE FACILITY WHERE
WE THAT'S PART OF OUR EXPORT
EXPLORATION GOING FORWARD.
IT'S GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST TWO MORE
QUESTIONS.
SO THE MARINE LAB IT'S GONNA BE
WORKING WITH YOU --
PROTOTYPES.
ACTUALLY THE MARINE LAB HAS AN
R. O. V. E. IT'S GOING TO GIVE
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO LOOK AT
THE LINES VISUAL.
GOT IT THAT'S OKAY.
AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE AND
PROBABLY DO THAT ALL THE TESTING
KIND OF ON A ONE SHOT.
AND THEN UTILIZE EUROBEAT TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT THE LINE
PROFILES GOT A KIND OF THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
WHEN LAURIE TALK WITH US ABOUT
THAT MAY FIRST?
DATE THAT THAT THE DIRECTOR WAS
TALKING ABOUT COMING.
TO WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT.
HE'S BEEN TRYING TO CAST SO I AM
NOT THAT BAD I EXCUSE ME --
I WON'T BE STANDING BY THE
MAILBOX WAITING FOR CHECK --
WOULD BE NICE HOW DO YOU FEEL
[inaudible]
YEAH IT'S LIKE I SAID IT'S
BECOME.
A CRABBERS JOKE --
HOLD WHAT WE'LL DO IT WITH THE
CHECKS GO OFF YEAH.
YOU KNOW IT IS JUST.
LIKE I SAID I BELIEVE IT WHEN I
SEE IT HERE.
ABSOLUTELY NINE EIGHT CM FOLKS
WHEN WAITING FOR AN INCREDIBLY
LONG TIME.
WELL 200-015-2000 SIXTEEN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ONE IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A WAIT YEAH.
IT IS A GOOD WAY TO RUN A
BUSINESS RIGHT AND ALSO
DEFINITELY.
SO CHALLENGING I THINK THAT'S
THE FOR THE P. SAID SO IF YOU
REALLY UNDERSTAND ABOUT HOW MUCH
YOU'RE CARRYING --
AND ALSO WITH THE REDUCED
REVENUE. EIGHT EVEN SEEN COMING
IN AT YOUR OWN BUDGETS I AND IF
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT I DECREASE
ABUNDANCE ON THE NORTH SIDE THIS
YEAR.
DECREASED FASHION THE SOUTH.
IT'S JUST ADDING INSULT TO
INJURY WE CAN HANDLE
[inaudible]
THE FLUCTUATIONS.
IN THE NORMAL CROWD CYCLES WE
CAN HANDLE THAT WE PLAN FOR THAT --
WHEN WE'RE FACED WITH
CIRCUMSTANCES OUT OF OUR
CONTROLS SEASON CLOSURES IT'S
LIKE PAUL WAIT A MINUTE THIS IS
A WHOLE NOTHER ANIMAL
[inaudible]
AND THAT ADDS AN EXTRA LAYER.
ABSOLUTE STRESS A REGISTERED TO
HUGE LAYER OF STRESS.
THIS WAS A THANK YOU TO OUR
PANEL -- IN
SAY HW GRATEFUL WE ARE THAT ALL
OF YOU HERE TODAY ANY OTHER --
CLOSING COMMENTS BEFORE WE
ADJOURN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REALLY NICE JOB.
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK.
THEY DID YOUR NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO OUR THIRD PANEL IN
A IN WE COULDN'T BE MORE EXCITED
TO BE FOCUSING.
ON THE AQUACULTURE INDUSTRY.
AND HEARING ABOUT THE FISHERY
DISASTER RE RELIEF AS WELL AS
LEGISLATIVE UPDATES THIS IS A
BIG PANEL ALL IN.
ONE WE ARE.
GRATEFUL THAT GREAT DEAL HE'S
HERE FROM HUMBLE COUNTY HE IS OF
COURSE WITH A PACIFIC SEAFOOD
AND HE'S GOING TO GIVE US AN
UPDATE ON ISSUES OF AQUACULTURE.
KNOWN OPHEIM IS HERE THE
EXECUTOR SHE SHE KNOWS CAN
PROVIDE AS AN UPDATE ON LAST
YEAR'S LEGISLATION THIRTEEN OR
NINE THIRTEEN TEN HOW THE CRAB
X. ADDRESS --
AND THEN ALSO TALKING ABOUT THE
FISHERIES ON THIS BILL THAT'S
GONNA BE COMING UP LATER THIS
YEAR AND HE'S GOING TO GIVE US
AN UPDATE --
ON FISHERY DISASTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE MAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND
ROB ROSS'S HERE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FISHERIES AND SEAFOOD INSTITUTE
AND RECTOR BUT DECIDED
REGULATORY AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA UP WITH.
A CULTURE ASSOCIATION.
IN HE'S GONNA BE PROVIDING A
LEGISLATIVE UPDATE AS WELL AND
THEN -- DO
WE HAVE TOM TRUMPER --
HERE TO THERE WE GO OTHERS
MISTER FREEZE VICE CHAIRMAN OF
CALIFORNIA'S YOUR CHIN
COMMISSION.
MYSTERY REALLY CANDID --
IT IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGING TIME
VERTICALLY FOR REDDER CHIN I'M
HE'S GONNA BE PRESENTING --
WHY HE SEEN POOR CONDITIONS --
AND SEE FOR XIN URCHIN FISHERIES
IN IMPACTS TO THE INDUSTRY.
AND THE ONGOING NEED FOR
DISASTER RELIEF COMMITTEE SO
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO LET'S TURN
IT OVER TO GREAT THEN WE'RE
GONNA GO TO KNOW WHAT ROB IN
TOWN.
BREAK THE FORESHORES FIVE
MINUTES SIR AND I'LL GIVE YOU
ONE MINUTE FROM THANK YOU FOR
TUNING TODAY SIR.
THANKS FOR YOUR WORK LAST NIGHT.
THANK YOU CENTER REQUIRE BOMB
MISTER CHAIR MISTER COCHAIR.
OM AND MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT --
ARE OBVIOUSLY I WASN'T I I WAS
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE THE ONE
TALKING TODAY MISS MIRANDA HAD
AN UNEXPECTED --
CHILD ATHLETE OF AUNT COME UP
AND SO I'M TAKING HER PLACE.
OUR EFFORTS CONTINUE TO BE TO
IMPROVE THE REGULATORY.
ARM CERTAINTY AND AND PROCESS
THAT SHELLFISH CULTURE
AQUACULTURE FACES GOING THROUGH
ALL IN THIS STATE AND I DON'T
WANT TO THINK --
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR ADVICE
AND HELP.
AND MISTER WOULD YOUR STAFF AND
YOUR SUPPORT IN MOVING THROUGH --
MR STONE SORRY.
ALL RIGHT YOU CAN YOU HIT HIM
FOR ME OKAY MISTER WHAT.
AND AND WE'RE WE'RE SUPPORTING
THE SB SIXTY NINE AND AN
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON RIGHT NOW.
AND I AND I THINK THERE'S
THERE'S A GOOD POSSIBILITY THAT
IT WILL IMPROVE.
ON THE PROCESS WELCOME SCIENCE
WE WELCOME THE OVERSIGHT BY OPC
AND O. S. T. --
OCEANSIDE STRESSED SO WE'RE WE
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO SOME HELP
THERE -- I'M
NOT GONNA TALK TOO MUCH LONGER
BUT I GOTTA TELL YA IT'S NOT
SURPRISING TO ME.
BOMB FROM A FROM A CULTURE EST
THAT.
REALLY REQUIRES AND DEPENDS ON
PRIMARY PRODUCTIVITY IN THE
OCEAN THERE WERE NOT SEEING
OTHER OCEAN SPECIES THRIVE.
OFF --
SHELLFISH HAVE BEEN SLOWER
GROWTH FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS.
MAYBE MORE ON THEIR THEIR THEIR
FAN AND I'M SURE OTHER SPECIES
IN THE OCEAN ARE IN THE SAME
PLACE WE SEE IT FIRST AND
GENERALLY A FEW YEARS LATER WE
SEE IT.
COME OUT AND SALMON AND AND
OTHER --
SPECIES THAT DEPEND ON PRIVATE
PRIMARY PRODUCTIVITY.
I I'M I'M HOPING AT YOU KNOW I
THINK.
LIKE FISHERMEN SHELLFISH FARMERS
ARE THE ETERNAL OPTIMIST AND
THIS YEAR WILL BE THE YEAR IT'LL
BE GOOD THIS YEAR IT'LL BE
BETTER THIS YEAR WE'RE HOPING
THAT THIS WEATHER THAT WE SEE IN
THE LAST --
THREE FOUR MONTHS WILL IT WILL
TURN THE OCEAN AROUND ON AND I'M
I'M COUNTING ON THAT I'M I'M
HOPING THAT THE NORTHWEST WHEN
THIS SUMMER.
THEY WERE ALL SICK OF IT I HOPE
WE'RE SICK OF NORTHWEST WIND
THIS YEAR.
I THANK YOU THINK SO MUCH DOWN
IN REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
PATIENCE AS WELL --
GREAT JOB AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE OR HAVE SOME FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS HERE IN JUST A BIT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
THE SHOP IN TIME HI DEAR TO GIVE
US AN UPDATE IN PLEASE SIR FIVE
MINUTES AND WE'LL GIVE YOU A
MOMENT A PROMPT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GERMAN WIRED
MISTER LESTER NO OPPENHEIM WITH
THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS --
IF YOU IF YOU CAN LEGISLATE AWAY
JUST A FEW WEEKS OF OF CALM WHEN
WEATHER --
THAT WOULD BE GREAT SO WE CAN
GET OUR THEM FISHMAN SOME GOOD.
SOME GOOD OCEAN CONDITIONS WHICH
WHICH WHICH I THINK WE ALL KNOW
OR ARE COMING --
GOOD CIRCULATION BREEDS GOOD
GROWTH AND WITH THE OUTFLOWS
WE'VE SEEN THIS YEAR --
IT LOOKS IT LOOKS PROMISING SO
IT IT I'LL BE BRIEF AS WELL --
SENATE BILL.
THIRTEEN OH NINE IS IT LOOMING
LARGE IN OUR MINDS RIGHT NOW AS
YOU HEARD IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL --
THE WELL ENTITLEMENT WORKING
GROUPS.
THE PROCESS IS GOING TO BE A
MAJOR OCAL POINT.
IN A MAJOR ISSUE OF OF REALLY
NATIONAL.
IMPORTANCE --
AND IT'S A VISIONARY PROCESS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN IN IN IMPLEMENTING
SECTION --
SIX AS WELL AS THE OTHER
PROVISIONS WORK WE'RE GOING TO
BE.
TESTING THE TOOL AT SOME POINT
WE ARE GOING TO BE USING THIS
PROCESS TO MANAGE COMMERCIAL
DUNGENESS CRAB FISHERIES --
TO MITIGATE AGAINST THE RISK OF
WELL ENTITLEMENTS --
FOR THE FIRST TIME [inaudible]
AND THOSE IMPACTS AS WE'VE HEARD
ARE GOING TO BE SEVERE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE.
SIGNIFICANT.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DONE
COLLABORATIVELY.
WE'RE GOING TO BE DONE WITH
FISHERMEN AT THE TABLE.
WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT.
THOSE COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS WE
HEARD EARLIER THAT THE BENEFITS
THAT WE ACHIEVE IN RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT WHEN.
THE USER GROUPS ARE AT THE TABLE --
IT AND AND WORKING TOGETHER WITH
THE MANAGERS WITH WITH
LEGISLATURES LIKE YOURSELVES.
TO DESIGN SOLUTIONS AND AND SO
WE WE THANK YOU.
FOR CHAMPIONING A PROCESS LIKE
THIS.
IN ORDER TO REALLY CREATE A
VISIONARY PROCESS --
THAT THAT ARE GOING TO KEEP THE
INDUSTRY AT THE TABLE AND NOT ON
IT -- AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
SPEAKING OF LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR WE HAVE A FEW EXCELLENT
BILLS --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY TWO THE
THE FISHERIES OMNIBUS BILL
TWENTY NINETEEN I'LL TALK ABOUT
A COUPLE PROVISIONS THERE IN --
THE AS YOU SPOKE TO EARLIER
CENTER WHERE THE THE NEED TO
AVOID THE LANDINGS TAX CRISIS.
OF OF A COUPLE YEARS AGO IS
CRITICAL WE NEED TO PEG LANDINGS
TAXES LENNIX FEES. TO CPI OR
SOME OTHER INDEX --
SO THAT WE CAN.
ITERATIVELY AND COMFORTABLY AND
PRODUCE --
STAND WITH THOSE FEES ARE GOING
TO BE THAT WE DON'T GET INTO
SOME SORT OF HUNG UP SITUATION --
PUNCTUATED EQUILIBRIUM TO THE
TUNE OF THOUSAND OR MORE PERCENT
INCREASE IN TAXES --
IT IT IS DESTRUCTIVE AND
DEVASTATING WE NEED TO AVOID
THAT SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP THERE AND OF COURSE
MAKING SURE THAT THE SEA
CUCUMBER FISHERY --
CONTINUES TO BE A PART OF THE
PORTFOLIO FOR FISHERMEN LARGE
AND SMALL IN CALIFORNIA --
IS IS CRITICAL AND N. AS WE'VE
HEARD WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX
OF ALL KINDS INCLUDING PERMITS
AN ACCESS AND THIS WILL GO A
LONG WAY TOWARDS THAT.
WE'RE ALSO REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
SENATE BILL.
SIXTY NINE WHICH IS CALLED THE
OCEAN RESILIENCY ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN IT'S BEEN GREAT TO WORK
WITH OUR PARTNERS IN THE SHELF
IS GROWING INDUSTRY --
I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT A COUPLE
KEY PROVISIONS IN THAT BILL --
THE BILL WOULD ENHANCE.
THE STATE'S USE OF BEST
PRACTICES FOR OFF SITE RELEASES
OF HATCHERY FISH WHEN DROUGHT
STRIKE WHEN WE KNOW THAT ONSITE
RELEASES WILL BE HARMFUL.
OR WE KNOW THAT CERTAIN BEST
PRACTICES.
FOR OCCUR ALREADY SCHEDULED OFF
SITE RELEASES COULD BE USED THIS
WILL CREATE A POLICY OF THE
STATE.
SO THAT WE WILL USE IT WE WON'T
HAVE TO FIGHT YOU WON'T HAVE TO
BEG.
FOR INVESTMENT IN THOSE KINDS OF
RELEASES THAT'S GOING TO PUT
FISH ON THE BACK DECK --
IT'S GONNA BRING MORE FISH BACK
TO THE RIVER WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON SOME KEY WATER
QUALITY PROVISIONS THAT HAS TO
DO WITH TIMBER HARVEST --
AS YOUR COLLEAGUE MISTER DALI
ALREADY SPOKE --
TO THE CAL FIRE.
IS IT REALLY IMPORTANT AGENCY
FOR THE PURPOSES OF MANAGING OUR
WATERWAYS.
AND THEY HAVE ONE MAJOR -
THE RESPONSIBILITY WHICH IS TO
TRANSMIT TIMBER HARVEST PLANS TO
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
PLAN BOARDS FOR REVIEW BUT THOSE
REGIONAL BOARDS ARE ARE DEEPLY
UNDERSTAFFED AS YOU KNOW --
AND OFTEN THOSE REVIEWS DON'T
OCCUR.
AND SOMETIMES TIMBER HARVEST
PLANS THAT ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH RESPECT TO SENATE POLLUTION
CAN MAKE IT THROUGH --
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT
REVIEW TO OCCUR AND IT WOULD
REQUIRE REGION BOARD TO
RECOMMEND HOW A TIMBER HARVEST
PLAN THAT WOULD.
BE OUT OF COMPLIANCE CAN GET
BACK INTO COMPLIANCE SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE.
TIMBER HARVEST --
THAT OCCURS IT'S PROFITABLE --
AND PROSPEROUS AND DOESN'T
IMPACT ARE CRITICAL SANITARY
WATERWAYS --
OF COURSE ALL OF THIS BRIEFLY
ECHO THE SENTIMENT THAT A SENATE
BILL ONE IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
SALMON FLEEING ORGANIZATION AND
WE WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE SUPPORT.
AND JUST BRIEFLY WE'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT FISHERY DISASTER
ASSISTANCE I WANT TO EXTEND A
HEARTFELT THANK YOU TO SECRETARY
CROWFOOT AND DIRECTOR BONHAM FOR
PROMISING TO LEVERAGE THERESOURCES OF THE STATE. TO SHAKE
THESE FUNDS OUT OF THE FEDERAL
POSSIBLE IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS
THE TIME IS NOW WE ALL KNOW WHY
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THIS HAPPEN VERY SOON --
AND SO I'M CONFIDENT IN THE
STATE -- AND
AND THEIR EFFORTS TO TO WORK
WITH OUR PARTNERS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO DELIVER THESE
FUNDS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE TIME
AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK
YOU SO MUCH OKAY FOR YOUR HERE.
WHEN I MENTION THE FLOOR OVER TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE US AN ALL --
ACCESS UPDATE ON AQUACULTURE --
THIS TURN IT OVER TO MR ROBERT
HASS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I ADVISE THE
CALIFORNIA AQUACULTURE
ASSOCIATION.
AFTER MY LONG ASSOCIATION WITH
EVERYBODY THAT PRODUCES FISH.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FISHERIES AND SEAFOOD INSTITUTE.
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND SEE FOR
INSTANCE BEEN AROUND SINCE
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR IT'S LARGELY
THE GROUP OF ON SHORE SECTOR OF
THE INDUSTRY --
THEY PROCESS.
ROUND FISH INTO PRODUCT FORMS
THAT ARE LITTLE MORE ADAPTABLE
TO THE TO THE HOUSEHOLDS IN OUR
IN OUR STATE.
INTO THE CHEFS AND PRODUCT FORMS
THAT THEY WANT AND FRANKLY
DEMAND --
LET LET ME TALK ABOUT
AQUACULTURE BECAUSE STARTS WITH
A AND AND YOU MENTIONED IT FIRST --
I HAVE SOME A LITTLE HAND OUT
HERE FOR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND OTHERS OF THE END OF A SORRY
JUST THANK YOU.
PUT TOGETHER SOME FACTS AND AND
FIGURES --
WHAT IS AWFUL CULTURE WHAT IS
AQUAPONICS WHAT IS AQUA FINA
WHAT IS?
IT THE FISH FARMERS THEY FARM
FISH.
THEY FARMED OYSTERS ONE DAY WE
MAY FARM --
OCEAN --
FINFISH --
CALIFORNIA FISH FARMERS DO SOME
OTHER THINGS SO THEY STOCK A
100% F THE WARM WATER FISH.
STOCKS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BASS BLUEGILL CATFISH
AND ABOUT HALF OF ALL THE TROUT
THAT STOCK.
THAT LEADS TO LICENSE SALES AT
LEAST A FUN FOR FAMILIES AND
VETERANS AND AND PEOPLE WITH --
ACCESS --
RESTRICTIONS AND IT'S A LOT OF
FUN.
THEY ALSO PRODUCE A VARIETY OF
FISH AND SHELLFISH INCLUDING
ALGAE AN ABALONE.
BASS BLUEGILL CARP CATFISH
CAVIAR MUSSELS OYSTERS
[inaudible]
PERCH.
SEE WE'D STURGEON TILAPIA TROUT
AND MORE --
THEY ARE ACTIVE AQUACULTURE FISH
FARMING IS ACTIVE IN EVERY
COUNTY IN THE STATE --
IT'S GOING TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION FOR FUTURE SEAFOOD
DEMAND.
I THINK OUR FISHERIES AND IN
MANY CASES.
OUR FULLY --
DEVELOPED.
WE KNOW WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
INCREASE OUR TAKE A FISH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO OUR EXPERT.
AND IN OUTSTANDING FISHERY
MANAGEMENT --
BUT OVERALL ON OUR PLANET WE
NEED TO PRODUCE MORE PROTEIN
IT'S GONNA COME FROM AQUACULTURE.
THE OTHER COUPLE OF FACTOIDS.
IT HAS A LOW CONVERSION.
RATE FOR RACING PROTEIN.
AS OPPOSED TO OTHER PROTEINS
THAT WE CAN RAISE LARGELY DUE TO
THE FACT THEY'RE IN WATER AND
THERE'S NO GRAVITY.
THE CONVERSION RATES ARE
OUTSTANDING.
IN ITS NON CONSUMPTIVE --
IT AS FAR AS FRESH WATER THAT IS
THE WATER THAT LEAVES FISH FARMS
IS OF THE SAME OR HIGHER QUALITY
THAN WATER ENTERING THE FISH
FARMS.
ESPECIALLY WITH AGRICULTURAL
NEIGHBORS ENJOYING THE WASTE
WATER THAT WE SHARE WITH THEM.
AND OF COURSE WHEN YOU FARM
MARINE SPECIES THERE'S NO NEED
FOR FRESH WATER. TO PRODUCE THE
FOOD.
AND THEN LASTLY.
CALIFORNIA OCEANS RESOURCE
ENHANCEMENT HATCHERY PROGRAM.
HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS.
IT'S SOUTH OF POINT CONCEPTION.
IT INCLUDES ONLY THE DEDICATED
MARIE IT IS THE ONLY DEDICATED
GREEN FINFISH.
HATCHERY ON THE WEST COAST SO WE
HAVE BEEN --
FARMING --
FINFISH IN CALIFORNIA FOR SOME
THIRTY YEARS --
WITH --
EXCELLENT RECORD OF PRODUCTION
SOME TWO MILLION FISH HAVE BEEN
PRODUCED. TO AUGMENT THE TAKE OF
THE COMMERCIAL FISHING INDUSTRY
AND THE AND THE RECREATIONAL
FISHING INDUSTRY.
LIKE TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT --
PROCESSORS ARE AN EQUAL PART.
OF THE FISHING INDUSTRY WE
EMPLOY MORE PEOPLE ON SHORE IN
THE TO SUPPORT THE FISHERMEN.
THEN THAN THE FISHERMEN
THEMSELVES HAVE --
THE PRODUCT FORMS I TALKED ABOUT --
PUTTING OF FISH TO THE MARKET
PLACE IN THE MARKET FOR A MINUTE
SEPTA WILL TO THEM.
AND IF ANY OF YOU HAVE NOT BEEN
IN A FISH PROCESSING PLANT.
WE HAVE THE MAN IN THE VICE
CHAIRS DISTRICT IN IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
WE INVITE YOU TO COME TAKE A
LOOK AND WALK AROUND AND SEE THE
INVESTMENTS THAT'S BEEN MADE.
IN ORDER TO PROCESS AND MARKET
THE FISSION KEEP IT IN SAFE
STANDARDS AND SEE THE INSPECTION
STANDARDS.
HAZARD ANALYSIS CRITICAL CONTROL
POINT THE MILITARY AND STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
HEALTH STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH.
WE WANT TO TELL YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE'RE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL TO YOU. FOR YOUR
AUTHORSHIP OF SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY NINE LAST YEAR ON LANDING
RECEIPTS AND UP UNTIL THIS POINT.
LANDING RECEIPTS FOR DO.
EVERY TWO WEEKS BY SNAIL MAIL.
I'M IN AN APARTMENT AT A GREAT
IDEA TO REQUIRE ELECTRONICALLY
EVERY DAY --
WITHOUT THE HOUSE OF LITTLE
VICIOUS SO THROUGH YOUR
LEADERSHIP WERE ABLE TO WORK OUT
A DEAL WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
THAT WE WILL REPORT WITHIN THREE
BUSINESS DAYS OF THE RECEIPT OF
THE FISH WHICH IS REESE.
SO NOW THEY GET IT EIGHT TEN
TIMES A MONTH [inaudible]
THEY WILL.
VERSES --
TWO TIMES A MONTH BY SALE A
SNAIL MAIL COLLECT TRONIC GLEE
WE JUST HOPE THEY'RE SOMEBODY
THERE ON A SUNDAY ANDSATURDAY
TO READ.
THE READ THE DATA THAT THEY GET.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THIRTEEN OH NINE AND TEN NOTE
TALKED ABOUT THAT YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
YOUR IT IS SO IMPORTANT WE WE
CANNOT THANK YOU ENOUGH IN THE
SUPPORT THAT YOU HAVE.
BUILT WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES HAS
BEEN ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC AND OF
GREAT ASSISTANCE.
ASSISTANCE --
YOU HEARD ABOUT CRAB.
I WOULD ASSOCIATE MY REMARKS I I
JUST WISH I WASN'T PAID TO BE
LIKE AN OFFICIAL SPOKESMAN
BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO TALK LIKE
LAURIE FRENCH.
BUT WITH MORE FRENCH HEY THERE
YOU GO -- IT
IF.
SARDINE.
RED CEDAR CHIN THE TOP TWO
MINUTES TALK ABOUT --
ARE ARE JUST ABSOLUTELY NEEDED --
THE SARDINE RESOURCE BUSINESSES
STORAGE.
RESOURCE IN CALIFORNIA AND I WE
HAVE BEEN ADVISED AND I'LL
ADVISE YOU OF THAT --
THE NATIONAL OCEANIC AND
ATMOSPHERIC HIS MINISTRATION
I'VE BEEN PUT PUT IN TOUCH WITH
THE TOP PEOPLE THERE.
THEY SAID IT'S A DEBATE BETWEEN
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE AND OMB.
AND WE PROBABLY WON'T SEE
ANYTHING FOR SEVERAL MONTHS.
SINCE WERE MANY MONTHS BEHIND
THE CRAB INDUSTRY --
THAT'S GONNA BE A WHILE BUT
IT'LL BE WELCOME TO HAVE BECAUSE
IN THE CASE OF THE STARTING
INDUSTRY THEY'RE GONNA USE.
MOST OF THE IT IS KIND OF
BUZZARDS LUCK THAT WHEN THEY GO
LOOKING FOR SARDINE POPULATION
TO SET A QUOTA.
THEY DON'T LOOK WHERE THE
SARDINES ARE SO IF WE GIVE THEM.
ANOTHER AIRPLANE OR TWO AND SOME
OTHER VOTES THEY CAN THEY CAN
FIND THAT.
LASTLY I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
IN ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU THE LAST THING I WANT
TO SAY THAT --
YOU KNOW WE HEAR ABOUT THE WISE
MANAGEMENT CITY CALIFORNIA I
AGREE WITH IT.
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT --
COURSE SUSTAINABILITY IS IS
INVOLVES ECONOMIC SUSTAINABILITY
IS FOR THE FISHERMEN.
AND I THINK YOU ALL KNOW THIS
BUT I THINK SOMETIMES WE ALL
FORGET THAT.
FISHERY RESOURCES ARE RENEWABLE
RESOURCES.
THEY COME BACK IF THEY'RE OVER
FISH THEY COME BACK WITH THEIR
STRESSED --
WE DON'T WANT THEM TO BE OVER
FISH WE DON'T WANT THEM TO BE
STRESSED.
BUT IF WE MANAGE IT WISELY.
THAT WE CAN BUILD UPON THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE NOW.
AND THAT'S A GOOD THING FOR
FISHERMEN AND FOR OUR PROCESSORS
AND THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE
PLANTS --
LASTLY I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN.
FOR ALL YOU DO FOR THE
AQUACULTURE INDUSTRY AND FOR THE
CONSUMER SEAFOOD SUPPLY INDUSTRY.
THRUST THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF THINKING TO
LOOK.
AT ROB ROB OUR OFFICES ALMOST
EVERY DAY --
AND MAKING SURE THAT IT WORKS
FOR HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN.
WHO MAKE A LIVING IN FISHERIES
AND AQUACULTURE AND WE CAN'T SAY
THANK YOU ENOUGH --
BECAUSE LOOK IF YOU'RE NOT ON
THE COAST OR IF YOU'RE NOT ON
THIS COMMITTEE CANDIDLY.
IT'S A CHALLENGE A DEBATE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE RIGHT
JUST BECAUSE OF WHAT FOLKS
ASSOCIATE WITH SEAFOOD IS EAT.
I AND NOT --
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE NATURI SOURCE IS THIS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN IT
AND ALL OF YOU ARE SO CRITICAL
TO THAT SUCCESS AND JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU?
AND YOU'RE THE ONES THAT WE NEED
TO SAY THANKS TO BECAUSE YOU'RE
THE ONES THAT ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES EVERY DAY DOING THE HARD
WORK.
AND WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE I'M IN BEING ABLE TO
TAKE THE MESSAGE OUT TO ALL THE
HUNDRED TWENTY HI DIFFERENT
OFFICES WITHIN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY IN THE STATES.
AND WE'RE REALLY REALLY GRATEFUL.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO TURN IT OVER
TO MRTRUMP FOR HE'S A VICE
CHAIRMAN OF THE CONFERENCE YOUR
CHIN COMMISSION.
AN A IF YOU ARE --
A SEA URCHIN FISHERMEN IT HAS
BEEN A REAL CHALLENGE AS OF LATE
WHEN I SAY THANK YOU MR TRUMP
COVER FOR BEING HERE ON IN ALSO
WANTED MOMENTS HE THANK YOU
GOVERNOR NEWSOME WHO.
LITERALLY WITHIN TWO DAYS TURNED
HIS BUT BACK THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE AND STRIPPER THE FLOORS
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK SIR.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
YOU AND THE GOVERNOR --
THIS IS GONNA BE SHORT BUT NOT
SWEET.
THE STATE OF OUR FISHERY.
RIGHT NOW IS.
IN YOUR COLLAPSE.
THE CENTRAL COAST'S DOWN 250%
THE SOUTH COAST OF DOWNTON 90%
NORTH COAST YOU DONT MORE THAN
90%.
WE HAVE A VERY VERY FEW FISH
MOTHER HANGING ON TRYING TO KEEP
IT GOING [inaudible]
WITHOUT.
THIS LAST EL NINO WE HAD REALLY --
FLORIDA'S.
I'VE BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS AND I'VE BEEN
THROUGH A FEW EL NINO'S BUT
WE'VE NEVER HAD ONE THAT IMPACT
IS THE WAY THIS ONE DID.
AND THEY WERE REELING FROM IT --
WE'RE LOSING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
THE PROCESSORS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING HE CAN TO HANG ON
WE'RE LOSING MARKET SHARE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE THINGS ARE
BEING -- A
WORLD IN THEIR FLOODING OUR
MARKETS WITH OUR PART OF A STATE
OF THE COUNTRY --
CHINS AND SO WHEN WE DO RECOUP
WHICH WE WILL I I TRULY BELIEVE
WE WILL.
IN THE FISHERY CONTACT BACK
WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT OUR WAY
BACK INTO THE MARKET.
SO THAT BEING SAID --
I DO THANK YOU GUYS FOR TRYING
TO GET THIS DISASTER.
RELIEF BECAUSE WE DO NEED WE DO
NEED IT AND I LIKE --
TO SAY ONE OTHER THING THAT
HAPPENED DURING THE CELL NINO.
THAT -- HAS
BEEN REALLY DEVASTATING AND NOW
IT'S WORKING ITS WAY DOWN TO
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
THE PURPLE URCHIN INVASION.
THAT HAPPENED WITH THIS WHEN WE
GOT THIS WARM WATER IT KILLED
THE PRIMARY --
PREDATOR FOR THE PURPLE URGES
WHICH WAS ACE ON STAR.
AND THEY HAVEN'T RECOVERED AT
ALL I MEAN I'M BURSTING OF VERY
FEW OF THEM BUT THEY'RE NOT
RECOVERING SO THE PROPELLER GINS
WHEN THEY HAVE THEIR BABIES ARE
BEING.
THERE NOT BEING ENOUGH.
WELL --
TAKING CARE OF I DON'T KNOW HOW
ELSE TO SAY IT --
SO WE'RE WE'RE WORKING WE AS A
FISH WE ARE WORKING ON WAYS TO
TRY -- TO A
RATTY KILO MORE PRODUCT FOURS.
BUT THAT'S YOU KNOW AN APPEAL
ROAD WERE REALLY TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THAT SO.
I MEAN JUST WALKING THROUGH HIS.
LOOK WE WE HEAR FROM FOLKS ARE
OUT THERE ALL THE TIME --
JUST YOU KNOW WITH THE KELP BEDS
GOT NOW GONE OFF I'LL I'LL TALK
ABOUT THE NORTH COAST IN GIGLI
AROUND.
DATABASE IN ALLAH THROUGH FOUR
BRAG INTEREST EXPLOSION OF
PROPORTION.
IS THERE EVEN A MARKET --
FOR PROPORTION I JUST I THEY'RE
IN YEAH IN THE PAST WE HAVE HAD
A MARKET FOR IT AND THERE IS A
THERE IS A MARKET FOR ANY KIND
OF PURCHASE --
THE PURPLE URCHIN ARE KIND OF A
THE SPECIES.
HAS BEEN TRADITIONALLY NOT BEEN
MUCH OF A MARKET PAROLE.
URCHIN --
WORKING ON WAYS TO TO DO THAT
NOW A MY SONS ARE ALL INVOLVED
IN THAT IN THERE.
WORKING HARD AT IT --
TO GIVE GIVE THIS EXAM SO WHAT
WHAT IT WHAT WOULD THAT
POTENTIALLY LOOK LIKE WELL.
WHAT WE'RE KIND OF LEANING
TOWARDS AS WERE READY CREATING
THESE ARE TUNES PICKING UP THE
LARGER ONES IN TRYING TO FEED
THEM?
AND SEE IF WE CAN BRING THEM
INTO A MARKET VALUE.
AND THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT HAVE GOT SOME REALLY
GOOD IDEAS BUT THEY ALL NEED TO
BE TESTED WITH US YOU KNOW WE WE
HAVE TO SET UP FACILITIES.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER THING I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO ASK YOU GUYS FOR
IF WE DO GET THESE THINGS UP AND
RUNNING.
IS WE'RE GONNA NEED HELP GETTING
PERMITTED.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE WITH
THEIR PART IN FISHING GAME OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND WITH YOU
GUYS.
AND SO AS WE WORK INTO THIS WE
WILL NEED HELP.
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO THIS
THE SCREENING BECAUSE IN TO READ
WRITE.
BOMB YEAH COUSIN.
THERE THERE I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE SEEN THE TWO DIFFERENCE
HERE THE SPECIES OF THE PURPOSE
OF SMALLER TO MAJORITY LINES ON
IT.
ARE USUALLY IN THE SHOWER WATERS
THE REDS ARE IN SHALLOW AND DEEP
BOTH AND THEY GOT ALONG RESPONDS
IN THEIR BIGGER --
JIM THEY'RE MORE REMARKABLE
VALUE TO SO.
IN AT MY LAST QUESTION I MEAN
PLAY TWENTY QUESTIONS WITH YOU.
THE BIGGEST HAVE YOU SEEN SIZE
OF WHAT YOU WOULD TYPICALLY
HARVESTS AS A RED.
I KNOW THEY DON'T GROW THAT BACK
THERE --
THREE INCHES OR THE LARGEST ONE
GENE OF MARBLE COMES ABOUT --
ONE AND THREE QUARTERS TO TWO
INCHES WERE THEY'LL START
BECOMING A MARKETABLE THNG BUT
LIKE THE PROBLEM IS. 99% OF THEM
ARE JUST LITTLE TEENY TEENY
THINGS AND THEY'RE NOT GROWING
YES YOU'RE JUST TOO MANY OF THEM.
KELP IS STARTING TO COME BACK.
BUT WHEN IT DOES THERE IS JUST
ATTACKED BY ALL THESE LITTLE
BITTY PURPLE SO THEY HAVE MOTHER
FOOD.
AND SO THEY'RE EATING IT BEFORE
REALLY GETS A CHANCE TO TAKE OFF.
AND WHAT WE ARE SEEING SOME KELP
COMING BACK WHICH IS REALLY A
LOT OF HOPE FOR US.
BUT IT'S STILL.
A BIG PROBLEM ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TROUBLE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE.
THANK YOU FOR THE REST AREA
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
IF YOU ALL DON'T MIND TALK TO US
ABOUT MARKET --
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING OUT THERE --
WITH.
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'VE HAD IN THE NEWS RIGHT WITH
TOMORROW CASTED WOULD HAVE YEAH.
WOULD YOU HEARING ABOUT MARKET
ON AQUACULTURE [inaudible]
ANY CHALLENGES [inaudible]
MR.
WE'LL SHOW FISHER ARE THE MARKET
IS STRONG DEMAND IS STRONG --
IN FACT NONE OF US CAN CAN MEET
THE DEMAND OF THE MARKET WELL
I'M CURRENTLY [inaudible]
THE THE OCEAN HAS BEEN KIND TO
US TO KEEP UP.
BUT THAT'S WHY YOU SEE SO MUCH
INTEREST IN IN INCREASING
PRODUCTION.
YEAH.
WELL BUT THE MARKET'S GOOD.
IT'S GREAT. FOR US.
IN THE IN THE TERRESTRIAL
FINFISH PRODUCTION.
MUCH OF IT TO THAT WHICH HAS AGO
FOR STOCKING OF RECREATIONAL
LAKES AND STREAMS --
GOES FOR LIVE MARKETS --
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ENJOY --
THE FRESHEST FISH AVAILBLE
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT.
WHERE LIFE ISSUES OF THE PREMIUM?
AND SO THEY'RE STILL GREAT
DEMAND. FOR THE EVERYTHING THAT
IS PRODUCED BY AQUACULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S FORTUNATE.
HISTORY.
IS IT ANY CLOSING COMMENTS FROM
OUR PANEL.
PLEASE NOW IF I MAY IS THANK YOU
CENTER WHO ARE AT THE THE
LEADERSHIP YOU SHOWN.
IN.
CLEARING A PATH FOR FISHERMEN
THEIR REPRESENTATIVE.
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE THE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACHES TO
MANAGEMENT THAT WE HAVE SEVEN
STEP COMMITTEE DONE INSTRUMENT
CRAP TASK FORCE THE THE GEAR IN
TIME A WORKING GROUP.
ALL OF THESE SHARE ONE COMMON
THREAD WHICH IS THAT FISHERMEN
ARE PART.
OF DETERMINING SOLUTIONS AND WE
WE CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH
BECAUSE WE CAN'T DO THIS WITHOUT
THOSE KINDS OF OPPORTUNITIES SO
WILL WILL BE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU TO STRENGTHEN.
WE AUTHORIZE WHEN APPROPRIATE --
AND THESE ORGANIZATIONS TO REACH
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF POWER --
WE'VE ALREADY SEE WE'VE WE'VE
SEEN THAT WE HAVE A A RECEPTIVE
AND THOUGHTFUL AUDIENCE AND AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IN HIS
ADMINISTRATION ADMINISTRATION --
AND HIS APPOINTEES --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE NOT GETTING
GOOD WORKS NO I THINK HE'S
EMOTIONAL AND AN ANALYSIS OF
CRAB OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE.
TO WHATEVER THAT IS GONNA BE IT
WHENEVER THE RIGHT TIME IS
WORKING TO CONVENE A MEETING I
DEBATED TALK ABOUT NEXT STEPS AS
WE HEAD INTO THE SEASON SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH PLEASE SIR MISTER
CHAIR I I I THINK NO SET.
WADE WILL CREATE A MORE
ELOQUENTLY THAN I COULD OF BUT I
SHARES FEELINGS NOT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. EIGHT TWENTY IS A ALSO
THANK YOU --
TO AND DEALING WITH A LOT OF
FIRES AND JUST VERY VERY
GRATEFUL ACTIVISTS WAS SO IT'S A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH HIM ALONG
WITH VICE CHAIR.
WHO'S JUST BEEN SUCH A CHAMPION
AS WELL AND SO HAPPY TO BE
PARTNER WITH YOU AGAIN SIR AND
TO ALL OF YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR WORK AND WE'RE REALLY
HAPPY HERE.-ON ANY MISTER BRIAN WANNA FOLLOW
PATEA IS WELL TALK MORE ABOUT
PROPORTION SO --
YOU'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM US
HERE NEXT WEEK SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK MISTER.
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
PLAYS GERMAN HERE WE GO.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TOWARDS OUR
FINAL PANEL OF THE DAY AND WE'RE
SO HAPPY THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE
BEEN HANGING WITH US.
DURING HIS FORTY SIXTH ANNUAL
ZEKE GRADER FISHERIES FORM.
WE'RE GOING TO BE WELCOMING EVER
SHOW FISHER.
HE'S WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
TEAM OF THE JUDGES CRAP TASK
FORCE HE'S GOING TO PROVIDE AND
UPDATE THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
CRAB TASK FORCE.
AND WHAT THE HECK THEY'RE GONNA
BE UP TO HERE IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO DARREN IS HERE HE'S
THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
VISOR COMEDIAN SALMON AND
STEELHEAD TROUT.
HE'S GONNA BE UPDATING THE
COMMITTEE ON THE ACTIVITIES OF
THE COMMITTEE.
I AS WELL AS THE GRAND
LEGISLATION.
IN HE'S GOING TO BRIEF THE
COMEDIAN TO CRITICAL PROGRAMS IN
NEED OF MORE SUSTAINABLE FUNDING.
AND THEN WERE GRATEFUL THAT
LEASES HERE LIZ WHITE MEAN SHE'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE OCEAN
SIGN STRESSED.
BUT SHE'S NEW AND WE'RE EXCITED
TO BE WORKING WITH HER SO HOT
DANG WATCH OUT.
DONE AND SHE'S GONNA BE
PRESENTING --
ON THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN ANNUAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE --
AND SHE'S GOING TO BE SHARING
THEIR UPDATED STRATEGIC VISION
AND SOME OF THOSE HIGHLIGHTS AS
WELL.
DELAYS IN GERMAN --
WITHOUT FURTHER DO THAT SHIRT
OVER TO OUR PANEL WE'RE GONNA
START WITH HER SHALL THEY WERE
GONNA TURN OF A DARING RAN
TURNOVER LACE.
SHELL THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND
WELCOME YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES OF
YOU WHEN IT PROMPTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND GOOD
AFTERNOON --
AND YES THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
US TO PROVIDE THIS ANNUAL UPDATE
ON BEHALF OF THE TASK FORCE --
THE TASK FORCE LAST NIGHT JUNE
FIFTH AND SIX OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHERE THEY APPROVE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
POST RAFT LOST FISHING GEAR
RECOVERY PROGRAMS TITLE FOURTEEN
REGULATIONS. FOR AT THE MOUTH
FULL EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH NINE AND
THIRTEEN TEN AND THEY PROVIDED
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSED.
SERVICE GEAR SET UP REGULATIONS
TO THE DEPARTMENT ON THE TWENTY
SECOND.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TRI STATE
DUNGENESS CRAB COMMITTEE MEETING.
THEIR SUBCOMMITTEE THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE MET IN AUGUST AND
DISCUSSED OTHER --
PRIORITY TOPIC THAT THE TASK
FORCE'S INTERESTED IN DISCUSSING.
X. ESPECIALLY THOSE RELATED TO
GEAR SERVICING REQUIREMENT.
AND DIE IN OCTOBER MY SELF AND
MY COLLEAGUE KELLY FACE THE
FACILITATION TEAM ADMINISTRATIVE
TEAM AND YES --
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE.
HIDE THE PLEASURE AND PRIVILEGE
OF VISITING PORTS BETWEEN
ADELINE CRESCENT CITY TO TALK TO
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN AND WHOEVER
WOULD WANNA SIT DOWN AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
AND WE LEARNED ABOUT INTEREST
SPECIFIC TO THE TENSIONS CRAB
INDUSTRY SHARED UPDATES ON THE
TASK FORCE AND PRIORITY ISSUES
INCLUDING WHALEN TELEMANN'S AND
DEMOC ACID.
AS YOU KNOW SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TEN REQUIRES AN UPDATE TO MAKE
ABOUT THE TASK FORCE BASED ON
SOME TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE OF
THAT URGENCY BILL LAST YEAR THE
TASK FORCE OR SEES ME THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL BEGAN THE
PROCESS OF TASK FORCE ELECTIONS.
WHICH HAD NOT BEEN CONDUCTED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE SO WE'RE
VERY EXCITED TO HAVE SOME NEW
ELECTIONS.
AND SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TEN
REQUIRE FASHION SO THE ELECTIONS
THE AUCTIONS MATERIALS WENT OUT.
YESTERDAY OR THE DAY BEFORE SO
FOLKS SHOULD START GETTING
MAILED BY FRIDAY WITH THE
ELECTIONS MATERIALS ALL.
DENTURES CRAB COMMERCIAL PRINT.
COMMERCIAL DENCH'S CRAB PERMIT
HOLDERS.
AND ON THE ELECTIONS THIS YEAR
WILL BE HELD IN THE PORT
COMPLEXES A CRESCENT CITY
TRINIDAD FORT BRAGG.
SAN FRANCISCO AND THE PORT SOUTH
OF HALF MOON BAY AND NEXT YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY BE ELECTIONS WILL
BE FOR THE NON RESIDENT PERMIT
HOLDERS YOUR RICA.
BODEGA AND HAPPEN BAY.
AND ON TOP OF THE LECTURE INS
CURRENTLY AS AS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY THE
DEPARTMENT --
PC ARE WORKING THROUGH STATE
BUDGETING AND CONTRACTING
PROCESS IS TO SECURE SUPPORT FOR
TASK FORCE ADMINISTRATION
FACILITATION BEYOND APRIL FIRST
WHICH IS WHEN STRATEGIC EARTH
CONTRACT --
COMES TO AN END.
THROUGH SB THIRTEEN TEN FUNDS
FROM THE DENTURES CRAB ACCOUNT
WILL BE USED TO SUPPORT THE TASK
FORCE AS THEY ARE AVAILABLE.
AND THE INTENTION IS TO CONFIRM
TASK FORCE ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORT IN A TIMELY MANNER SO
THE TASK FORCE CAN RECONVENE AS
SOON AS THE ELECTIONS ARE
COMPLETED.
THE MEMBERS OF THE TASK FORCE
FISHERMEN AND OTHERS CONTINUE TO
IDENTIFY PRIORITY TOPICS FOR THE
TASK FORCE TO ADDRESS THIS
UPCOMING YEAR AND BEYOND SHORT
AND LONG TERM.
AND INCLUDES TOPICS RELATED TO
REDUCING THE RISK OF WOMEN
TANGLE MEANT IN THE DENTURES
CRAB INDUSTRY THE EFFORTS OF THE
DENTURES CRAWFISH AND YOU'RE
WORKING GROUP WE TRY TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S A LOT OF OVERLAP
THERE IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
I DEMO CASTED INVESTIGATION
ORDERS AND SEASON OPENERS.
ETCETERA AND SO THESE TOPICS ARE
BEING TRACKED BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE TEAM AND BY THE
AGENCIES FOR CONSIDERATION AND
DISCUSSION FOR FUTURE DENTURES
CONTEST FOURTH MEETING AGENDAS.
THE TASK FORCE IS GRATEFUL TO
SENATOR REQUIRE AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE TASK FORCE ESPECIALLY
THROUGH SB THIRTEEN TEN AND
THIRTEEN OH NINE IN THE TASK
FORCE ALSO THANK THE DEPARTMENT --
PC FOR THE FISCAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF THE TASK FORCE ME
ADMINISTRATIVE TEAM I JUST LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS.
AND WE ALSO HAVE THE AUDIENCE
AND I THINK.
HE'S STILL HERE IF WE HAVE
QUESTIONS RELATED TO TALK.
MISS FISHER THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND THROUGH THE YEAR THAT THE
GLUE THAT MAKES IT ALL WORK SO
AND KEEP IT MOVING FORWARD SO
VERY VERY GRATEFUL.
FOR ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS WERE
HAPPY THAT YOU'RE HERE THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
IS NOW ART PLEASURE TO BE TURNED
OVER TO MR MARROU HE'S THE CAT
CHAIR OF THE COMPANY BUYS RE
I'VE COMEDIAN SALMON STEELHEAD
TROUT.
WELCOME THANK YOU IT WAS GREAT
TO SEE LAST NIGHT MY GOODNESS IN
SOME GOOD GRAB I GOTTA TELL YA
THAT WAS GREAT --
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES WE'LL GIVE
YOU A ONE MINUTE PROMPT OKAY
WELL THANK YOU CENTER REQUIRE
AND MEMBER STONE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY TOM THINKS
INVITING ME --
BEFORE I GET MY PREPARED NOTES I
JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
EFFORT LAST YEAR TO CREATE THE
GREAT RED WOULD TRAIL IN THE EEL
RIVER THIS IS A TREMENDOUS THING
YOU KNOW THAT MY WORK IN THE
REVERSE FOCUSED ON BRING BACK
SEVEN IS STILL HAD BUT THAT
TRAVELED VIA AN INCREDIBLE --
VALUABLE RESOURCE IN THAT
WATERSHED FOR MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS HE JUST --
THERE'S ABOUT SIXTY MILLION THAT
WHICH IS FUNDED LAST THURSDAY
VERY SEGMENTS IT'S GONNA ONE
THOUGH YEAH I KNOCK ON WOOD.
IT'S GONNA BE A GREAT PARTY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
RCA SEES BEEN VERY BUSY THIS
YEAR WE HAD --
THREE MEETING QUARTERLY MEETINGS
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE HAD OUR
FIRST MEETING IN TWENTY NINETEEN
YESTERDAY HERE IN SACRAMENTO --
AMONG THE MANY AGENDA TOPICS WE
HAD -- WE
FOCUSED ON STREAMLINING OF
REGULATORY PERMITS TO HELP
ENABLE BETTER AND MORE EFFECTIVE
SALMON RECOVERY --
WE'VE FOCUSED ON THE CALIFORNIA
BAR MIDDLE FLOWS FRAMEWORK UNDER
DEVELOPMENT BY THE STATE WATER
BOARD AND YOU SEE SCIENTISTS.
AND YESTERDAY THE MENTION WE HAD
A MEETING ON CENTRALLY
HATCHERIES THAT WAS VERY ROBUST
AND WELL ATTENDED BY --
MANY FISHERMEN AND OTHER AGENCY
REPRESENTATIVES --
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR APPOINTING
FOR MEMBERS TO OUR PEER REVIEW
COMMITTEE AS WELL --
TO THOSE WERE NEW MEMBERS TO
WERE --
REAPPOINTED IN ADDITION TO THOSE
APPOINTMENTS WE ALSO --
SELECTED A NEW PAIR C. CHAIR
MISTER --
MATT CLIFFORD FROM TRY TO
LIMITED AND LAST YEAR WE ALSO
WROTE A CHARTER. TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO REDEFINE THE GOING
FORWARD IN OUR OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE OF THE FISHERY
RESTORATION GRANT PROGRAM SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THAT -- WE
WERE GOING TO SPEAK ABOUT --
OUR SUPPORT FOR LEGISLATION
YESTERDAY BUT WE HAD TO TO
ROBUST MEETING THAT WE DIDN'T
GET TO IT SO I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE CONSENSUS FROM THE CDC ON
BILLS THAT WE SUPPORTS ALL I'LL
GET BACK TO YOU ON THOSE THINGS.
I DID WANT TO MENTION HOWEVER SP
NINETEEN WOULD HAVE THE W. ARE
IN THE WATER BOARD DEVELOPED THE
PLANTED A PLACE STREAMFLOW
GAUGES.
THROUGHOUT THE WATERSHEDS AND
THE NORTH COAST AND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND THIS WOULD HELP
CLOSE THE GAP ON CALIFORNIA'S
WATER SUPPLY SIDE I THINK THIS
IS SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO
SUPPORT.
BUT AGAIN I'LL GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT IT'S A TREMENDOUS.
MISLI IMPORTANT THING TO BE ABLE
TO MONITOR STREAM FLOWS
ESPECIALLY WITH THE DEMANDS FOR
WATER -- I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO REPORT THAT IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN HE WE HAD A
VERY PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE WITH A
GROUP OF RESTORATION SCIENTISTS.
AND MEMBERS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE GRANT PROGRAM
STAFF -- OUR
GOAL IS TO BRING FORTH
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
RESTORATION COMMUNITY TO THE
GRANT PROGRAM STAFF ON WAYS TO
IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROGRAMS.
WE CAME FOR THE SET OF EIGHTEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
DELIVERED AT THE END OF THE YEAR
TO DOCTOR BONHAM.
AND THEY WERE VERY WELL RECEIVED
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THE STAFF
NOW IS WORKING TOWARD
FORMULATING STRATEGIES FOR
ADOPTING MANY IF NOT ALL OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS --
THERE WAS ONE UNRESOLVED
RECOMMENDATION WHICH WAS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO UTILIZE FEDERAL
ACCOUNTING RULES.
AN INDIRECT COST RECOVERY RATES --
THESE ARE KANIKA AGREEMENTS SO
THAT OUR RESTORATION
PRACTITIONERS CAN BE REIMBURSED
FOR FOR THEIR INDIRECT COSTS
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
SMALLER ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT CONDUCT SOME OF
THE RESTORATION PROJECTS --
WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND BETTER WHY THE
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY IS
EXPRESSING THEIR INABILITY --
TO SUPPORT THE USE OF THOSE --
INDIRECT RATES IN THE IN THE
GRANT PROGRAMS.
I THINK THEY'RE WORKING ON IT
BUT WE JUST WANT SOME SOME
ASSISTANCE ON UNDERSTANDING OF
THINGS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT TO
FUNDING RELATED PROBLEMS THAT
ARE SALMON IS STILL A RECOVERY
EFFORTS KIND OF REFERRING TO
WHAT DOCTOR BONHAM REFERRED TO
AS SUSTAINABLE FUNDING THAT ARE
NEEDED --
FIRST AS YOU ARE AWARE OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
AND STATE TAX MONIES ARE SPENT
ANNUALLY. FOR HABITAT
RESTORATION TO BRING BACK NATIVE
SALMON AND STEEL HEAD.
HOWEVER THESE PROGRAMS LACK A
STABLE LONG TERM SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO MONITOR ADULT AND
JUVENILE FISH POPULATIONS. TO
DETERMINE IF OUR ACTIONS ARE
BEING EFFECTIVE.
CITY OF W. AND THE NATIONAL MEAN
FISHERY SERVICE HAVE A COASTAL
MONITORING PROGRAM THE CMP.
THIS IS A STATE WIDE PROGRAM AND
IT NEEDS FUNDING IT NEEDS AT
LEAST FIFTEEN TO TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
THE MONITOR TEN ESA FEDERAL YES
A LISTED SPECIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE --
THESE FUNDS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
VALIDATE WHETHER OR NOT OUR
CONSIDERABLE INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC FUNDS ARE BEING
SUCCESSFUL AND EFFECTIVE IN
REBUILDING THESE POPULATIONS --
OUR COMMITTEE THE CC IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO THIS BASIC PROBLEM
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
TRYING TO IDENTIFY SUITABLE
FUNDING SOURCES THAT'LL BE
SUSTAINABLE FOR THE LONG TERM.
AND THE SECOND ITEM I LIKE TO
BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION IS --
THE RECENT PLIGHT OF
CALIFORNIA'S COAST SALMON.
COLD WAR ON STATE AND FEDERALLY
LISTEDAS ENDANGERED AND THESE
POPULATIONS ESPECIALLY SOUTH OF
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE.
ARE CURRENTLY AT HIGH RISK OF
EXTINCTION.
I'VE HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS WITH
THE NATIONAL MARINE FISHERIES
SERVICE.
ALONG WITH STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL I STAFF ABOUT THE
CURRENT PLIGHT --
AND THE SCIENTISTS BELIEVE THE
COAST SOUTH OF THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE ARE BEING SUSTAINED
PRIMARILY BY THE KING FISHER
FLAT.
BROODSTOCK PROGRAM --
WHICH IS A JOINT FACILITY
OPERATED BY THE MONTEREY BAY
SALMON AND TROUT PROJECT
NURTURING FISHERY SERVICE.
AND SEE IF W. SO MEMBERS STONE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S IN YOUR
REGION AS WELL AND VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE FOLKS DOWN
THERE --
THIS FACILITY THIS KING FISHER
FLAT FACILITY CURRENTLY LACKS
DEDICATED FUNDING IN NEEDS ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR TO SUSTAIN THEIR OPERATIONS --
THE EXISTING FUNNIES FINDING IT
IS SET TO EXPIRE IN MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY IN ADDITION THE
MONITORING PROGRAM IT'S FOCUSED
ON SCOTT CREEK THAT KIND OF
MONITORS THE SUCCESS OF THE THE
BRIDGE DOT PROGRAM IS ALSO IN
DANGER OF LOSING ITS FUNDING
IT'LL EXPIRE AT THE END OF THIS.
YEAR -- SORT
WERE AT HIGH RISK OF LOSING
THESE FISH.
AND THE PROGRAMS DEDICATED TO
THEIR PREFERRED TO PREVENTING
THEIR EXTINCTION ARE SET TO
EXPIRE IN THE NEXT YEAR.
SO WE NEED TO ESTABLISH THIS
BROODSTOCK PROGRAM IS A PRIORITY
AND IT'S ESSENTIAL TO SAVE THE
COLE ALONG THE CALIFORNIA COAST
SO THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE.
BROUGHT ALONG SOME --
INFORMATION FROM OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS THAT CAN LEAD TO GIVE
YOU MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
WE CREATE LIKE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WHAT THE
SURGEON YOUR MIND IS PASSING OUT
THE INFORMATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WITHOUT A CLOSE AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE AND I SHOP SIR I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS HOUSEHOLD TO
WE'RE DONE HERE THAT WORKS OKAY.
WITH YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH GREAT
JOB WERE GRATEFUL THAT LIZ IS
HERE SHE'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
HE OCEAN SCIENCE TRUST YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES WE WALK ME TO
COMMITTEE IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU ONE MINUTE
PROMPTED YOU SO MUCH FOR
ATTENDING. THIRTY MCGUIRE CHAIR
AND SET THEM.
AND THE MEMBER STERN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS LIZ WHITE MEN I AM
PRIVILEGED TO SERVE AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA OCEAN SIGN STRESSED.
A UNIQUE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
BUT ESTABLISHED BY CALIFORNIA
STATUTES AND WHICH ALSO SERVES
AS SCIENCE ADVISER TO THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL.
I'M WE ARE A TEAM OF TEN A SMALL
POWERFUL TEAM OF TEN SCIENCE TO
POLICY EXPERTS BASED JOINTLY IN
SACRAMENTO IN OAKLAND.
THAT BELIEVES THAT SCIENCE CAN
ACCELERATE PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
STATE'S GOALS OF A HEALTHY AND
PRODUCTIVE OCEAN COAST.
WE'RE REQUIRED BY OUR FOUNDING
LEDGES THE FORMULATION RESOURCES
TO CHIP ACT TO REPORT ANNUALLY
ON OUR ACTIVITIES TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO TODAY I AM MY PURPOSE HERE IS
TO PRESENT TO YOU THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ANNUAL
REPORTS IN PARTIAL FULFILLMENT
OF THAT REQUIREMENT.
AND WITH FORMAL --
TRANSMISSION TO TO FOLLOW TODAY
ALTHOUGH I BELIEVE YOU SHOULD
HAVE IT IN THE BACKGROUND
RESOURCES --
I'D LIKE TO JUST VERY BRIEFLY
HIGHLIGHT TWO AREAS OF WORK FROM
THAT --
SHARING WITH YOU HOW WORK THAT
WAS LAUNCHED DURING THAT TIME
PERIOD HAS HAD SUBSEQUENT IMPACT
AND HOW WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS.
THE FIRST IS THAT A BIG SORT OF
HIGH LEVEL GENERAL --
LAST YEAR WOKING WITH THE
EXPERT PANEL FROM THIS OPEN
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL SCIENCE
ADVISORY TEAM WE PRODUCED THE
FIRST EVER COAST IN OCEAN
SYNTHESIS --
AS PART OF CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT.
THIS REPORT REPRESENTS A SHIFT
FROM.
I WOULD SAY MERELY BUT IT IT --
COMMENCE --
PROJECTING CHANGE AND IMPACTS TO
ALSO BEGINNING THAT DIALOGUE ON
SOLUTIONS AND ADAPTATION OPTIONS.
SO AS A SCIENCE ADVISORY TEAM WE
CAN NOW LOOK TO FIND WAYS TO
LIFT AND LEVERAGE AND ENGAGE
MORE BROADLY TO DIVE DEEPER INTO
THOSE ADAPTATION AND MITIGATION
SOLUTIONS AND AND
RECOMMENDATIONS.
INCLUDING ADDRESSING QUESTIONS
LIKE WHAT ROLE DOES ON NETWORK
OF MARINE PROTECTED AREAS PLAY
HOW DO WE YOU SEE CROSSES AND
HELP FORESTS.
HOW DO WE STRENGTHEN THE
OBSERVATION OF THE STATE AND THE
WEALTH OF SCIENTIFIC KNOWLEDGE
THAT IS HOUSE NOT JUST IN
ACADEMIA BUT ALSO IN IN FISHING
AND FRONT LINE COMMUNITIES?
THE DRILLING DOWN THAN THE
SECOND PROJECT THAT I JUST
QUICKLY WANTED TO TO HIGHLIGHTS.
IS M. REFERENCED WITHIN THAT
BROAD SYNTHESIS BUT IS LOOKING A
LITTLE BIT MORE AT ADAPTING TO
CLIMATE CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA'S
FISHERIES AND FISHING
COMMUNITIES.
THIS WORK WAS LAUNCHED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AGAIN WITH
AN EXPERT PANEL FROM THE SCIENCE
ADVISORY TEAM.
WHO DISTILLED WHAT YOU WHAT YOU
ALL KNOW IS JUST AN AMAZING
COMPLEXITY OF SCIENTIFIC?
RESEARCH AND DATA INTO FOR
POTENTIAL FUTURE SCENARIOS --
FOR CALIFORNIA'S OCEAN
ENVIRONMENT AND USE THAT AS A
WAY TO LAUNCH A CONVERSATION
ABOUT SEX OF PRAGMATIC
MANAGEMENT OPTIONS AND CHANGES
THAT COULD SUPPORT.
ADAPTING FISHERIES IN FISHING
COMMUNITIES TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
TODAY BUILDING ON THAT
FOUNDATIONAL WORK AND WITH
ADDITIONAL PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT.
WE'RE ABLE TO CONVENE A A BROAD
ARRAY OF STAKEHOLDERS MANAGES --
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO EXPLORE
WHAT THE SPECIFIC TOOLS THE
LEAVE AS THE MANAGEMENT LEAVE US
AN OPTIONS ARE.
THEY CAN HELP --
TO SORT OF BUFFET BUILDERS THIS
GAIL AND HOW THOSE MIGHT LOOK
MEANT AND TWEAK AND MODIFIED THE
THE BROADER FISHERY MANAGEMENT
STRUCTURE THAT EXISTS THAT A
STATE WIDE SCALE.
AND SO BECAUSE I'M LOST I'M
GONNA MAKE THIS VERY BRIEF --
TURNING THEN --
TO OUR OCEAN SCIENCE TRYST --
STRATEGIC VISION RECENTLY
UPDATED --
WITHOUT BOARD OF TRUSTEES THEM
AND SUPPORT FROM UP HOTNESS.
I WANTED TO JUST EXPRESS TO YOU
THAT -- WE
TAKE PRIDE IN AS A NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION NIMBLE RESPONSE TO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SCIENCE TO
HAVE A MEANINGFUL IMPACT ON
POLICY.
OUR UPDATED STRATEGIC VISION IS
ORIENTED TO THE TWENTY YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF OUR FOUNDING
LEGISLATION --
WHICH CORSO WAS PASSED IN IN THE
YEAR -- TWO
THOUSAND AND HI HUMBLY BELIEVE
AND I SHOULD CLARIFY THAT WHILE
I'M NEW TO THIS ROLE I HAVE BEEN
WITH THE ORGANIZATION FOR TEN
YEARS -- AND
I FEEL VERY PRIVILEGED TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THROUGH
TO THE THE TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE OCEAN SCIENCE STRESSED.
THAT TO AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
BOLD EXPERIMENT LAID OUT IN THAT
LEGISLATION OFTEN NONPROFIT
PARTNER TO THE STATE IS WORKING
AS A MODEL FOR EFFECTIVE SCIENCE
INFORMED POLICY.
WHAT I WOULD LOVE?
TO DEEPEN AND STRENGTHEN INTO
THE FUTURE THAT WE DO.
AND THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE STATE AGENCIES IS ALSO
MORE DIRECTLY IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
PRIORITIES AND AND INTERESTS AND
I WOULD WELCOME A VENUE FOR THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND SO WITH THAT I WOULD JUST
CLOSE IN SAYING NO WE BELIEVE IN
PUTTING SCIENCE TO WORK --
TO CREATE SOLUTIONS TO
CHALLENGING PROBLEMS.
WE HAVE IN FOR YOU IN FRONT OF
US AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND LOVE THAT
YOU WERE STANDIN BY DATA IN
SCIENCE AND WISH EVERYONE.
AT EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
WHAT SO BUT WE WILL GET INTO
THAT TODAY SO I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH IN NICE JOB.
I WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER WITH
DARREN FOR SO DEAR AND TALK WITH
US ABOUT YOU KNOW WE WE HEARD.%
EARLIER --
FROM THOSE WHO ARE WITHIN THE
SAME INDUSTRY AND ARE THERE A
FISHERMAN.
BUT COLD WATER --
AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS AND THIS
IS GOING TO BE A GOOD YEAR CAN
YOU GIVE US OUT WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING ON THE GROUND AS WELL.
WELL THE FISHING'S BEEN TERRIBLE
WHICH IS A GOOD THING FOR THE
FISH.
THE RIVERS HAVE BEEN SO HIGH --
THE WORK WE'RE HAVING REALLY
GOOD WINTER FLOWS --
I THINK PERSONALLY THAT THE MOST
CRITICAL PERIOD OF THE YEAR IS
THE SPRING TIME WHEN THE SMELTER
HEADING OUT TO SEA.
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
COLD WEATHER PATTERNS THE
RAINFALL THAT WE'RE HAVING --
IT OUGHT TO BEAR A GOOD.
YOU KNOW THREE YEARS FROM NOW
RETURN. TO THE RIVERS --
YEAH [inaudible]
THAT'S GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHOW.
GIVE US A MINUTE DOES BUT WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING --
FROM FISHERMEN --
IN CHALLENGES --
THAT Y'ALL COME THROUGH SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHAT DO YOU
HEAR.
THIS YEAR OR IS COMMITTED NOW
RIGHT THANK WE WE'VE HEARD --
THAT IT STARTS TO ADD UP AND ON
TOP OF IT WERE NOT SEEN IT IS
BEEN A SLOW MOVING TRAIN.
BE ABLE TO SEE THAT THE DISASTER
RELIEF COMING IN.
ARE.
ARE YOU SEEN FOLKS ARE COMING
BACK --
WHAT'S YOUR OUTLOOK AND WOULD
YOU HEARING FROM THOSE WHO
YOU'RE WORKING WITH.
I THE TASK FORCE IS MAINLY
CONCERNED WITH MAKING SURE THAT
THE FISHERY OPERATES IN A
FASHION THAT EVERYBODY SEEMS
REALLY AND SO.
I THINK THE TASK FORCE WAS
ESTABLISHED I MEAN WHEN IT WAS
ESTABLISHED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE WE DON'T HAVE TO MOW GAS
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE WAYLAND
TANGLE MINUTES.
SO THESE ISSUES ARE VERY NEW TO
THE A LOT OF ENERGY FOR THEM TO
DISCUSS THEY ARE DISCUSSING IN
THE SERRATION ORDERS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
AND YEAH I THINK THEY'RE THE
TASK FORCE'S MAIN GOAL IS JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE INDUSTRY.
AND SOME OF THAT IS LOOKING AT
THESE BIG ISSUES AND ALSO
LOOKING AT THE EXISTING
REGULATIONS AND MAKING SURE THAT.
THAT DOES WORK FOR THE INDUSTRY.
ONE OF THE ITEMS THAT WE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT AND WHAT WE WERE
ASKING --
STRICTER BOTTOM LINE IS  LACK
OF RESOURCES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SIDE ON THE
TESTING SITE --
IN IN OUR ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
PICK IT QUICKLY I HAD TO BE ABLE
TO ASSIST.
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE TASK
FORCE IS ABSOLUTELY BROUGHT UP
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE FASTER
PROCESSING OF THE SAMPLES FROM
DENMARK ACID AND HAD.
MADE REQUESTS TO THAT EFFECT IS
IT BEN WITH THAT THE LABS OR IS
IT NOT ENOUGH RESOURCES WHAT'S
YOUR BUT I COULDN'T.
I COULDN'T.
IT'S NOT MY PLACE I DON'T WORK
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WE JUST KNOW WHAT THEY'VE
TOLD US THAT.
IT'S THERE'S A LOT OF SAMPLES
COMING IN THIS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS MUCH BIGGER THAN
OREGON AND WASHINGTON SO WE HAVE.
MUCH HIGHER VOLUME OF SAMPLES
COMING INTO THEIR SO.
I IMAGINE IT IS A COMBINATION OF
FACTORS THERE CAUSING A DELAY.
IN AN ITEM THAT SAKE WAS TALKING
ABOUT WHICH WERE VERY GRATEFUL
FORMALLY HEARD IN APRIL OR MAY
IBM TO GET EVERYONE ON THE SAME
PAGE ON THE WEST COAST HOW DO
YOU THINK THAT'S CAN IMPACT THE
FISHERY.
I THINK THAT WILL BE OF A
POSITIVE THERE'S A LOT OF TALK
TALK AND IT DOESN'T JUST STOP AT
THE STATE LINE SO HAVING THAT
THAT TRI STATE DISCUSSION I
THINK IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE ENTIRE FLEET.
THANK YOU WHICH OF PLEASE TURN
YOUR CHAIRMAN AND I DON'T KNOW.
LIZ -- TALK
WITH US ABOUT OCEAN INSTEAD OF
AND WE LOVE THE BEAUTY HERE
ABOUT YOUR CONCERNS GOING
FORWARD --
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS
THAT WERE SEEN NOW IN WHAT YOU
EXPECT HERE --
IN THE COMING YEARS TO COME --
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION SIR THEM IT.
IN CRUDE TERMS THE REDUCING PH
OF OCEAN WATERS BUT THEY
ACTUALLY ISSUES A FORMAL
COMPLICATED THOUGHTS AND REALLY --
INTERTWINED WITH THEM BROUGHT TO
CHANGES IN OCEAN CHEMISTRY AND
OCEAN TEMPERATURE --
I THINK WE ARE --
WE ARE POISED TO BE SORT OF HAVE
FRONT LINE IMPACTS ON THE WEST
COAST AS A RESULT OF THE
PHYSICAL ENVIRONMENT OF THE UP
WELLING OF COLD NUTRIENT RICH
WATERS.
AND IT WAS IN RECOGNITION OF
THAT SO THAT --
I THE STATE I THINK IS ON THE
FRONT LINE OF ACTION TO ADDRESS --
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL WE CONVENED A
SCIENCE PANEL THAT LOOKED AT THE
ISSUE.
AND PROVIDED A SATYR OF
PRAGMATIC POLICY SCIENCE AND
MANAGEMENT OPTIONS FOR THE STATE
TO ADDRESS THIS IS ACTUALLY BEEN.
SUBSEQUENT TO ADAM TO THAT AS
SUCH THE LET THE DEVELOPMENTS --
IN COLLABORATION WITH US AND
MANY OTHERS OF AN OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION ACTION PLAN THAT
REALLY LAYS OUT A ROAD MAP OF
ACTIONS ALONG THE WEST COAST AND
AND FOCUSED ON CALIFORNIA. TO
DEEPEN OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THIS
ISSUE IT IS AN ISSUE OF RAPIDLY
EVOLVING ANTI PAINTING
SCIENTIFIC UNDERSTANDING BUT
ALSO BEGINNING TO PRO ACTIVELY
ACT -- AND
PILOTS NEW APPROACHES THAT LOOK
AT THINGS LIKE SEA GRASSES --
AS M..
AREAS WHERE YOU MIGHT FIND LOCAL
AMELIORATION POTENTIAL --
AND PILOTS AND KNEW IT NEW
PARTNERSHIPS NEW COLLABORATIONS
WITH FISHING COMMUNITIES TO
BEGIN.
TO LOOK AT HOW WE MIGHT SUPPORT
ADAPTATION STEPS INTO THE FUTURE
THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM THAT IS
GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO MANAGE
OUR WAY AFTER THE VISIT IS A
GLOBAL PROBLEM --
SO I THINK FINDING THOSE WAYS
THAT WE CAN --
SO TO MITIGATE IMPACTS --
IT IS IS GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
CANDIDLY HOW FAR BEHIND.
THE EIGHT BALL DO YOU BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA IS AT THIS POINT.
OF BEING ABLE TO REACT TO WHAT
THAT NEW REALITY IS.
I CANDIDLY --
I'VE I FEEL VERY PLEASED TO BE
IN CALIFORNIA --
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE ISSUE WE
ARE ONE OF THE FIRST STATES TO
PRODUCE AN ACTION PLAN AND TO
HAVE PRIORITY TO INVEST IN THAT
ACTION PLAN --
SO I THINK WE ARE POISED TO
TACKLE IT IN THE BEST WAY THAT
WE CAN.
IN DO YOU BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
BE TAKING --
HERE IN CALIFORNIA OR WORKING
WITH HER PEERS --
THROUGHOUT THE WEST COAST WHAT'S
YOUR TAKE ON IT --
PEERS THROUGHOUT THE WEST COAST
AND ALSO INTERNATIONALLY I MEAN
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS IS A GLOBAL
COP AN ISSUE AS WELL --
AND  THINK IT CARS BOTH THE
LOCAL AND INTERNATIONAL DIALOG
EXTRA THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS RESTAURANT.
I GUESS JUST A FEW COMMENTS AND
IF WE START.
BROADLY AS TALKING TO SCIENTISTS
ABOUT THE NORTH EASTERN PACIFIC
OCEAN THE THING I THINK WE HAVE
TO KEEP IN MIND.
THEY TALK ABOUT THAT ESPECIALLY
ONES THAT ARE.
TRACKING RIGHT ORGANISMS.
LARGE SCALE.
PROJECT READ ORGANISMS THERE'S
MORE AS MUCH OR MORE VARIETY AND
AND CAPACITY IS THEY TALK ABOUT
IS THEIR DADDY WE WE THINK WE
HAVE IMAGES OF THE SERENGETI
DESERT AND THAT.
THE NUMBER OF ORGANISMS AND HOW
EXCITING THAT IS WE HAVE THAT
OFF OF OUR SHORES.
AND WE SEE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
AND WE'RE TALKING A LOT ABOUT
THIS.
IN OUR INSHORE WATERS WE TALK
ABOUT THE FISHERY FISHING
INDUSTRY BUT THIS IS WHAT'S WITH
ULTIMATELY AT STAKE.
AND WITH THE OCEAN BEING THE THE
BUFFER FOR A LOT OF THE CHANGES
THAT WE'RE SEEING IN CLIMATE THE
MORE WE KNOW IN THE MORE WE WORK
WITH OUR INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS
AND ESPECIALLY UP AND DOWN.
THE EASTERN PACIFIC OCEAN NORTH
EASTERN PACIFIC OCEAN THAT THE
MORE INROADS I THINK WE CAN MAKE
BUT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE PROTECTING
AND THAT'S WHAT'S WORTH LOOKING
AT KEEPING THAT VIBRANT.
OCEAN ENVIRONMENTS AND THE
FISHERIES INVOLVED IN IT WITH
ALL OF ITS ECONOMIC POTENTIAL
AND AND ALL OF ITS HUMAN
POTENTIAL THAT THAT REPRESENTS.
AND I THINK CALIFORNIA IS.
ALWAYS PRETTY WELL BECAUSE OF
WHAT WILL BE DONE AND WHAT.
THE OCEANSIDE STRESS DOES THAN
WHAT THE THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL IS.
BRINGING REAL SCIENCE INTO THE
CONVERSATION AND I HAVE TO ADMIT
THAT LISTENING TO THE FISHERMEN
TALK HERE AND THIS CONVERSATION
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON SHORE WOULD WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT WILDFIRES
HERE.
IN THE FISHERIES COUNCIL.
AND WHAT HAPPENS N SHORE WITH
WHAT HAPPENS OFF SHORE SOMETHING
THAT IS JUST IN THE EIGHT TO THE
FLEET AND TO THOSE INTERACTIONS.
BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT HOW
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN STRUCTURED.
AGENCY BY AGENCY OR DIFFERENT
GROUPS THEY TEND TO BE FRESH
WATER FOCUSED OR SO.
AND THIS IS THE A VERY
INTERESTING PLACE WHERE THAT ALL
COMES TOGETHER.
BECAUSE IT COMES TOGETHER
NATURALLY HERE FISHERMEN
UNDERSTAND THAT PLEASE.
SO WAS AS WE RAZORS YOU RAISE
THE ISSUE OF TESTING AND THE
FUNDS THAT ARE NECESSARY I ALSO
KNOW THAT.
THAT WITH THE WAY WE'VE DONE
FISH COUNTING WONDERING OTHER
MONITORING THEIR FEDERAL FUNDED
STATE FUNDS THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY WE'RE REALLY AT RISK
OF LOSING THIS LONG TERM.
SCIENTIFIC BASIS IF WE STOP OR
IF WE ALLOW TO STOP THE KINDS OF
MONITORING THAT HAS HAPPENED.
AND WATER QUALITY MONITORING
WHETHER IT'S ON OR OFFSHORE.
THAT OCEAN CONDITIONS THAT
CHEMISTRY THE OCEAN WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE COLLECTING IN
INVESTING IN.
THAT BROADER SCIENTIFIC DATA SO
THAT WE CAN BRING THEM TO THESE
KINDS OF FOR AND SOCIAL
PROTECTION COUNCIL AT OCEANSIDE
STRESSED.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE.
THE DATA TO START TO KNOW WHAT
TO DO BECAUSE ULTIMATELY WITH
THE CHANGING CHEMISTRY AND THE
IMPACT THAT THAT'S GOING TO HAVE
THESE ARE VERY LARGE INTRACTABLE
PROBLEMS.
AND WE'RE SEEING A WEATHER WITH
TIMO CASTED CHANGING
TEMPERATURES THAT ARE DRIVING
SPECIES CHANGES THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE ON A REAL TIME
BASIS.
AND HOW WE MANAGE THIS BIG
QUESTION BECOMES.
VERY DIFFICULT THREE TWO BUT WE
ARE STARTING WITH THOSE THE
PIECES TOGETHER AND THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND THROUGH OTHERS.
MAKING SURE WE'RE BRINGING THAT
THE SCIENCE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
CONTACTS SO THAT WE KNOW WHAT TO
DO AND WORKING MORE CLOSELY WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION.
IS IS A KEY FOR US COLLECTIVELY
TO FIND OUR WAY THROUGH THIS AND
I THINK WE'RE SEEING THAT
AWARENESS AND THAT'S WHY.
I HAD LUNCH IN THE SUMMERTIME.
TO THIS COMMITTEE THIS JOINT
COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHAIR WITH UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP THE FACT THAT WE ARE
HAVING MORE HEARINGS THAT ARE
HEARING OUR IN DEPTH THAT WE'RE
NOT STARTING.
WE'RE NOT JUST HEARING THIS AND
WORKING WITH THE FISHERMEN ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS YES THE FOOD LAST
NIGHT WAS LOVELY AND WE DO THAT
BUT THE ONGOING CONVERSATION AND
BRING SCIENCE INTO.
THE CONVERSATION ON A REGULAR
BASIS IS IS REALLY WHAT WE NEED
TO BE DOING.
AND THAT'S WHY I AGREE WITH
DOCTOR WHITE AND THAT I AM VERY
HAPPY TO BE CALIFORNIA NOW AND
VERY HOPEFUL THAT EVEN AS WE
TACKLE DIFFICULT QUESTIONS.
AND HAVE HAD LONG STANDING
DEBATES IN CONVERSATIONS AMONG
THE DIFFERENT SECTORS INVOLVED
HERE.
THAT WE ARE STARTING TO MAKE
PROGRESS.
ON INDIVIDUAL LEVELS BUT ALSO
LOOKING AT THE BIGGER PICTURE
WHICH IS ULTIMATELY SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE SIT ON THE SHORES OF
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT.
PIECES OF WILDLIFE AND
BIODIVERSITY IN THE WORLD AND
AND THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
MAINTAIN AND TO TO HELP US
MANAGE THIS WILL REALLY DOING
HOPING WE IN THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS AS WE GO THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS.
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
SHORTFALLS IN TESTING.
AND PROVIDE SOME OF THAT
CONTINUITY AND BRING IN.
THAT DOES NUTS AND BOLTS PIECES
UPDATED THEY WORK SO THAT WE
DON'T LOSE THE TRAJECTORY OF THE
SCIENTIFIC DATA THAT THAT WE
HAVE COLLECTED.
SO THIS IS THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES.
AND THROUGH THAT PROCESS WE NEED
TO BE LOOKING AT THAT AND AND
LOOKING AT WHERE WE HAVE RELIED
ON FEDERAL FUNDING AND WE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO RELY ON THAT
ANYMORE OR WHERE THE STATE HAS
BEEN FUN THE DIFFERENT PROJECTS
PICTURE WE'RE TYING THOSE
TOGETHER.
AND FINDING THOSE IN A IN A
SIGNIFICANT MANNER BECAUSE THE
SCIENTISTS IN THE FASHION THAT
ARE REALLY GOING TO NEED.
THAT DATA AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
TRY AND SORT OUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND WHAT WE CAN DO
ABOUT IT IN THE LONG RUN SO I
APPRECIATE THE REPORTS.
THE HOPEFULNESS BUT ALSO THE THE
SORT OF CONNECTIONS BETWEEN EACH
OF THE PIECES.
OF THE ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
THAT WE'RE SEEING HERE AND THE
PROGRESS THAT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE.
TO MAKE OVER THE YEARS BUT SO.
WELL SIR THANK YOU I THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A QUESTION.
BUT JUST LISTENING TO YOU TALK
IN THOSE AREAS THEY JUST STRIKES
ME THAT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S AT STAKE
AND THE GAPS IN WHAT WE'RE
PROVIDING AND WHETHER IT'S
PERMITTING FOR GETTING DIFFERENT
AGENCIES TO TALK TO EACH OTHER
THAT HADN'T AND LOOK.
MORE HOLISTICALLY AT WHAT THE
IMPACTS ARE IN THE VARIOUS
ECOSYSTEMS.
THAT HAVE ON ONE ANOTHER AND
THAT'S OFTEN BEEN LACKING IN --
POLICY MAKING FRAMEWORK AND
THAT'S WHAT.
THIS COMMITTEE REALLY AND START
TO DO OR HAS BEEN DOING AND
CONTINUES TO DO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH PLEASE I JUST
WANT TO ADD TO THAT YES AND
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT WHALES
AND WHALE INTEGUMENT WERE THE
DENTURES CAPTION YOU'RE WORKING
GROUP AND THE CRUX OF THE RAMP
IS.
FIND A DATA INPUT SO GOES RIGHT
BACK TO EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
YEAH IT'S SO SO HEARING WHERE
THE SHORTFALLS ARE IN
UNDERSTANDING THOSE UP. FOR
TALKING ALOUD TO OURSELVES HERE
TOO WE NEED TO INTERNALIZE THAT
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING
THOSE AND THOSE MECHANISMS IN
PLACE HERE THROUGH OUR BUDGETARY
PROCESS.
AND ENSURE THAT THAT THAT WERE
WHERE TO GO FIVE YEARS TEN YEARS
NOW IF THESE DATA STREAMS STOP.
THE THAT'S TOTALLY VERY CRITICAL
FOR US NO THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
RESCUE PLEASE I COULD ADD A
COMMENT TO THAT --
WE'RE IN IN THE RESTORATION
INDUSTRY WERE WERE VERY GOOD AT
THE TRACTOR PART OF THE
RESTORATION WE KNOW HOW TO TAKE
OUT CULBERTSON PUTTING BRIDGES
WE NOT A PUT.
LOGS AND STRUCTURES IN STRINGS
TO CREATE HABITAT WELL WE'RE NOT
REAL GOOD AT AND WE DON'T HAVE
CONSISTENT FUNDING FOR IS THE
PLANNING.
THE UP FRONT STRATEGIC PLANNING
AND AND BUILDING IN THE SCIENCE
INTO OUR RESTORATION AND THEN
THE FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE
MONITORING AND WE NEED THAT DATA
WE NEED THAT SCIENTIFIC
STRUCTURE AND THE DATA TO ENSURE
THAT THE MONEY THAT WE SPEND.
ITS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR
NOW ARE BEING EFFECTIVE WE
REALLY NEED THAT THAT SCIENTIFIC
STRUCTURE IN IT AND IT DOESN'T
COME FROM THE GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT DOESN'T COME FROM TE BOND
FUNDS.
WE NEED A CONSISTENT SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO DO THOSE THINGS.
IT WAS JUST TALKING WITH THE
SECRETARIES OF ABOUT THIS AS WE
CREATE BONDS IN IN SOME OF THE
OTHERS.
BECAUSE WE WE FIND SOME OF THE
SEXY STUFF SO INTERESTING OFF
THE BUS BUT NOT THE PLANNING
YOUR RIGHT AND NOT THE
MONITORING.
THE LOCAL AGENCIES ARE FINDING
IT INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO
EVEN APPLY FOR SOME OF THE FUNDS
THAT ARE OUT THERE.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO TO BE ABLE TO APPLY
TO DO THE PLANNING.
AND WERE WERE FAMOUS FOR MAKING
SURE THAT THINGS ARE SHOVEL
READY BECAUSE THAT SUFFICIENT
THAT'S EFFECTIVE BUT HOW DO WE
GET TO THE POINT OF BEING SHOVEL
READY.
WITHOUT THE PLANNING.
AND HOW DO WE EVEN UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE IF WE
COULD HAVE THAT LONGER TERM
LINES FIVE YEARS TEN YEARS DOWN
THE LINE.
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE PUT THE
RIGHT PROGRAMS IN PLACE WITHOUT
THAT PLANNING AND THEN YOU'RE
RIGHT WITHOUT THE MONITORING
PIECES.
IT'S ALMOST THAT.
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING THE
PROJECTS?
BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
BENEFIT THE PROJECTS IT.
WITHOUT.
THE WITHOUT THE MONITORING AND
WAR WITH THE NEXT PROJECT SHOULD
BE WITHOUT THE MODERATE SO
YOU'RE RIGHT WE'RE WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT THE VERY EARLY AND
FOR THE BACK INTO THE PROJECT
SOMETHING IN THE WAY THAT WE
SHOULD BE.
AND WE HEAR THIS ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS FROM THE AGENCIES THAT ARE
OUT THERE TRYING TO IMPLEMENT IT
TRY TO FIND WAYS TO DRAW DOWN
THE MONEY.
SO THE YEAH THANK YOU POINT WELL
TAKEN.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
WHEN I SAY THANK YOU TO OUR?
COMMITTEE REPORTS GREAT JOB AS
USUAL IN WERE SO APPRECIATE THE
HERE TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU JOHN WE NOW WOULD LIKE
TO OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE ANY ONE OF
YOU TO BE A TO COME FORWARD
UNDER PUBLIC COMMENT.
EACH SPEAKER WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES BE ABLE TO SPEAK WITH
THE COMMITTEE WE WELCOME ANY
COMMENTS CRITICISMS CONCERNS ANY
OF COURSE ANY CONVERSATION.
IF YOU DON'T MIND IS GIVEN AS
YOUR FIRST NAME WELCOME SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
HANGING WITH US IS GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN YOU BET I'M FREEZING
BUT I'LL TALK FAST SO A WARM UPS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY --
WANT TO TALK TO SOMETHINGS THAT --
WE WE KINDOF SKIPPED AROUND
TODAY BUT YOU KNOW I SPENT A LOT
OF TIME ON THE COAST IN MORAN
FROM STINSON BEACH UP TO JENNER
PICKING UP TRASH SO I KNOW WHAT
SHOWS UP OUT THERE --
GEAR RETRIEVAL AND I THINK IT'S
GREAT THAT.
THE CRAP INDUSTRIES TALK ABOUT
GAY RETRIEVAL --
NOTHING WAS SAID ABOUT ALL THE
GEAR OF THEIRS THAT I RETRIEVE
OFF THE BEACH AND THAT'S THE
ROPES THE TRAPS THE BIG JARS THE
BULLIES.
AND ALL OF THE ABOVE MENTIONED
STUFF THAT BACKGROUND INTO TINY
BITS -- I'VE
REACHED OUT TO DECALOGUE.
HE REACHED OUT TO THE OTHER
FISHERMEN IN TODAY TO PAY.
AND THEY SAID NO THEY WOULD NOT
COME DOWN AND HELP SO GIVEN THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE THAT THE
INDUSTRY FUND.
A CLEAN UP CREW.
OTHER THAN MYSELF --
I'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR TEN YEARS
NOW -- ON
PAGE.
AND GET SOME PEOPLE OUT ON THE
BEACH TO CLEAN UP THE MESS THAT
PLASTERS.
THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA OREGON
WASHINGTON EVERY YEAR WITH CRAP
YOUR TICKETS --
THAT SHOWS UP --
WE TALK ABOUT LANDING TAXES OF
FISH.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE AWARE BUT
TO MOST BIG GROWERS --
GROW SEVERAL MILLION OYSTERS
EVERY YEAR AND TO MOST PAY AND
YET THE LEASE FEES AND THE TAXES
COLLECTED JUST RECENTLY BUMPED
UP TO ABOUT THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THERE'S NOT EVEN ENOUGH MONEY TO
PAY FOR A A TECHNICIAN MUCH LAST
GAME WARDEN OVERSIGHT.
AND YOU KNOW REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
PEOPLE OUT THERE KEEP AN EYE ON
THOSE GUYS --
THE THE GEAR THAT I PICK UP.
OUR WELL I TALKED I TALKED ABOUT
THAT -- YEAH
I GUESS I DON'T WANT.
TO BELABOR THE POINT.
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS I SORT OF
SAY TO ME WHETHER IT'S ITEMS ON
THE BEACH.
OR WHAT'S HAPPENED IN OUR STATE
HIGHWAYS YOU HAVE BEEN OUT THERE
LIKE YOU SAID FOR THE PAST
DECADE -- IN
WITH A SPECIAL FOCUS ON WEST
READY JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU BET WELL THANK YOU
BUT I DO WANT TO PUT IN A WORD
FOR THE TWO MOST BIG GROWERS --
BECAUSE I'VE EEN WRITING THEM.
AFTER THE HUGE STORM EVENTS THAT
WE JUST HAD THAT'S WHAT USUALLY
SHAKESPEARE LOOSE.
THERE WAS AN WHAT LAST YEAR AND
PICKING UP THEIR GEAR SO I'M I'M
NOT HAVEN'T YEAH I'M ABLE TO GO
OUT AND SPEND MORE TIME
ELSEWHERE SO I WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR THEIR EFFORTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
FOR TRAVELLING HERE TODAY IT
REALLY MEANS A LOT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU MY NAME IS MIKE MCCORKLE I
LIFETIME SEAFOOD PROFESSIONALS
THE FOOD OR RESEARCH.
ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF A GROUP OF
SMALL TRAWLERS [inaudible]
CALLED.
ALSO IN CALIFORNIA TRAWLERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE FISH IN A
GROUP.
ALL OF WHICH CATEGORY WHICH IS
CALLED NON GROUNDFISH TROLL WHAT
WE CATCHES SEA CUCUMBERS.
ALL RIDGEBACK FRONT AND
CALIFORNIA HELLO.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL TO
EXTEND THE LIFE OF THE SEA
CUCUMBER FISHERY.
ALL HAIL STARTED THAT FISHERY
FORTY OVER FORTY YEARS AGO AND
I'LL.
ALL OF A WHIM OF I THOUGHT MAYBE
THERE WAS A MARKET AT NIGHT WE
AN AUDIT KETCHUM WE DIDN'T WANT
TO DO ANYTHING FOR THE FORTY
YEARS.
WE DEVELOP THE GOOD SUSTAINABLE
RENEWABLE FISHERY FOR THE RED
SEA CUCUMBER.
ALL.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO THE FISHERMEN
IT'S JUST A FEW FISHERMEN IN
THIS GROUP GOT ALL BALSAM DIED
THE GOLD SOMEONE BROKE IN.
THE STRONG ONES LIKE MYSELF WERE
STILL HERE BUT ALL THE PROCESSOR
IS IMPORTANT TO THEM TOO BECAUSE
AS A NEW UNIQUE PROCESSING --
THING THAT HAPPENS TO PROCESS
THE SEA CUCUMBER THEY'RE
ACTUALLY COOKED AND DRIED.
AND THEY'RE SOLD DRIED AND THEN
THEY'RE RECONSTITUTED --
INTO OF ACTUALLY OF PROTEIN
PRODUCT.
AND VERY GOOD FOR MALES THAT IS
GOOD FOR MALES IT'S GOOD DEED
FOR THE PREPARED CORRECTLY
[inaudible]
AND ALL.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT IT
IS THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED
PROBABLY.
DIFFERENT KINDS OF CUCUMBERS IN
THE WORLD ON THIS I SEE ON THE
DRIED MARKET IS A BALL NUMBER
THREE IN VALUE.
SO IT HAS A GOOD VALUE TO A AND
WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE OUR
FISHERY.
IT'S A LIMITED ENTRY FISHERY
THERE'S NOT VERY MANY PERMITS
LEFT NOW.
SO IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT SOMEBODY CAN JUST
JUMP INTO REGULAR PURPLE GO OUT
AND DO.
YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CATCH THE STORIES YEAH SO AGAIN
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR WHOLE LONG
IN THE LIFE OF THAT FISHERY
THANK YOU NO GREAT MIKE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE AS
USUAL IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
[inaudible]
HEY.
THIS IS THE SERVER.
RICHARD GANGER I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN --
WATERSHED RESTORATION AND
FORESTRY ISSUES AND ALL RELATED
MATTERS SINCE THE SEVENTIES.
AND I DON'T WANT TO USE SOME
THESE PAY AND MITCH FERRO
[inaudible]
AND CRAIG BELL Z. GREATER --
VERN CLARK.
AND STEPHEN DRONE.
VERY FUSSY AND TIME WAS SO LOW
AS EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMMUNITY ORIENTED IN TRYING TO
DO -- THE
BEST RATE BETWEEN THE FORCE THE
FISHERIES.
HI AND I'M REALLY TRYING TO
FOCUS ON THAT INTEGRATION.
IN CONNECTION WITH COMMUNITIES
AND THAT WAS JUST HEAD ON REALLY
WITH THIS ISSUE ABOUT PLANNING
pTHERE NEEDS TO BE --
THE THE EMPOWERMENT OF THE
SMALLER GROUPS IN THE SKIN THE
RUSSIANS IS SPECIALLY IMPORTANT
pRIGHT NOW.
WITH THIS WHOLE --
THE OF WHAT A CROSS SECTION OF A
B. --
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO WITH THE
INTENT -- OR
FOR GAS REDUCTION --
ROAD IN --
RIGHT PARIAN --
MANSION PLANS WITH.
THE FOREST MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE.
NO THAT IS COME TO THE FORE
BECAUSE OF THE THE DAMAGE WITH
FIRE IN THE FIRE AND ALL THAT IS
ONE THING THAT REALLY HASN'T
BEEN CONSIDERED.
IN THE CONTEXT OF CUMULATIVE
EFFECTS INTERNAL HARVESTING NOW
ALL THE SUDDEN IT'S ALL GOING ON
WITH THE NEEDS TO BE SOME REALLY
THOUGHTFUL.
OF THE PLANNING AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE DYNAMIC AND
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN AND PART OF
THAT.
OKAY I'LL TALK WITH YOU --
A SENATOR ABOUT --
THE FOREST MANAGEMENT AND I KNOW
THERE ARE ALSO THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF OF OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FORESTRY AND HIS EFFORTS TO
PREVENT THE DAMMING OF THE
OVERDOSE RIOS.
AND HIS CURRENT --
REAL FOCUS AND WE NEED TO RENEW
OUR TO PREDICT FORCE MIS FITS IN
WITH THE WHOLE --
THE MISSION OF THE FORCE
MANAGEMENT TEAM.
AND ALL OF THAT --
AND INDUCE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH THE
AGENCY'S HISTORY --
THERE ISN'T ACTUALLY MOVING
FORWARD ON THE FOR REFORMS OF
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LOT
OF SEC PUTTING THINGS OFF HAVING
AGENCY CENTRIC AND I'M.
REFERRING TO THE SPECIFIC
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF THE
PLANNING WATERSHED PILOT PROJECT
OF THE INITIAL WHICH IS JUST --
COMPLETED AND IT'S IT'S PROBLEMS
WITH HAVING --
A LACK OF YOU [inaudible]
AND FACILITATE RESTORATION IN A
WHOLE.
RANGE y
THE HARVEST PLANTS ARE MEASURED
IN ABOUT A MINUTE AND I
APOLOGIZE I'M WELL I HAVE THAT
MUCH LEFT HEY THERE YOU GO
THAT'S AMAZING I'M SAYING AND
TRAIN FOR THREE SO THIS TICKET
IS REALLY INTERESTING
[inaudible]
BUT AND I WOULD IMPLORE YOU
YOURSELVES SENATOR AND THE
COMMITTEE AND OTHER --
OF LEGISLATIVE BODIES --
TO HAVE --
SOME SERIOUS HEARING OUR
HEARINGS --
BOTH FOR WHAT IS A HEALTHY.
FOR WHAT IS HEALTHY FOR SKIN IN
THERE AND HELP THE FORESTS HAVE
LARGE TREES.
AND OVER TREES THERE ARE
RESISTANT AND THEN PUT IT ALL
THESE OTHER NEEDS AND FOR THE
INCENTIVES TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
AND WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
HOPEFULLY HAVING A TWO DAY
WORKSHOP AND TOUR OF JACKSON.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT.
AND I HAVE YOUR THOUGH GIVE TO
THE SERGEANT ARMS TO GIVE I HAVE
A FOREST HEALTH.
THANK PUT OUT HERE BY WHY FORCE
MATTER WHICH WAS FOUNDED BY
RICHARD WILSON --
ARTICLES PHOTOS I WROTE.
IN THE PLANNING WATERSHED
PROCESS MIGHT MAKE MICHAEL
CURRY'S COMMENTS ABOUT THE
PLANNING WATERSHED.
HOW FRAGILE A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE AND
FOR YOUR?
TIRELESS FIGHT AS WELL SO THANK-YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE TO MAKE SOME
PROGRESS ABOUT TIME HEY THERE
YOU GO THANK YOU RICHARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HANGING WITH US THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY NAME IS DAVID GOLDENBERG
I'M THE CHAIRMAN OF A DETERRENT
BUT THE MANAGER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SEVEN COUNSELING
CALIFORNIA SEA URCHIN COMMISSION.
THAT HAS BEEN SAID ABOUT THE
PLIGHT OF THE SALMON BUT AS THE
SALMON COUNCIL WE ARE THE
MARKETING ENTITY THAT HELPED
MARKETING.
AND THAT PROMOTE THE THE FISH SO
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THIS YEAR WITH
A GREATER OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
SOME FISH TO MARKET LAST THREE
YEARS IT'S BEEN KIND OF LEAN.
BUT LIGHT --
ATTACK ON TO WHAT JIM ANDERSON
SAID EARLIER AND ALSO LAURIE
FRENCH THAT FEWER AND FEWER
FISHERMEN HAS BEEN OUT THERE
BECAUSE IT HASN'T BEEN MUCH
OPPORTUNITY.
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES HERE IS STILL
AMOUNT TO ITS FEWER FACE THEN
WE'VE NORMALLY AT THE MARKET AND
SO -- AND
THEY HAVE TO DO IT FOR A PROFIT
AND SO WHEN THEY'RE OUT THERE
SPENDING AROUND TRYING TO FIND
FISH -- WITH
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THE HAVEA
PROFITABLE TIME AND AND KAY AND
AND HAVE SOMEPLACE TO MARKET
DIVISION BASICALLY WE'RE
STARTING OUT FROM SCRATCH.
AS WE HAVE BEEN IN THE MARKET
PLACE THAT THAT OFTEN HE
SEVENTEEN I KNOW THAT IT'S NOW
UP TO CONGRESS AS HANDS TO
SUPPLY THE PROCREATION BUT
ANYTHING THAT THIS COMMITTEE CAN
DO. TO HELP GET US TO THE FINISH
LINE TO BRING THOSE PHONES ON
WOULD BE VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
ON ZERO TEN YOU'VE ALSO HEARD
FROM MR TRUMP WERE AND HOW DIRE
THE SITUATION IS AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE AND ALSO THE
GOVERNOR AND THEY ALSO
DEPARTMENT. FOR HELPING US GET
THE SECOND ROUND OF
APPROPRIATION REQUEST WAS OVER
DISASTER REQUEST. FOR THE C. H.
INDUSTRY BUT IN TALKING TO MY
CHAIRMAN --
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE SITUATION IS GETTING WORSE
SO EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE A
DISASTER IN 201-620-1720
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN ARE NOT
WELL AT ALL.
AND SO -- I
KNOW WITH THE PURPLE SITUATION
IN THE FORT BRAG AREA IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
THAT A LOT OF FISHERMEN ARE
GOING OUT AND WORKING WITH THE
UNIVERSITY TO REMOVE SO THE
PURPLES. TO MAKE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE AND CLEARING A PATH FOR
THEIR HELP TO COME BACK.
BUT THEY'RE CALLING THE PHONE
TOGETHER GOOD DEALS TWENTY
STABILITY AND AND AND SECURE
FUNDING WOULD BE MUCH
APPRECIATED.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST WE ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
REGARDING LANDING TAXES BECAUSE
WE WERE HERE A COUPLE YEARS AGO
AND DECLARING HOW HEART
HOPEFULLY WERE.
AND WE'LL PREVIEW YOUR
LEADERSHIP WITH LOOKING AT A
MORE PREDICTABLE A FUTURE FOR A
LANDING TAXES EVEN THOUGH --
IT'S HARD.
TO PAY THOSE BUT HAVING
PREDICTABLE FEATURES.
FOR IN THEM GO THROUGH THEIR
EXERCISE WITH THE BUDGETING
PROCESS AS WELL BECAUSE THAT
WILL.
SHOW THE NEED FOR WHAT FISHERIES
ARE COSTING AND TO MANAGE THEM
SO.
ALL TOGETHER WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU YEAH DAVID
THANK YOU SO MUCH MAKE YOUR
COMMENTS BEEN TAKING NOTES AS
YOU'VE BEEN.
TALKING AS WELL IN WERE GREAT
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN YOUR
ADVOCACY AND SO HAPPY THAT
YOU'RE HERE TODAY THANK YOU A
CANADIAN WORK LIKE WORKING WITH
THE GERMAN TLF HECK YES.
WATCH OUT FOR WEST SO HE'S A
GOOD A GOOD PEOPLE YES OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
HEY COME INTO A SYSTEM KENNY.
I KNOW YOUR OLD STOMPING GROUNDS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU FOR THIS GREAT HEARING
YOUR ANNUAL --
JOINT COMMITTEE IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND I WOULD LOOK
FORWARD TO COMING UP TO
SACRAMENTO TO SEE YOU GUYS AND
HE WAS GOING ON I LEARNED SO
MUCH.
I'M JUST FOCUSING TODAY A LITTLE
BIT ON SOMETHING I THINK CENTER
KIND OF LOW HANGING FRUIT THAT
MIGHT HELP ON THE DEMO GAS IT
SITUATION.
I'VE SEEN LITTLE BABY SEA LIONS
STARVING AND IT'S JUST SOMETHING
YOU CAN'T UNSEE.
AND I KNOW IT IF THE LG IS
AFFECTING THE CRABS AND SO I
THOUGHT THE LOW HANGING FRUIT MY
FEET THAT WE FIGURE OUT WHAT TO
DO ABOUT SOMEONE [inaudible]
THE PHOSPHORUS AMMONIA AS AND
THE WHAT'S THE OTHER.
ONE US HERE IS --
MANANA AND NITROGEN --
AND THAT IS JUST FLOWING DOWN
OUR CREEKS INTO RIVERS AND IT'S
GOING IN THE OCEAN AND THAT
CREATES ALGAE BLOOMS IS
SOMETHING.
WE CAN CONTROL WE CAN THIS
REALLY CONTROL CLIMATE CHANGE
TOMORROW BUT WE CAN CONTROL WHAT
GOES INTO OUR STREAMS.
WHICH IS HARMING OUR FISHERIES.
AND OF COURSE IT'S CREATING YOU
KNOW HYPOXIC AREAS THAT CREATE
WHICH THE OXYGEN OUT OF THE
WATER AND THEN YOU HAVE --
HE FISH GOING FURTHER OUT TO SEA
TO GET OXYGEN AND FOOD AND THAT
RESULTS IN SOME BABY SEA LIONS
STARVING.
SO IT'S ALL CONNECTED SO I MY
SOLUTION WOULD BE YOU KNOW
ENCOURAGE REGIONAL BOARDS AND
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN STOP SOME
OF THE SEDIMENTATION --
THAT SEEMS TO BE A IS SOMETHING
THAT THIS IS OUR DUTY AND
RESPONSIBILITY ALREADY SO IT'S
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
THE I. CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE
NEED TO DO BETTER ON OUR RUN OFF
ISSUES -- I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE HIGH QUALITY --
INDUSTRIES AND FISH AND W
SHOULD MARKET IT AT A HIGHER
PRICE WE WOULD HAVE TO HARVEST
AS MUCH.
FISHERMEN COULD MAKE A LIVING
AND WE COULD LEAVE MORE FISH IN
THE OCEAN I THINK THAT'S IT AND
THE SUPERBOWL GOAL IS TO SAY WE
HAVE THE BEST FISH AND THAT WAY.
EVERYBODY CAN SURVIVE AND MIGHT
BE AN INTERESTING MARKETING
APPROACH --
I DON'T REALLY I'M NOT TOO
EXCITED ABOUT HEARING THAT WE'RE
GOING FOR INSULATED INCIDENTAL
TAKE PERMIT. TO TAKE WHALES
BECAUSE OF ENTANGLEMENTS --
INCIDENTAL TAKE PERMIT MEANS
IT'S OKAY TAKE.
SPECIES AND I WOULD NOT
ENCOURAGE A STATE TO PURSUE THAT.
MYSELF I THINK THAT WE CANCEL
THIS ANOTHER WAY --
IN I THINK THIRTY PARTS PER
MILLION I JUST LEARNING SO MUCH
TODAY -- FOR
OUR DEMO GAS LEVELS I THINK WE
SHOULD.
GO FOR THAT AND WE SHOULD GO
LOWER I MEAN WE SHOULD WEAR
CALIFORNIA WE CAN GO BETTER WE
CAN HAVE THE CLEANEST CRABS AND
NOT.
THE SECOND FIDDLE TO WASHINGTON
OREGON SO I'D SAY LET'S.
WORK ON THE RUN OFFICE ISSUES
AND THAT COULD THAT COULD MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING.
REALLY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU FOR COMING TODAY I'M GLAD
YOU'RE HERE.
IN IN.
EIGHTY ONE GOOD AFTERNOON YOU
HAVE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR --
MISTER VICE CHAIR MISTER WESSEL --
THE JEFF CHESTER WITH OCEANIA
THAT'S A THAT'S A BIG PRIORITY
RIGHT NOW --
WE AGREE WITH --
DIRECTOR BOTTOM SCHOOL THE
WEEKEND BOTH SAVE THE WHALES AND
MAINTAIN --
THE VIBRANT FISHERIES OFF OUR
COAST -- AS
A WORKING GROUP MEMBER I LOOK
FORWARD TO TO THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE --
NEXT TUESDAY TO DISCUSS SOME
PROACTIVE MEASURES --
FOR THE SPRING --
AND OTHER ACTIONS --
WE WERE VERY ENCOURAGED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY RECENTLY
HELD AN OPEN HOUSE SHOWCASING
VARIOUS FORMS OF ROBUST GEAR AND
OTHER GEAR INNOVATIONS --
WE ALSO HAD A VERY POSITIVE
DISCUSSION AT THE MARINE
RESOURCE COMMITTEE OF THE FISH
AND GAME COMMISSION ON ROUGH
WITH GEAR --
TESTING YESTERDAY --
WITH WITH --
A LOT OF VERY INTERESTING GOOD
DIALOGUE ABOUT THAT --
LARGELY BECAUSE I THINK THIS
COULD BE A A LOT OF WELLS AROUND.
THE RECENT EXPERIENCE ON THE
WORKING GROUP DID REVEAL THAT WE
WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
KNOWING WHERE THE GEAR IS --
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
THAT SOLAR LOGGERS SHOULD BE
EXPANDED OUT THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE FLEET.
AND AND AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OPC AND OTHERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
DATA THAT WE NEED TO RUN THE RAP
PROGRAM --
WE ASIDE FROM WELL TEN MINUTES
WE SUPPORT ADDITIONAL EXPANDED
C. D. F. W. FUNDING IN
PARTICULAR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE MASTER PLAN FOR FISHERIES AT
THE COMMISSION JUST COMPLETED --
IS IT IS A HUGELY VALUABLE --
PIECES THAT THEY CAN BE I THINK
VERY.
THEY CAN BE A STRONG CASE MADE
FOR MORE FUNDING BASED ON THE
VALUE THAT THEY'LL HAVE TO TO
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES --
WONDER THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
SUPPORTING SENATE BILL TEN
SEVENTEEN REGARDING DRIFT GILL
NET TRANSITION AND ENCOURAGE YOU
HEAR THAT APARTMENT IS NOW
IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS AND WE
ARE CURRENTLY --
RAISING MONEY NOW --
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THAT TRANSITION
PROGRAM --
VERY ACTIVELY WE ALSO HAVE SOME
EXCITING NEWS --
WE DO HAVE A CONSENSUS WE JUST
ARRIVED AT A NEW FISHERY
MANAGEMENT PLAN A FULL DRAFT WE
HAVE WELL GOOD CONSENSUS ON THAT
AND THAT'S NOT GOING TO GO
BEFORE THE COMMISSION FOR A
POTENTIAL ADOPTION IN OCTOBER.
VERY EXCITING TO SEE THAT
COLLABORATION ACROSS THE NGOS --
INDUSTRY AND AND THE AGENCY --
AND JUST LASTLY --
WE DO REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LACK OF CONSERVATION
REPRESENTATION ON THE PACIFIC
FISHERY MANAGEMENT COUNCIL --
ON THE CALIFORNIA DELEGATION IN
PARTICULAR BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH FEDERAL
MANAGEMENT OF ANCHOVY WHICH IS
CURRENTLY IGNORING THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE.
AND WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED BY
RENEWED EFFORTS TO EXPAND AND
REINTRODUCED HARMFUL PELAGIC
LONG LINES OFF THE WEST COAST
THEY'VE BEEN BANNED HERE FOR
FORTY YEARS DO TECHNIQUES --
HIGH LEVELS OF BI CATCH UP SO WE
WE DO --
CONTINUE TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH FISHERMEN AND AND AND AND
REALLY SEE THAT THAT IS THE
ANSWER TO SOLVING MOST OF THESE
PROBLEMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANKS FOR
YOUR WORK OKAY FOR HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HEY ANYONE LETTERMAN WIRE CENTER
STONE AND NOW.
AND HOW MUCH WILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR GIVING ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE SOME
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING.
I STARTED MY FIRST.
COMPANY CATELYN OFFSHORE FORTY
TWO YEARS AGO AS A SEA URCHIN
DIVER AND I'VE.
OVER THE YEARS I'VE LEARNED TO
PROCESS YOUR CHINS AND BY LOCAL
SEAFOOD.
I PRIMARILY BY TUNA.
WELL I WANT TO REALLY THANK YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN YOUR VISION
REGARDING THE LANDING TAX.
YOU INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING US
TO GO SHE'S WITH THE DEPARTMENT
COME UP WITH A REASONABLE
LANDING TAX.
IN YOUR CONCEPT OF INDEXING IS
IS GREAT I REALLY THE SUPPORT
THAT ARE PERCENT.
SECOND OF ALL.
I WANT TO THANK YOUR EFFORTS ON
THE THE DISASTER FUNDING FOR SEA
URCHIN WE WENT THROUGH THE WORST
EL NINO WE EVER WENT THROUGH.
OFF AGAIN THE WORD I'VE BEEN
THROUGH TWO OTHER MAJOR EL NINOS
THAT IMPACT OFFICIALLY BUT
NOTHING LIKE THIS.
ONE SO WE WE HAVE --
WHERE I BUY MOST OF MY SEA
URCHINS ARE TRADITIONALLY BOUGHT
MY SEA URCHINS OUR LANDS ARE
DOWN BETWEEN 8290% IN SAN DIEGO
ORANGE COUNTY --
WE KNOW THERE'S A HUGE PROBLEM
WITH PURPLE OR TONS OF THE NORTH
COAST.
AND THERE ARE SOME POSSIBLE
IDEAS THAT YOU HAD IN YOUR YOUR
DISCUSSION WITH MR TRUMP ARE
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF SOME
TYPE OF LAND BASED --
RANCHING OF THE LARGER PURPLE
SEA URCHINS I THINK THAT NEEDS
TO BE EXPLORED AND DISCUSSED.
ALSO I WANT TO GIVE YOU SOME
NEWS ABOUT THE SEA URCHIN
COMMISSION --
I WAS INVOLVED IN THE REGIONAL
DIRECTORS YOUR CHIN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WHEN IT
WAS AN INDUSTRY INITIATIVE.
INITIATED BY A STATE SENATOR
BELIEVE FROM FORT BRAGG.
WHO WHO AND WHO SET UP A SYSTEM
THE TUITION WERE WE TAXED
OURSELVES WE PACKED OURSELVES SO
WE CAN HELP MANAGEMENT OF THIS
ERA AND FISHERY?
SO I WAS APPOINTED.
TO A B. AT INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES AND WE WORK HAND
IN HAND WITH THE DEPARTMENT THAT
TIME TO COME UP WITH REGULATIONS
FOR THIS YEAR AND FISH INCLUDING.
SIZE LIMITS AND LIMITED ENTRY
AND THOSE HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL UP UNTIL THE LAST ON
THE NEW --
ANYWAY SO THE SOLUTION
COMMISSIONED A NUMBER GOOD
THINGS AND WE RECENTLY HAD A
RENEWAL OF COURSE YOUR CHIN
COMMISSION.
WHAT WILL IT WITH WILL INCLUDE
THAT DIVERS AND PROCESSORS WHICH
WAS PASSED BY A HI MOST 50%
WROTE?
MOST THE INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND SO GREAT
THAT YOU HANG WITH US AT THE
INTERROGATORS DAY READING IS A
LOT.
AND ALWAYS ENJOY HERE FROM YOU
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY BUT IT'S GOOD TO SEE.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON.
YEAH YOU DON'T FROM SERENITY TO
INDIVIDUAL GOOD EVENING I GUESS
YEAH I GUESS A GOOD EVENING
[inaudible]
HANSEN AND ORGANIZATION FOR SOME
LIMITED OF CINEMA COUNTY.
AND FIRST OF ALL WHEN I THANK
YOU FOR THE HEARING YEAH VERY
INFORMATIVE.
IN ALSO WENT --
TO IMAGINING OF IT WHICH IS THE
ANGER WHO IS JUST STOP BY WHEN A
SUPPORT.
HIS COMMENTS SPECIALLY ON THE OF
ON THE HEALTHY FOREST --
HE'S KIND OF IN A MENTOR FOR US
AND I READ ALL THESE THINGS HIS.
WRITINGS IN.
HAS FOUGHT HAVE FOLLOWED HIM FOR
YEARS SO.
I REALLY APPRECIATE HIS WORK --
AND ALSO LET'S SAY I SUPPORT --
ICE I ALSO SUPPORT A OF
FORGETTING WHO CAME UP AND
TALKED ABOUT.
A BILL THAT.
WOULD -- I
GUESS FUND --
THE WATER BOARDS FOR MORE
PARTICIPATION IN THE PHP PROCESS
BECAUSE I MEAN I'VE I'VE BEEN TO
MANY REVIEW TEAM MEETINGS AND
FOLLOW THE BALL THAT PRETTY WELL
AND WITHOUT HAVING THE WATER
BOARD'S EXPERTISE THERE.
AND FISH WILDLIFE AS WELL --
THAT CAUGHT FIRE IS NOT NOT SO
GOOD.
AND ANYWAY I'LL LET IT LET IT GO
AT THAT THAT WE NEED TO BOLSTER --
THOSE FUNDS SO THAT THEY CAN GET
IN THERE AND PURCHASE.
PARTICIPATE WITH THEIR EXPERTISE.
AND AND LASTLY I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION THAT --
WE TALKED ABOUT THE WATER.
FISH SALMON ESPECIALLY.
IN THE WATER FOR SALMON BEGINS
IN THE TRIBUTARIES HIGH UP IN
THE TRIBUTARIES.
INDIA HEADWATERS AND AND THERE'S
A LOT OF LOG GAIN THAT GOES UP
IN -- STARTS
UP HIGH IN THE IN IN THOSE
HEADWATERS.
AND THEY'RE NOT GETTING VERY
MUCH PROTECTION AND THOSE OF
WHAT'S WHAT THEY CALL CLASS
THREE CLASS.
TOO AND BECAUSE THEY ALL LEAD
INTO OUR STREAMS.
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE --
DENUDED WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE SELF WILL FALL --
FLOW DOWN INTO IS TO THAT OR
WHAT WATERS IN THEIR HEATS UP.
AND SO ON AND SO FORTH BUT
ANYWAY SUPPORT SOME TIME.
AT TO HAVE THAT KIND OF ACTION
HAPPEN MAYBE THROUGH A FUTURE --
ACTION THAT YOU CAN DEAL ANYWAY
APPRECIATE AGAIN THAT YOU WILL
HEAR AND WE SEE NEXT TIME --
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HEARING
CAN REALLY AS WELL --
IN WILL.
RICHARD IS THERE IN THE BACK AND
HE IS A LEGEND AND DOES
FANTASTIC WORK ON BEHALF SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON HELLO MY NAME
IS GERRY TRUMPER OF BOMBS OLDER
SON WATCH OUT AT EYES WAS THANK
ALL THREE OF YOU FOR A SIT AND
LISTEN TO ALL THIS BUT SO YEAH I
JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE FUTURE THING IT'S
BEEN MY ONLY.
JOB I'VE EVER HAD MY ENTIRE LIFE
SO -- IT'S
BEEN A PRETTY TOUGH FOR YEARS.
GOING ON FIVE NO I THINK IT IS.
FOUR FIVE ANYWAYS --
I'M ALSO ONE OF THE URCHIN
PURPOSE YOUR GENERATOR CATER
DIVERS IT IT'S WORKING WITH
CYNTHIA COTTON OVER OUT OF FORT
BRAGG AND SO I'VE BEEN PUT A LOT
EFFORT OUT FOR ABOUT A YEAR ON
THAT -- JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT IF THERE REALLY
IS SUCH THING AS A DISASTER
RELIEF WE KIND OF NEED.
THAT'S ABOUT ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
NINE A END.
JUST SIT BACK I THINK THAT.
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE PRIORITY --
FOR LEGISLATURE IT'S MOVED FROM
US AS THE GOVERNOR GOT ON IT
LITERALLY WITHIN TWO DAYS.
I AND IT IS NOW MOVING --
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE
SO ALSO BE HONEST ABOUT IT IT IS
A SLOW PROCESS.
HOW MANY HITS THE FEDS I
UNDERSTAND YEAH ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU YEAH BUT I THINK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER PROGRAM FOR YOUR
HERE THANK YOU? TWO GENERATIONS
THE TEMPERATURE HERE ARE HERE
TODAY SO IT'S GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH I LOVE IT.
A GOOD EVENING GOODBYE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE AND A
MEMBER STILL IN TIME.
FOR TAKING YOUR TIME TO HAVE
THIS HEARING TODAY I'M VIVIEN
HELLO WELL ON THE WATERSHED
CONSERVATION DIRECTOR OF PACIFIC
COAST FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS.
AND SO I SPECIALLY APPRECIATE.
NO OP NOT COMMENTS TODAY FOR
ORGANIZATION. ONE AD THE I WAS A
SPECIFIC ESPECIALLY.
IN FAVOR OF WHAT.
ASSEMBLYMAN DOLLY WAS SAYING
ABOUT FOREST PRODUCING CLEAN
WATER [inaudible]
AND ABOUT HAVING A BALANCED
BETWEEN THE USES OF WATER.
NO THERE'S MORE DEMAND FOR WATER
THAN THERE IS SUPPLY.
THE SUPPLY IS BEING DIVIDED UP
POLITICALLY AND NOT.
AS EQUITABLY AS WE WOULD LIKE
[inaudible] FOR EXAMPLE.
THE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
ACRE FEET.
THAT CONGRESS DESIGNATED FOR US.
FROM THE SACRAMENTO RIVER WE
HAVEN'T SEEN A DROP OF THAT.
IN THE MANY YEARS [inaudible]
SO -- WE
WILL NOT LOOK BACK AT SOME OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA VICE RE COMMITTEE
THAT WERE THE REASON ORIGINAL
REASON FOR THIS HEARING.
EVERY YEAR WITH OUR REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE I'VE BEEN ON
THAT COMMITTEE FOR MANY YEARS
[inaudible]
LOOKING BACK [inaudible]
WE FIND [inaudible]
THAT.
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
EARLIER ON ARE STILL APPROPRIATE
TODAY AND SOME OF THEM HAVE NOT
BEEN CARRIED OUT.
BUT WOULD IT WOULD BE GOOD FOR
US TO LOOK BACK AT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE CHC AND
TOM HAS.
POSTED THEM ON THE WEBSITE SO
THERE REALLY SHOULD FIND
[inaudible] FOR EXAMPLE.
IN. NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE
NEW.
HABITAT COMMITTEE OF THE PACIFIC
FISHERIES MANAGEMENT COUNCIL.
HAD A POLICY HAS A NEW POLICY.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THAT
THERE SHOULD BE NO NET LOSS.
IN THE PRODUCTIVE CAPACITY OF
ANY MARINE ASTRAEA REMAIN OR
FRESHWATER HABITATS THIS THIS
DAN.
RESERVE EXAMINED.
THE CITY COUNCIL REASSURED CO
EQUAL TREATMENT WITH OTHER
PURPOSES OF WATER AND LAND
RESOURCE.
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS AND THERE'S
THE BALANCE THAT WE'RE SEEKING
AGAIN.
DID ANY OF THAT ON ONE MINUTE
[inaudible]
WHICH OF WE HAD A HATCHERY.
MANAGERS COME TO THE CSE MEETING
YESTERDAY.
AND THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
LEGALLY HOT WATER IN THE RIVERS
BLOW THEIR HATCHERIES FOR THE
NATURALLY SPAWNING.
SALMON.
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT REPORT
SAID A REASONABLE GOAL WOULD BE
TO DOUBLE STATEWIDE SALMON
PRODUCTION BY.
TWENTY TEN THIS DOUBLE LANGUAGE
DURING THIS THE STATE'S ECONOMY
BY GENERATING A FIVE THOUSAND
NEW JOBS AND INCREASING REVENUES.
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND BE WORTH SIX
BILLION DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS AND BUSINESSES.
AND THAT WOULD BE DOUBLE THAT
AMOUNT IN TODAY'S DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD VERY LOW
INFLATION FORTUNATELY.
I WANTED TO REMIND ASSEMBLYMAN
DOLLY THAT FISHERMEN ALSO
PRODUCE FOOD FOR PEOPLE AS WELL
AS THE AGRICULTURE FOLKS.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR SUPPORT AND I WANT TO
PRESENT YOU.
WITH ONE OF THESE T. SHIRTS FROM
PACIFIC STATES MARINE FISHERIES
COMMISSION.
A FEW YEARS AGO LIKE THIRTY
YEARS AGO.
AND IT SAYS IT'S A LITTLE KNOWN
FACT.
THAT FISH GROW ON TREES.
OKAY THERE WE GO.
THAT'S A GOOD SURE.
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE PRIDE I
LOVE THAT.
VERY COOL SO WE'LL KEEP THAT I'M
NOT AS OPTIMISTIC AS THE
DIRECTOR ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
WERE FACING THIS DAYS AND
FISHERIES.
BUT WE'LL KEEP PLUGGING AWAY AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR A GRATEFUL EYES
CAN BE A LITTLE AWKWARD BECAUSE
THE VICE URINARY FIGHTING OVER
HERE SHORTLY SO WATCH OUT.
SO -- I
THINK.
ART HEY THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
GRATEFUL.
GOOD EVENING WELCOME THANKS FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU --
MY NAME IS DAN TRUMPER I'M TOM
TRIPPERS WHY LIKE IT WE'RE GONNA
TREVOR FAVOR YOU.
KNOW YOU SEE THERE.
YEAH I THINK YOU'RE BEING HERE
YOU BET I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THERE WAS THREE GENERATIONS OF
THE DINNER LAST NIGHT ALL MY
GOSH YEAH AND SO THAT'S WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT.
THIS DISASTER RELIEF MONEY YEAH
SO THAT WE CAN KEEP THE
PROCESSING PLANT GOING FOR THE
NEXT FEW GENERATIONS TO COME AND
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR EFFORT YEAH IT WAS.
INTERESTING BEING HERE TODAY I'M
NEW TO ALL OF THIS SO I GET TO
IT IN THE GOOSE RIVER I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS --
IT IS SO PERSONAL RIGHT IT IS --
IN MORNING REMAIN IS WONDERFUL
TO BE ABLE TO SEE.
YOUR SON HERE TODAY AND BE ABLE
TO PUT A FACE IT IS A FAMILY RUN
BUSINESS CREDIT IS CORRECT.
WONDERFUL AND I'M REALLY HAPPY
MADE A DECISION TO BECOME THE
SPEAK WITH US THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEANS A LOT NICE JOB.
WE'D LIKE TO GET TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO SPEAK IF YOU CAN JUST
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT WHEN WE BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE OUT WHEN I START
OUT BY SAYING THANK YOU TO ALL
OF OUR SPEAKERS --
IT'S ONE OF THE BEST PARTS OF
THIS FORUM IS HEARING FROM ALL
OF YOU -- IN
I'M GONNA SEE IF THE VICE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO HAVE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS --
AT THE SITES TAKEN THE SHIRT.
AS A STEP OFFICE VICE CHAIR.
YOU HAVE A BELIEVE THEY SHOULD
HAVE TO I JUST WANT.
TO HE SAID MORE THAN ENOUGH
TODAY THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE THIS IS ALWAYS A VERY
INTERESTING.
AND I THINK PRODUCTIVE SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I WOULD LIKE
TO ADD.
THIS TO A FEW FOLLOW UPS FIRST
OF ALL -- TO
DIRECTED TO MISTER ANDERSON --
YEAH I KNOW YOU HAD SOME
CONCERNS RICK WE'RE ALREADY ON
IT WILL BE ABLE TO GET YOU SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THOSE
REPORTS --
IS THERE'S BEEN SOME --
SINCERE FRUSTRATION ABOUT
ACQUIRING THEM AND PARTICULARLY
HOW BEHIND THEY ARE SO WERE
ALREADY WORKING ON THAT --
AND JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR THAT FOR THAT FEEDBACK WILL
BE WORKING WITH THAT.
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE LOOK AT
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT --
FORMS OF THE YEAR HERE IN THE
CAPITAL --
IN IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE BRINGING
IN SMALL FAMILY BUSINESS OWNERS
AS WE HEARD FROM JUST.
FROM HIS TEMPER WHO IS THE HEART
OF CALIFORNIA'S FISHING INDUSTRY.
IT'S NOT LARGE COMMERCIAL FIRMS
IT'S FAMILY RUN BUSINESSES IT'S
FAMILIES WHO HAVE PASSED BOATS
DOWN FOR TWO THREE SOMETIMES
FOUR GENERATIONS.
OUT WE'VE BEEN HARVESTING CRAB
OFF OF THE GOLDEN GATE SINCE THE
MID EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
I. N. A ROBUST FISHERY HAS BEEN
A PART OF THE STATES PASSED IN
BECAUSE OF ALL OF YOU IN THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING WE'RE
GOING TO ENSURE THAT IS CAN BE
PART.
OF OUR STATE'S FUTURE.
I A WHILE WE HAVE CHALLENGES I
GOT A TOGETHER WHEN TIMES ARE
TOUGH WE ARE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO GET THROUGH IT.
AND I I THINK TIME IS OF THE
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE AS WERE
SEEN SIGNIFICANT CHANGES LIKE
NEVER BEFORE WITHIN OUR OCEANS
AND WITHIN OUR WATERSHEDS --
IN HOW THEY'RE ALL RELATED YOU
HAVE OUR COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE AT YOUR
VOICE HERE IN THE STATE CAPITAL
I AND WANT TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY.
WITH YOU I'D LIKE TO BE TO GO
THROUGH SOME FOLLOW UPS THAT WE
HAVE ODD THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL
BE WORKING ON NUMBER ONE IS
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED.
TO FIGURE OUT THAT ISSUE WITH
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INSURING THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
GET ADDITIONAL FUNDING BECAUSE
ON THE CRAB SIDE.
THEY DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
BANDWIDTH AND IT'S BEEN AN
ONGOING CONCERN AND WHY THEY
RECEIVE SOME ADDITIONAL MONEY
LAST YEAR IS NOT NEARLY ENOUGH
NOT AS MUCH AS HE DFW.
WE ARE GONNA BE INVITING ALL OF
YOU TO OUR WIND ENERGY HEARING
THAT'LL BE HELD UP AT THE
AQUATIC CENTER IN EUREKA HERE ON
MAY THIRD --
MR WESSEL BE PUTTING INFORMATION
OUT ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE --
AS SPECIFIC TIME AND LOCATION
AND WE'LL BE GETTING BACK TO YOU
ON THAT WE HOPE THAT ALL THE
YOU'RE GONNA BE COMING UP.
ACTUALLY THINK SOME OF YOU ARE
GOING TO BE TESTIFYING THERE.
WE WILL BE FOLLOWING UP ON IS --
THE VICE CHAIR YOU KNOW THAT
THAT'S BEEN ATTEMPTED BEFORE BUT
IT'S ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO BE A PROTECTOR.
OF FRESHLY FARMED WILD FISH OFF
OF THE STATE WATERS.
IN OR IN OUR STATE STREAMS I
KNOW THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE --
FOLLOWING UP WITH.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND OUR EYE ON THIS BILL THIS
YEAR YOU'RE ONNA SEE A
STREAMLINED PROCESS WORKING WITH
THE CALLS COMMISSION ON ISSUES
OF AQUACULTURE PERMITTING.
AND BEING ABLE TO SET OUT
GUIDELINES ABOUT WHAT FOLKS ARE
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO HIT AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE REALLY
SHOULD AVOID --
IF YOU WANTED TO BE A TO GET
INTO A STREAMLINED PROCESS HERE
AT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE WILL BE FOLLOWING UP WITH --
THE COMMISSION ON PROPORTIONS ON
AND WE'D LIKE TO BE A TO GET
YOUR FEEDBACK HERE IN THE COMING
MONTHS OF WHAT DOES A FORMULA
LOOK LIKE. FOR A REALISTIC --
INCREASE WHEN IT COMES TO
LANDING FEES.
I ARE WE GONNA TIED TO THE CD AS
CPI WE WE CAN HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH ALL OF YOU I
IN THAT SENSE THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO BE ABLE --
TO FLUSH OUT HERE IN THE IN THE
MONTHS TO COME --
WITH THAT I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH TWO TOM WAS SLOW
TOMMASO DOES SUCH A FABULOUS JOB
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE.
EACH AND EVERY DAY --
AND VERY GRATEFUL FOR EVERYTHING --
THAT HE HAS DONE FOR HIS ENTIRE
CAREER -- IN
ON AN INDIE HERE WITH AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME OUT FOLLOWING
THE LEAD OF THE CAFFERTY
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE.
HI THIS COMMITTEE WILL BE
CONVENING A WORKING GROUP
MEETING --
WITH --
CALIFORNIA CRAB FISHERMEN OUR
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE CAVERN
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND NATURAL RESOURCES --
VICE CHAIR AND I WILL BOTH BE
THERE AND I WOULD LIKE TO BE A
START WORKING WITH MR OPPENHEIM
DEBATE A FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT
WORKING GROUP LOOKS LIKE --
THAT WILL BE MEETING IS WE
MOVING TOWARDS I SEASON I TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE ALL ON THE
SAME PAGE WHAT RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED AND WHAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO --
BUT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WAIT
TILL WE SEE THAT FINAL OUTCOME.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE WORK AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS SERGEANTS
WHO HAVE BEEN WITH US FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING NICE JOB YOU ALL
MY GOODNESS --
AND NO ONE WAS TASERED HERE
TODAY WHICH IS ALWAYS A GOOD
THING SO I I IDEA I'M I'M
KIDDING --
WATCH OUT HEY EVERYBODY THINK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE IN
WILL LOOK FOR TO SENIOR NEXT
YEAR
--